Hello everyone. Welcome to the fifth
applied active inference symposium day
3, November 14, 2025. My name is Zorera
Manad. I'm honored to introduce the
first presenters of today, Steph
McCertie and Andreas Kuloscos.
Uh, presenting money and the free energy
principle. Okay, the stage is yours,
please.
>> Thank you. Uh, thank you to the active
inference institute for hosting this
symposium and having us give this talk.
This is money and the free energy
principle. My name is Steph McCertie.
I'm the head of blockchain research and
education at Wolam research and my
collaborator is Andrew Kulicowskis, PhD
in mathematics who runs maths for
wisdom.
In this presentation, uh, we thought it
would be a good idea for me to share a
little bit about my story and how I
arrived at the active inference
institute. And I'm going to share a
connection that I see in um that I
believe is is true in um free energy
principle and money. and then I'm going
to give it to Andrew to speak a little
bit more about the math of energy,
entropy, and free energy and pull back
the curtain a little bit.
So my story begins around 2014 when I
read these two books back to back and
they kind of set the stage for the next
decade of my two approaches of research.
Um, one direction and was cosmic
evolution by astrophysicist from
Harvard, Eric Chaisan, which kind of
said something along the lines of
um how much free energy is flowing
through a physical system normalized by
mass and time.
And it points to this evolution across
the universe in a direction of
complexity.
And in the other direction on the other
end of the spectrum was this book called
why information grows by Cesar Hidalgo
statistical physicist from MIT. And that
kind of gave me another way of seeing a
similar story which was how do you
measure and determine order and
structure in systems and that kind of
painted a picture of information growth
or entropy minimization.
So, this colored
a spectrum or two two roads for me and
I'm going to just fill in some personal
events over the past 10 years that
helped color this in. So in 2015 I found
Bitcoin and while I didn't understand it
completely technically at the time I
became fascinated by the consensus
mechanism called proof of work which to
me really was the connection between
energy
computation and value.
And
it was interesting because while
reaching this distributed consensus in a
new way, we could organize
uh economies or economics or money and
in different ways and and that gave me
just a sense that we could be looking at
either ends of the spectrum.
In 2017,
I had a a another question that I really
wanted to answer, which was uh about
solar energy. So, I went to work for
Tesla in 2017 to understand a little bit
more about the proliferation of solar
energy and solar panels.
And
it was obvious that in nature, the sun
provides ample free energy. And I
expected the same to be true for our
economy that more of our energy
production would come from the sun. Um
Tesla had an interesting approach which
said
there are constraints and limitations on
the current electrical grid
infrastructure.
Uh to get around that one needs high
free energy density of batteries.
So that colored in another kind of two
points on my spectrum here.
Then in 2020 I learned about Wolram
physics and this was Steven Wolram's
fundamental phys physics project and
Steven Wolram has an approach to physics
which is deeply computational and it's
computation with a capital C. It's how
do you look at simple rules and how do
that how does that lead to emergent
complexity and that filled in a couple
more gaps in my understanding of the
major pillars of physics general
relativity quantum mechanics and
statistical mechanics or he calls uh the
second law of thermodynamics.
So I was seeing this happen. I joined
Wolffrram. I was tasked to lead the
research team at Wolram Blockchain Labs
and there I studied many blockchains,
many consensus protocols and many
cryptocurrencies
and I learned about a new uh blockchain
in 2024 called Ki network which really
captured my attention for two reasons.
It has a novel consensus protocol called
proof of entropy minima which is a
variant of Bitcoin's proof of work and
it has a two token architecture which is
important because money has several
important characteristics and if you
have more than one token you can
separate those characteristics and be
more
uh true to what those characteristics of
might be. So all of my attention uh over
the past year and a half has been on
understanding that more and that led to
um
coming to the active inference institute
a couple of months ago where I met
Andrew. We're both investigating the
math of active inference and we headed
off. Um, Andrew began working for me in
helping me to understand the two token
architecture of Qui Network and the math
of active inference. And we've had a a
wonderful back and forth over the past
couple of months investigating these
things. And so it feels like I've this
is my story and I've been orbiting
around
um the free energy principle. I've been
looking at it from a physical energy
perspective and an informationational
computational perspective and all those
things kind of have brought me to to
want to learn more. So I'm here as an
investigator still on a path and journey
trying to to to learn more. But um I
wanted to say one thing about
technically about Y network and about
the consensus mechanism because it might
show a little bit more about um what we
mean when we say proof of entropy
minima. So this paper in 2023 by Carl
Creeder and Shakara Shashri
um put out the the way that this is
calculated. So proof of Shannon entropy
minimization is what we're speaking
about here. And what we really want to
talk about um at least in the blockchain
world is when Bitcoin is doing its
mining, this is what people refer to.
It's running this secure hash algorithm
with a 256bit
digest.
And this algorithm SHA 256 has an output
of 256 ones and zeros. And so the total
possible state space of any particular
hash is 2 to the 256.
Now what can you do with that? Um well
if you put a simple rule or a simple
constraint on that state space
for example if you look at the number of
consecutive leading zeros in the output
of a SHA 256 hash beyond some threshold
you can start to find interesting
properties and you can use those
properties in a distributed computer.
So, here's an output, 256 bits. I've
colored in the first nine leading zeros,
and that's the
that's what we're measuring. And we say
in this space, 256 bits, the first nine
in this example are zeros. And that lets
us say something like we are going to
quantify that number of bits and remove
them or accumulate them. We're going to
accumulate them from one block to the
next perpetually. And in that way, what
we're doing is we're accumulating
uncertainty and removing it. And that's
the sense in which we're talking about
proof of Shannon entropy minimization.
That's a lot of words, but what does it
look like visually? Here is the output
of 5,000 STA 256 outputs in integer
form.
And as you can tell, there's not much
signal here. But when you
uh impose a constraint like this simple
rule consecutive leading zeros, you can
start to see that we get this uh kind of
hierarchy of events uh that some events
are rarer than others. And you can use
that fact
to sequence events in a hierarchy.
And that can be used as setting a
certain time interval in a distributed
computer.
Uh because there's there's not one
global clock in this distributed
computer. And so being able to get into
the nuance of establishing a frequency
or a time interval in several levels
really gives us this hierarchical
ordering which means we can establish
when uh one output is greater than
another. And that can lead to
establishing a dominant blockchain and a
subordinate blockchain. And that's
important because we can distribute the
algorithm in any geography and get the
same statistical results off of it. So
we're lifting some statistical
properties out of this distribution of
work and um pi network takes this to its
uh as far as I can tell takes it to its
limit and just really extends and and
expresses that idea to um to scale to it
to a large degree.
And so the rule is simple. It is the
change in entropy is the number of
states removed from one block to the
next. But it's a small difference that
makes all the difference.
And I just want to say one last thing.
The other important fact about P network
is that it is a two token architecture.
And this is important because in the
characteristics of money like store
value, medium of exchange and unit of
account, if all of those are lumped into
a single token, it makes that token uh
carry a lot of burden. And when you
separate the characteristics of money,
you get around something called
Gresham's paradox, which simply states
that if you've designed a global
decentralized monetary system to to make
a superior form of money, let's say in
this case it's Bitcoin, could be gold,
the participants are incentivized to
hoard that money. And that's in direct
tension with another characteristic of
of a monetary system, which is if you're
hoarding, you're not exchanging. And so
it diminishes that value. So it's
important that we kind of pull apart
these characteristics. And in this
network, because we're measuring
entropy, we are playing with the idea of
calling theqi token an entropy measure.
and we're calling y an free energy
measure. So there's something here to
play with. Um and um it's still in
pursuit. But with that said, I want to
pause there and let Andruse uh take the
reigns here and speak about the math of
energy, free energy, and entropy.
Andrew,
>> thank you. uh Steph
uh and thank you to the active inference
institute. Uh we Steph and I met through
the active inference institute. So I
recommend if you want to meet people um
that's the place to go and I am always
interested in meeting people because I
lead a investigatory community math for
wisdom. So um check that out. Uh and so
thank you Steph for all of your uh
lifelong insights and intuitions. It's a
wealth uh that uh brought you to Chi and
Quai and brought you as an investigator
to try to make sense, you know, does
this work? Could it work? Should it
work? What would that look like? What's
the structure? And that brought you to
active inference because as you said,
there's these two currencies. One that
seems related to entropy and scarcity,
the quai, another that's related to
energy, the cost of electricity. um and
that's chi and what's the natural
relationship between that in an economy.
So this uh slide uh shows the summary of
what I want to talk about which is um
this equation relating energy equals
free energy plus entropy. And so of
course free energy is active inferenc's
um valuable asset or and so we're um
that's why we're here and so this
formula is very good and I've always
wanted to understand it better. So uh my
theme is that um and this was said by
Carl Fristen uh quoting um Richard
Fineman at keynote address that uh uh if
I create it I can understand it which
kind of means like a lot of times I'm
not understanding things I'm not able to
create them. So some things I will tell
you I know and some things I'll tell you
I don't know. Um so the summary is that
to explain this mathematical equation
um and then to uh explain in terms of uh
cryptocurrency the distinction between
belief in an economic system and belief
in belief in the economic system. Those
are the themes. And then uh I have a PhD
in math but specifically algebraic
combinatorics which is the math for
counting things. But really what it
means is if you look at an algebraic
equation, can you say what it's actually
trying to tell us? You know, what is
actually it it what what does it mean
really? You know, so the way I write
these equations, uh I write them out
like this. And if you'll see the entropy
term has a q of x and a log of 1 over q
ofx, but the energy term has a q of x
and a log of 1 / p of x comm y. These
are probability distributions. And the
main theme of my um comments is that um
here they're different but if you made
this equal to q of x then you would get
entropy.
So if you this kind of leads to the
theme that entropy is a sort of
degenerate energy and so now let me talk
about uh energy. I mean first I'll talk
about entropy and then I'll talk about
energy. So let's rethink these things.
And uh you may have seen this formula
for entropy. I've always been curious
like why does it have a minus sign?
Becomes very hard on my mind. Uh so uh
it turns out that negative of a log is
just log of 1 / q ofx. So first of all,
you'll always see me writing this
because I'm allergic to negative signs
unless they really have a purpose. Okay,
so this is my personal allergy. Um
another thing is that and Steph saw that
this is important. Q of X appears in two
places. That's like one actor in two
roles. Okay. So it's important to be not
confused. You know that they're playing
two very different roles. One will be
knowledge gain and the other one will be
the knowledge lens. So you can see
there's a distinction here between an
observer and an observe. The knowledge
lens is uh all about the expected value
and that's coming from an observer
looking at everything through a lens of
different probabilities they're
assigning or sometimes they're called
different weights. But what are they
looking at? Well, they're taking the
expected value of this term which is the
knowledge gained. Okay, why is that the
knowledge gained? Well, this is a way of
writing and so let's remember that this
is a probability distribution. So that
means that these values you know x can
be cat or whatever the probability of
cat will be a number maybe like 30%. Uh
but or you know o comma 3 uh or o3 if
you're American I got living in 0. So uh
q of x is going to be greater than um
equal to zero and less than or equal to
one. Now if you're very astute uh um uh
you'll note that uh if this is zero this
is going to be a big problem because one
over zero is against the law. So um but
here this could be zero. So all of a
sudden we're seeing that these two roles
start to imply different things that in
the case of what I call the observed um
you're not allowed to have zero
probability. I mean nature wants it to
be there or just don't talk about it.
Okay. But from the point of the
observer, you're in control. You can
carve things up. You can say, "Hey,
nothing happened here. I'm observing."
Okay? So, there's a huge qualitative
difference and we pick up on this by
caring about these things. So, let's go
back to say this is a positive number
and it's less than uh one. Okay? Less
than or equal to. If it was one that
means you're certain then it would be
one over one. That's one. Log of one is
zero. So when you're certain the entropy
is zero, there's no I mean not the
entropy but this part is zero and the
knowledge gained is zero. So that's that
makes sense. No knowledge gained if
you're certain. Um but otherwise like
let's say this is 1/2. One over 1/2 is
going to be two. And you can see that
whatever this fraction is but if you
flip it over it's going to be bigger
than one. And when you take a log of
something that's bigger than one is
going to be bigger than zero. Okay. So
these are positive numbers. So negative
log of q of x is actually a positive
number. Okay, that's the that's one
point. And so let's look more
specifically and we're going to be
working in log base 2 because it's these
probabilistic choices, you know, this or
that. That's comfortable, but we could
be working in other logs. But if you
look at 1 over 1/8. So 1/8 is a
probability. You flip this over, it
becomes log 2 of 8. 8 is 2 * 2 * 2. We
write it as 2 to the 3. And then um log
base that is just pulling down that
exponent. It's three. Okay. So, and that
means that you have three choices. So,
like 1/8 would be the probability of
flipping a coin three times and getting
something specific like tails and then
tails and then head.
Well, that's basically three bits of
information. That's three choices,
binary choices. So, that's three units
of knowledge gained. Um and so when we
rethink of entropy, we see that all
these numbers are positive. Everything
here is positive. Uh and then oh let's
look at this knowledge lens and you just
talk about that. So you could your
knowledge lens could be how you're
looking at the world. Let's say you're
looking planetarywise and let's say it's
very crude but you're going to say look
it's one quarter land and three quarters
water. Okay. So if you want to talk
about the ruggedness or smoothness of
the planet, you'd say, well, 3/4 is very
smooth and then one quarter is
ruggedness. So it puts things in
perspective. But it could be, let's say,
one quarter youth, 3/4 adults. Okay?
Then you want to look at the loudness of
music that's preferred at a festival.
You could balance it in like that. Or it
could be like the relationship between
me and everybody else. So it could be
like one quarter me in terms of how
we're feeling and three/4ers everybody
else. More likely it's more like three
quarters me, one quarter the rest of
you. Um so that's how it's balanced. So
these are examples. You can see how then
that would you know then you can
actually calculate a case. Uh so let's
say it's let's put together these
knowledge lenses. So let's say it's one
quarter. Oh to do entropy. You see,
these are both the same thing, but
they're in different situations. So 1/4
and you flip over the 1 over 4, that'd
be four. 1/4 * log uh 2 of 4 plus, let's
say 3/4 log 2, you flip over the 3/4s,
you get 4/3. So if we calculate it out,
uh 4 is 2 * 2. So log 2 of 4 is 2. 1/4 *
2. Uh log 2 of 4 over 3, that's
basically roughly 40%, which is 2 over
5. I just made it I like fractions so I
wrote it like that times three quarters.
Okay. So the knowledge lens is the first
fraction and then the the knowledge
gained the surprising. So in the case of
the one quarter like it's more
surprising you know you get two in terms
of the land part but the water part's
less surprising. That's two-fifths of
surprise on on on that end. So and then
three quarters is how often you have
that and you put it all together one
quarter * 2 that would be like 1/2. I
can write 10 20th 3/4 * 2- fifths that'd
be 620ths. You can add it up and you can
see like who contributed more entropy.
Actually, it was the land that
contributed more entropy because if it
was only one quarter, but it contributed
a lot of surprise. Okay, so the land
contributed more. The rarer one
contributed more entropy. These building
blocks the the water there's three
quarters water but it's just not as
surprising. So it's not collecting as
much entropy. And so this is the
expected value of knowledge gained. The
knowledge gained from the land is two.
Like wow, something happened. Knowledge
gained from the sea, like if an asteroid
hits into the sea, it's oh well, not
such a big deal. Not not not such big
news. So that's two-fifths. Um so but
the chance of it happening, this
asteroid falling on land or water, well
3/4 chance it's going to fall there, one
quarter there. So you're kind of adding
it up. And then maybe something I'll be
talking about it's interesting this
relationship uh 10 to six right 10 over
20 to 6 over 20 we'll be looking at that
okay how that changes so why don't we do
that why don't we go to the next slide
because we're so into entropy we really
want to understand it because you'll see
I really I actually don't understand it
so and I think it's a secret probably
like no one really understands it and
we'll we'll try to show that why but
it's uh entropy is ambiguity though I
think that part I kind of understand
because and entropy means that um
um well from a physicist point of view
and I have a bachelor's degree in
physics it means that you have more
possible configurations that will give
you the same result okay so it becomes
like a combinatorial thing so it's very
it's very that part that part's
ambiguity and doubling entropy is
something conceivable kind of
straightforward let's do that and so
we'll look at a specific case let's say
there's n equal prob probabilities each
with 1 / n and n * 1 / n equals 100% is
1. Okay, so the formula for entropy
becomes this. Um you've you're summing
over all the possibilities and each of
these building blocks has the
probability in front which is 1 / n
times log 2 of 1 over the probability
which is 1 over 1 over n. And you'll
flip this over you'll get n. Okay, so
let's look at it concretely. And we did
this one. So eight times, but see now
there's eight of them because we've got,
you know, that was just a a separate
building block, but now we're going to
have all eight building blocks. And what
you'll notice is that the 8 * 1/8
cancel. So when everything's very
uniform,
there's nothing really contributed by
the knowledge lens to entropy. It's kind
of saying like we're we roll out, we're
not, you know, we're not affecting the
knowledge gain because we're just very
neutral. We're so neutral, we're not
going to really affect knowledge gain.
So it's all left to the log 2 of 8. But
you'll see that okay log 2 of 8 we saw
it was three. If we do it with 64 which
is 8 squared 64 you'll get again 1 over
64. That part cancels. That's just all
neutral. It's 64 equal probabilities
each with 1 over 64 chance. Okay. You'll
look at the log 2 of 64. This is the
knowledge gained. That's 2 to the 6
because it's 8 * 8 um 8 squar 2 or it's
u 2 cubed * 2 cubed so that's 2 to the 6
so it's going to be six and so you can
see it doubled okay so the lessons is is
that in this particular case when
everything's very neutral there's a the
knowledge lend is you know has equal
probabilities um then the only
contribution is from the s what they
what what we call surprise I call
knowledge gained um and that in order to
double it, you really have to square it.
Okay, so that's a big deal. Like you
have to square it if you want to double
the entropy. If you want to double the
knowledge gained and so basically like
if you threw a coin three times, you got
to throw a coin three more times. Okay?
And then so that'll be squaring. So like
the entropy if if you did a thousand
computations or choices, let's say,
right? And you want to double the
entropy, you got to go up to a million.
Okay. Or if you want to go up from a
million, you got to go up to not a
billion, but a trillion, right? Like, so
doubling entropy is not something you
would want to ever do really, you know,
especially not in that type of Shaw 56
game, you know, where it's all uniform.
Okay, so doubling's clear. Now, what
about having though? Okay, because not
everything's uniform. And so if you go
backwards, okay, you can go backwards
from 64 to 8, 8 to, you know, uh, well,
let's say we go to four to two and
whatever. So you get to two. How do you
go have that? Right? Like where do you
go? Right? So that's this diagram. If
you only have two choices, one will have
probability um x and the other one will
probably have 1 minus x. So like if x is
10%, then the other one would be 90%.
Right? And so you add this up. This will
be x over log of 2 1/x. This will be 1 -
x. Log 2 of 1 over 1 - x. Right?
Well, you can play around with that. And
I drew this blue graph to show that
because I don't know how to solve that
and I don't think anybody knows how to
solve this type of thing. Um,
unfortunately, but we can graph it with
my Excel spreadsheet. That's my computer
of choice. And so then, um, or actually
I use Open Office Calc. I can't afford
Excel. So 0 to 100%. Um, and then uh,
the entropy goes up to one. Okay. So 12
log 2 of 2 + 12 log 2 of two uh log 2 of
two is 1. 1/2 + 1/2 is one. Do you can
believe me on that if that was too fast
for you? But the question is okay this
will go down. So that's the peak. So
kind of makes sense. Maximum ambiguity
when both probabilities are the same.
Now we could get half the entropy. I'm
sorry maximum yeah entropy maximum
ambity. We could get half the entropy if
we were willing to skew it. Okay. And it
turns out that happens at 1 nth. So it's
1 nth this way, 8 9th that way for some
magical unknown reason. But that 1:8
ratio and this is approximate, you know,
it's it's these are real numbers. So but
I try I like fractions. So 1 nth to 8
9ths. Uh that is when this goes by two.
And so I made this whole thing like if
you want to go half again it'd be to get
1/4 it'd be 124th to 23 24ths. you know
1/8 157 uh you know 158 to 5758 and you
can see the sequence going down and so
that is a fascinating sequence um and
these integers are not known I mean
they're not in the encyclopedia of
integer sequences okay so that means
that this is treading new ground right
but you could see this one attention
because like in order to have the
ambiguity that means that you somehow
are able to skew things to get half
Okay. And if we saw um and if you want
to say well who's who's got the
ambiguity part right like is it in this
A or is it in the B part right so if A
is the one ninth part or is it in the B
part? Well it's um 2.3
of this will be 2.3 to 1. Okay. But when
you go to 124th it's going to be 3.2 to
1 and then 4.1 to one and five 4. Now
this is very nice because you know
instead of these huge numbers growing
like this is growing slow first of all.
So when you want to like we were
doubling you know like when we were
going up to double the entropy we're
just going out like crazy. But now all
of a sudden we're just getting a
slightly more certainty by saying we're
going to have a slightly smaller
percentage and then a slightly smaller
percentage and then we're going to feel
like the knowledge gained by having is
going to be halfed. Let's see. I got to
be careful. the expected knowledge gain
let's say the expected knowledge gain we
have so very curious but this almost
looks like the integers but these aren't
integers and of course you know these
are rounded uh so but these aren't
integers so there's a whole world I call
these invisible numbers okay and so
that's what's coming up so I went too
long on this but now you feel like you
don't know entropy and I don't know
entropy we're we're even okay so let's
talk about energy then so energy um I
also don't know about energy um but I I
know that there's Boltzman's
distribution and it relates probability
to energy and energy states. And so I
think the crucial thing I kind of
figured out reading this is that at
equilibrium. Okay, so if you've got a
system at equilibrium and it turns out
this is a theme first step, but like
that's useless. Okay, so in the useless
case, which is kind of like the default
case, like the death of the universe
case, it's just a a uniform temperature
and you just can't get a hold of it.
just things bouncing around sharing that
energy and they're just okay. So in that
case
um you can tell how all the energy
states are going to distribute
themselves and then you can look at the
sum. So each energy state would be this
separate thing. You can look at the sum
that's called the canonical partition
function. I'm so awesome. And so then if
you take that percentage that's a
probability.
I am going to do a little trick here.
This is called Z a lot of times, but I'm
going to just put in this uh cur curly E
to say really you can just not ignore
this Z if you just put in this curly E,
you know, because it'll be E to the
it's just another E factor basically.
Just convert this number. It's a number
and you just convert it to that kind of
number and you so the point of that is
that it's like a ground state energy.
Okay. So will will you know so e to the
i minus epsilon is just recalibrating
the energy to a ground state. You're
just ch moving it up or down you know to
so that you don't worry about. So that's
the first thing we'll do. Now let's look
at what that means then in terms of
flipping it around like because we want
to know the energy. So if we flip it
around we go okay let's take the log
that get rid of the e right. So now the
log is equal to this difference of
energies over uh Boltzman's constant
times the temperature. Well negative
we've already seen how to handle that.
It's the log of 1 over p to the i p subi
and that'll be that. So wow we got our
knowledge gained. We see that it's a
difference in energy compared to the
base energy and divided by temperature.
So I'll be writing like energy divided
by temperature etc. and it makes things
more messy but it's basically true but
actually you can this is just a
multiplicative constant you can get rid
of it if you introduce this number B and
these just numbers you know so you can
introduce it like this um and you put E
to this Boltzman constants times the
temperature it's all flipped over that
can be the base for your logarithm and
so if you just say look I'm not going to
work in uh natural logarithms I'm going
to work with this log with this case
okay then the whole thing goes away okay
so and it's really not temperature it's
one over temperature and it's you know
got this constant in it so one over
temperature is in a certain sense more
natural coldness is more natural than
warmness because coldness when things
are cold and there that means they're
moving around very slowly uh they're
much more receptive to energy they're
actually more adaptive like you give it
a little bit of energy and it will give
a lot of flexibility a lot more increase
in ambiguity which is to increase a lot
of increase in possibilities if you just
give it a little energy. So like in the
human body, everything's slowed down.
That's the point. Everything's
controlled, right? So that you give it a
little bump and things could happen in
different directions. That's really the
the derivative of um of uh entropy
versus energy. That's the way you really
want to talk about. So you really want
to talk about like one over temperature,
but you can think of that as the
interface. Um, and and that'll that's
maybe I'll say more about that later,
but it's really just the interface like
you're playing with the speed of things.
So, you know, if you want things to be
just play with the speed of time, so to
speak, that'll change the temperature to
hot or cold or whatever. Okay, that's
just a maybe not so important. But see,
basically, if we do that, then we can
take we don't just have then the
information gain, the knowledge gained,
but we have the expected value. So let's
take the same probability and let's take
the expected value and that'll be the
expected value of energy. Okay. So when
we say energy sometimes we mean a single
state but we some like look over all the
states. Now if you look over all the
states with the same probability well
then you're getting entropy. So expected
energy is entropy. Okay. But that's
because we're at equilibrium.
Okay. So that's a crucial thing about
Boltzman's distribution is that it's not
really it's it's like when you have this
special case the default case where like
um uh we're going to look through the
knowledge lens of our probably like
we're in our own messy room and it's
just I I don't know what to say like
it's as messy as it's ever going to be
like there's no one there's no mother to
make us clean it up let's say there's
nobody to we're just ourselves right our
natural selves kind of drift to this
state where like um it's just like that
so but in in disequilibrium. You see,
we're going to make these different.
We're going to say no, our mother came
or our father came to be more maybe to
blame our fathers, not our mothers,
let's say. And then they said, oh no,
you can't, you know, what are you doing?
Right? So, that's the expected energy. I
expect you to clean it up. That's right.
So, this tension. Okay. So, now let's
get to what we're talking about because
we're so smart and so ready. Um, we want
to explain this equation down here,
which I introduced us with. It turns out
it's super easy to derive. Okay, but I
think conceptually boris because we're
going to just start here comparing these
two probability distributions and this
line is says it all. It's just so
trivial. It's so trivial you won't
understand it. So I'm going to give a
little story to help you understand how
trivial this is. The story is that it's
a dialogue between two people. I think
Steph says that's maybe the easiest way
to understand like me and Steph, right?
And so uh but I like for me it's just
more visceral two minds the unconscious
and the conscious. Okay. And so a lot of
times in active influence we see the X
and the Y. The Y is the evidence. And I
think of that as the sensory mind. Okay.
And a lot of times we write it for P. We
don't write it for Q because P is the
probability distribution that's tapping
into that sensory evidence. Okay. But
there's also inferred causes, right?
Like so maybe the evidence is that there
was a shadow but the inferred cause is
that I'm walking under a tree right so
um so the unconscious notices everything
right but the conscious may not care
about the shadow but cares about the
tree because I don't want to walk into
the tree right I don't mind walking into
the shadow big deal so uh so then I have
this dialogue between these two so the
unconscious mind is like 100 billion
neurons giving me all these answers you
know every single pixel Right?
Everyone's got an answer. They're all
pandemonium as they call it. But I'm
trying to compress that and this is all
I know. I know all these things. But I'm
trying to say no. It's smarter to think
in terms of what I don't know. Tell me
Andrew like what you don't know about
entropy. Right? Get to the point. What
you don't know about energy. Right? So I
boil that down to 100,000 black boxes,
cortical columns, um questions, words.
Every word is something I don't know.
Like so if I say horse, I'm really
saying what is a horse? And then the
other mind tells me, oh here's a picture
of a horse, here's a fact about a horse,
here's a horse, you know, etc. So what
we have here, and this is like a
autoenccoder, and this is from the '9s
when I was at school at UCSD. Um, you
compress
all, and this is something a computer
could do on its own even back in the
90s. It could say, look, the computer
doesn't have to be trained. It's just
going to try to randomly, you know, by
trial by error compress things. It's
going to compress them and decompress
them. and it's going to see how it
happens. So, it's going to compress this
information into this language that's
more sparse and and pure and it's going
to decompress it, de decode it, encode
and decode. Did it get the same thing
back? If it did, that's valid. Was that
a better compression than what you had
before? Okay, so that's a typical game.
And so the idea is that I have a chasm
an abyss between the mind that knows
which is basically representing the
whole world which is basically like you
know my unconscious just tapped into my
body tapped into the world on the other
side I have a mind divorced from the
world you see how I like I'm abstract
thinker whatever I just have no clue
right but by being a tricky question
thinker you know embracing my not
knowledge we work it out we got the same
information two forms now so imagine
that dialogue and now let's say okay
I've got the sensory information.
I can use my conscious mind to slip it
in here and break it up into two
factors. Okay, Q compared to P and then
just one over Q, you know, so I can
multiply by one. I can multiply by Q on
top and Q on the bottom. I can do that,
but it mentally breaks this up into two
different things. And that is it. Okay,
that's all it is. It's just a slick
using of the Q to break things up. I can
take the log, it makes it additive. So
instead of multiplying, I'm summing,
which can be nice. I do my thing where I
flip everything upside down, right? So Q
over P is the same as 1 over P over Q
because I want to understand what I'm
reading, right? I want to be able to
create it. So if I write it this way, I
say, oh, that's knowledge gain. That's
knowledge gain. That's knowledge gain.
But there are different knowledge gains.
This is Q of X. This is P of X, comma Y.
This is how they compare.
And now I say, now I'm going to add my
knowledge lens to the whole thing.
So now with the energy and this is
obviously disequilibrium you know the
the observed world the sensory world is
the knowledge gained but the knowledge
lens how the observer is looking at it
is the Q of X it's the conscious is
observing the unconscious right and when
you do that though when you play this
game um and when you break things up
like that you're going to get two parts
and that's the interesting part like
you're going to get a useful term term
and a useless term you're going to get a
disequilibrium term where you can
actually do work because there's this
tension I can clean up my room and
there's going to be the lazy day where I
don't okay so there's lazy and is you
know you can't have and clean up his
room if you don't allow for lazy and
that's the law of the universe right so
so that's basically what this is saying
and so you can do the same type of thing
here uh maybe just to go back so the
free energy is saying okay my father
wants me to clean my room How does that
look like to me? Okay, that's the free
energy. How does it look like to me? I
don't see I I don't see the notion of
cleanliness. That's like where did that
come from? And here's the here's the
total picture of it. Okay, where it's
not about me, it's about reality.
Cleanliness is a real thing. Okay,
but here it's like how I look at
cleanliness. And then here's just me.
Okay, so now we're going to say you know
you can take this equation which is more
common you know with the free princ you
can break it up into divergence and
knowledge gained or also known as
surprisal um I'm no longer surprised
I'll just call it knowledge gained so um
but it's just this formula here P of X
comma Y you know we're looking at two
things the evidence and the knowledge um
inferred
um
uh state you know so be a state or an
action whatever
It's if you're not familiar with this
notation when you when you have the
probability of two things it's just the
probability of the one let's say the
evidence plus given the evidence what's
the probability of the other okay the
the cause. So it's probability of the
shadow and then given the shadow what's
probability of the tree. Okay you just
break that up now. And then if you just
do that you flip everything over and
then you've got the free energy breakup.
And there's other breakups I think it
would just work the same. If you
noticed, lazy and didn't use basis
theorem. Basis theorem would say, well,
P of X given Y * P of Y equals P of Y
over given X time P of X, right? And
then you can flip over and you can say,
well, then you can say, you know, we
want to do priors and we want to do it,
but we can't. It's all intractable and
so we're going to flip it all over. So,
we use basis theorem, etc., etc. There's
a whole story. Lazy Andress said, well,
lazy Andress and the Andrus, the Fineman
Andress said, look, if I can't create, I
don't understand it. I was trying to
create all that and I just got this and
lazy said why do you need all that right
that's the problem with me so let's now
apply this to cryptocurrency
uh we worked hard time trying to make
sense of coin chi and etc and what's the
point and the c the cool thing is is
that um it's um question of like does it
make sense to have two currencies and
you can see just like energy has kinetic
energy and potential energy where
kinetic energy is kind of useless it's
the energy of moving things around
bumping into each other. Potential
energy says there's like a unifying
thing that everyone can respond to. It's
not local. It's a global thing like my
father. So um uh just like in that way
you can have two currencies and in
particular the particular problem with
Bitcoin because there's only one
currency it's priced in the dollar. So
if the goal of this in Steve uh Steph's
heart is to uh say hey can we have a
civilization a world where um it has a
economic currency that's not um
um that's that that that's not depending
on fiat currency. It's not this current
system. Can we have an independent
system that's not dependent on nation
states and powers etc. Right? Well then
it's got to be able to price itself. So
it does kind of need two currencies.
Right? It shouldn't be priced in the
dollar or whatever. Um, and so there's a
need, but on the other hand, like in
order to get people to want to support
this, they really want to win, you know,
by mining and things like that or
investing or whatever, they need a
currency that allows them to speculate,
but we also need a currency for everyday
things. Well, this comes at a cost.
Okay, so if you're not familiar, like
Bitcoin mining, uh, I think LA recently,
it's like $20 billion a year. Okay, so
$20 billion a year just up in smoke in
electricity costs. It's huge. Now what
are you getting for that? You're getting
a $2 trillion economy. Okay, so that
becomes an interesting ratio. Okay, like
but per year like so 1% per year you
have to devote just to go up and smoke
but then you get this $2 trillion
economy which is not a joke. So that
ratio became very interesting like what
does that mean? And we compared that uh
to the price in dollars. And this is
long because you as you can see it it
starts at $1, $10, $100, $1,000, 10,000,
and at the very top it's $100,000, which
is like the current price for Bitcoin,
changing as I speak. So if you do a log
chart, you can see like there's ups and
there's downs, but like that up is a
huge up and that down is a huge down,
right? I mean, it went from a thousand
down to maybe 200, right? it went from
10, you know, 15,000 down to maybe, you
know, 6,000 or something, you know. So,
it's going up like that. What you'll
notice, uh, if you look at that ratio,
mining cost market cap, it swings, you
know, so it goes down to 2%, it goes up
to, uh, 7% and then down to 2% and 6%
and so on. It's swinging up and down.
Now a very curious thing is that when
this mining cost is high comparing to
market cap I mean which means lots of
people are spending a lot of money
mining right compared to what it's
actually supporting okay that's when the
price is down so there's a curious thing
like when the price is and you kind of
make sense you know we saw this whole
the the the econ the economy of bitcoin
being this that there has to be an even
rate of creating these bitcoins if and
it's a contest it's these lottery
tickets like Steph was showing you When
there's a lot of people wanting to get
the lottery ticket, the lottery ticket
has to be hard to get and becomes
increasingly, you know, exponentially
harder. And when there's not a lot of
people, they got to make it easy so that
people would mine it because they need a
steady rate of these bitcoins being
created one every 10 minutes or so.
Okay, gi maybe one every 5 seconds. So,
uh, that type of thing. So,
uh, what's the connection? Okay, and I
really don't know. I don't know. But um
it's about the cost of doing business I
suspect. So if you want a civilization
then you know you look at the Egyptian
primitives pyramids let's say what is
that all about? It may just simply be
the cost of doing business. Like if you
want to have a well functioning
civilization you say look we're going to
build pyramids right there's got to be
no reason for that. It's just simply
that that's how we organize ourselves.
Okay. And if that's 10% but that can
elevate everyone's standard of living
why not right? our um society is built
on fiat money, the Federal Reserve
system. There's these obligations to
have exponential growth in uh currenc in
in in in economic value. Like it's, you
know, we got to grow by 2 or 3% a year.
Uh which is obviously unsustainable, but
we're forced to do that. And if you
can't do that, then you have to go uh
find a ghetto where you can uh have
victims and then you can sign them up
for telephone plans that they never
ordered and things like that. So you
have to have uh what some presidents
call some kind of countries, let's say.
You just have to have all kinds of
horrible things in order to have this
moral cast system, you know, and to have
that, you know, where everyone can look
down on somebody and not be so unhappy
about themselves that I'm a
telemarketer, but I don't use drugs, you
know, I use drugs, but I buy them with
money, you know, etc. So horrible thing.
That's part of the cost of a
civilization, you see. Now, what if we
didn't have to have, you know, wars and
uh, you know, 5% military expenses,
whatever. What if we just could make our
own money, right? Okay. So, we burn it
up in smoke. Okay. So, maybe that's not
the best system, but maybe it's better
than what we have, right? I think that's
an important thing to say. So, this cost
of doing business um, and then it what
it becomes, this is kind of like one of
my concluding thoughts or maybe my few
thoughts about cryptocurrency, but is
this distinction between belief in the
system and belief in belief in the
system. So the sensory system believes
in the world there's something there's
an answer I got it but see these miners
they believe more there's no economy
there like you know in she inquire when
bitcoin started out there's no no
there's nothing being used but people
believe that they should be mining it
because they believe this thing has a
future they believe that there's
something there in on it okay they drank
the Kool-Aid okay so it's belief and
belief in the system so like with our
active inference community you can drink
the Kool-Aid and then you're like these
miners and you're saying yeah I'm going
you know, okay, so that's that's in an
early stage. You know, people drink the
Kool-Aid, they set this up, they invest
millions of dollars in a new community
currency,
but then what happens? Maybe some miners
say, "Hey, this is I'm not getting
anywhere with this or I just stop
believing, but they got a bunch of coins
left that they have to." So maybe those
coins, they try to get something with
them. So now they believe in the system.
They believe that there's these coins.
They just don't believe it's worth
mining, right? Or it's not their
problem. Now in a healthy economy,
everyone just believes in the money.
Let's say, you know, I believe in
dollars, but I don't believe that money
is the point of life. But like I
believe, okay, I'll function with
dollars or or euros or whatever
currency. I believe in the system. I
don't necessarily believe in the belief
in the system. And so it's kind of like
with acceleration versus velocity. If
you you know, you throw a ball up in the
air, there's a certain point which just
hangs, right? Like it has no velocity,
but there's acceleration. Okay? So
that's like starting an economy. like
there's no point to it. There's nothing
being exchanged, right? But there's
acceleration. People are investing in it
and then the question is it shifts over
like is there a real economy or not?
That becomes the question. So that's
very little said about cryptocurrency
but I think it's you but you think like
we we'll have a discussion maybe there's
more said than there but I did say a lot
about um the math of active inference. I
gave an alternative approach. Okay. So
we both with the customary approach we
both agree okay there's a distinction
between evidence and inferred causes
let's say right y and x but you see uh
in the traditional customary orthodox um
model there's a generative model and
it's predictive and then q of x is just
an approximation just an approximation
you see whereas in my case it's like
look uh q of x is the whole point the
whole point is to have a dialogue right
the whole point is to have your own mind
right so it's this these should be
different and if Q of X was a perfect
approximation that's like encoding
yourself with yourself you know one to
one with the same alphabet would be
absolutely useless so to call it an
approximation is to suggest that a
perfect one would be great you know
which is but that would be absolutely
useless so and then to say approximation
is it only serves this and so then also
for historical reasons I think this is
for historical reasons the generative
model was considered the predictive
model. So we have to predict where all
these shadows are instead of saying why
would I predict where shadows are? No,
I'm just going to predict where trees
are, right? So why do I have to care
about shadows? So this X in my like X
would be really actions. What are the
possible actions? So I'm stumbling
around the dark and then here's all the
information of what I should be doing,
you know? So I'm poking my head around.
I've got concepts. I've got
conceptualization swing around and I'm
trying to so this X really is my sensory
information saying look your arm moved
you've got neurons telling you your arm
moved or you can't move or whatever it
is and there's some kind of mystery you
know magical combination why these two
things divorced with each other somehow
they look at their relationships somehow
they're able to communicate or you can
believe in the optimization ferryy okay
so the free energy principle saying oh
there's all these approximations out
there but the optimization fairy is
going to pick the one that has minimal
free energy, you know, by blah blah or
maximum free energy. I always get
confused. It's going to do that. You
see, so you can choose two stories
narratives. And so they talk about like
if you notice in the math, there's no
markoff boundaries. There's no markoff
anything. There's no I mean I the
beautiful idea of free of active
inference is that you have action
perception loops. You can update you
know when there's something off you can
update your model. You can update the
world. But none of that is here. None of
it as far as I can see. So, uh, there is
a gap though between these two. So,
these are two ways of looking at it.
That's my conclusion. U, I hand it over
to you, Steph.
>> Thank you, Andrew. That was, uh, I mean,
you covered some serious ground. And,
uh, thanks for filling in a few of the
the gaps that I forgot to add in. Um,
so there's a question in chat that I
wanted to make sure that you got to
answer which was what does it mean that
entropy is a degenerate entropy?
>> Uh, yeah. So it's just maybe my mind is
degenerate. Maybe that's entropy. Yeah,
it's a degenerate energy. Right. So if I
go back,
you can see my slides, right?
>> Correct.
>> Let's go back to the very beginning.
what I wanted to
show.
See this looks just like that, right? I
got I mean they have the same form if
you write this way. Q of X and P of X
comma Y Q q of X and Q ofX. So all I'm
saying is that if you picked P of X
comma Y to be Q of X, you know, you
could pick it to be all kinds of things,
but if you picked it to be Q of X, then
you would get entropy. And so what that
means in practice is that um there's a
useless way of looking at things in
terms of getting things done or working
or whatever. It's like if you pick the
window for the window you're going to
pick on the world is going to be the
window that you're of how you look at
things in the world, right? The the
window you're looking upon the world is
the window that you're informing
yourself like of your reality, right?
Like if you're talking to yourself in
this way, you're not going to get
anywhere
special basically. You're just kind of
like u you're just like bumping around
against yourself. Okay? You're just
you're just at equilibrium. You're not
going it's not going to change you maybe
to say like that. It's just going to
keep you who you are. You're not going
to clean your room because of that.
Okay? So maybe if you're looking for
self-motivation
and this is maybe related to Alex
Kefir's thing is like well how would
this relate to selfm motivation? We can
see external motivation operating. Oh,
so there's a third level I would say
would be expected free energy. You see
the the orthodox church of you know
active inference if I can consider
myself a member you know is is that in
order to compare policies you have to go
back into the sensory world and imagine
okay if this is going to be a shadow and
this is going to be a shadow here etc
etc this is bizarre no if I was going to
compare policies I would want to
compress yet again instead of 10 you
know 100 thousand concepts I'd want to
have maybe 10 different parameters that
I could compare against to say Maybe
this is about speed. Maybe this is about
decision-making. Maybe this is about
morality. Maybe this is about
friendship. I don't know, you know. So,
that would be how I would be wanting to
get it down to not saying like, well, do
I like the smell of this cheese or
something? That's a very strange. See,
that's why I call it a religion because
those things are baked in because Carl
Fristen looks at the world this way and
we're just kind of going along and I
just think that that's science fiction.
It's fanfiction. That's my personal
belief. I can make up my own fanfiction
and then we can have two fanfictions and
then we can talk about a science that
distinguishes between science fictions.
So, I don't know if I answered that very
well.
>> Thank you.
Do we have uh what four minutes to wrap
up? Daniel,
>> you can make any last comments or stuff.
I was just curious what is the
uncertainty that's being reduced about
what to whom?
because the zero stacking up at the
beginning of a hashing algorithm to me
that's like flipping lots of 100 coins
and then if you get 50 um heads or 80
heads or whatever the the threshold is
you just keep that lot and you discard
the hashes that didn't get it. So, I
don't know if that process ever updates
any beliefs that I have other than just
the the um hypothetically nonforgeable
work of flipping those batches of coins.
So, what do the zeros leading up or
other kinds of hash plays lead to
actually how do you see that in terms of
belief updating and uncertainty
reduction in something?
>> Yeah. Well, a good question and let's
see if I can hit it.
The it's it's essentially establishing
kind of this like arbitrary boundary
where we say let's just play with what a
Shannon entropy measurement could be in
a single hash output. So all we're
caring about, all we're thinking about
at this moment is 256 bits and we have
to employ an arbitrary rule. So we could
look at leading ones, we could look at
leading zeros, we could look at pairs of
ones and zeros, but so that's what I'm
saying is an arbitrary rule used.
But in the kind of state space of that
single output,
if we were to determine that if we were
to to arbitrarily determine that the
leading number of zeros is what we cared
about as a way of saying
um that's a that's a known state or an
unknown state. We're saying we're going
to accumulate a number of known or let's
say accumulate a number of unknown
states and what is the expectation that
we should at the next interval overcome
that amount of unknown states.
So um
the
leading number of zeros
is
like let's say we have 50 leading zeros
that to get 50 leading zeros is a really
uh improbable event and that's
improbable
relative to the
typical output.
that has some some number less leading
zeros. And so if we're comparing
a very un improbable event to what we
expect from that typical statistical
distribution,
then we can arbitrarily just measure the
difference of that single rare event and
what we typically expect. And once we
have that then we uh kind of say that
was the that's the uncertainty that
difference between the expected average
and the improbable event. We're going to
say that's valid. We're going to reward
for that. Um and we're going to hold
that and add it to the previous amount
the the the one that was done just
previously. And so we're accumulating
those bits
that that difference uh at each at each
step. Let's see if that answered. But
that that was my my immediate attempt.
>> Cool. I will look forward to learning
more. Thank you both for the
presentations and and great to hear the
stories and the perspectives.
>> Thank you. Thank you, Andrew. Uh huge
ground covered. Love it. and let's catch
up uh very soon. See you.
>> Peace. Peace and love. Bye.
Um, welcome back.
We're moving straight to the second
session of the day, interactive math
tools for active inference education by
octopus.
Uh, remember you can drop your questions
in the live chat through uh the
presentation. So, Octopus, please.
>> Hello. Welcome everyone. Uh thank you so
much for coming. I'm very excited to
discuss some things with you today. And
the thing that I'm um wanting to talk
about is the connection between three
things that I find very interesting and
two of them I would say I know
relatively well. And those three things
are active inference,
math and education.
So, I've been in math and in education
for a while now under different names
and different personas, but always
extremely interested in it. And I think
there's an obvious connection between
active inference and education
through the some of the major concepts
here.
So, I'd like to talk about that first.
Um what I've seen in the last few
decades is a major shift in how
education is is enacted.
And this is going away from a
hierarchical top-down model where
essentially the teacher enacts
command and control on the students
towards a more decentralized
collaborative model.
um this decentralized collaborative
model
was partially forced uh by co but I
think it was also in the making already
and the active inference institute I
believe I hope it's uh not a
mischaracterization
in the eyes of the organizers is part of
this movement where it's not just one
expert who is solely
lecturing
like I'm trying to do right now, but
rather it is an interactive and
decentralized model that leverages all
of the nodes that can exist within the
network.
How does this relate to math? Well, one
of the things that traditional education
does is assign grades.
And already there's math there. we have
a problem in grading which is the fact
that uh grading runs into this issue
first of all it's it's rewardsbased
and inherently it runs into good heart's
law so if you're if an A is the reward
for good being a good student but then
being a good student becomes about
getting the A there's a distortion
effect that's inevitable
but even more we're taking arbitrary
measurements and and then further making
them arbitrary and distorted by
compressing them into these bins. So
that the difference between an 89.9
or an 89.4 or an 88.7
can feel very very determinative and
even destructive in the learner's
future.
I don't necessarily have a good answer
to that except to look at what is the
purpose of grading
and the purpose of grading I believe is
to provide feedback to the learner as to
where their progress is.
So if we think of grading not as a
labeling system but as a feedback system
then it can change our viewpoint of it
and the whatever purpose giving letter
grades was intended to serve um can
perhaps be reimagined into other systems
that provide feedback on lead uh
learning. And so instead of thinking
about a classroom either in a high
school or a university or however else
we want to think about it, I would like
for us to think about learning as
occuring occurring within a learning
system and to think about the different
ways in which learning systems can be
designed.
So already this is an application of
active inference principles because
I mean I hope this is getting somewhere
that's clear to people who are
interested in active inference
that uh active inference is about how
agents can learn or at least that's one
interpretation of it. And so if we're
thinking about a learning system and
we're thinking about the individual
agents who want to learn
regardless of their roles,
then we can start to leverage active
inference principles towards this
process of education.
Why am I specifically interested in math
education?
uh besides the fact that it is my
my chosen interest um I think it's the
place where it is easiest to fall into
the grading distortion trap
and what I mean by that is that we often
can conceptualize math problems as
having a right answer or a wrong answer
and uh the then the system might be
enacted as our goal goal is to get
people to get to as many right answers
as quickly as possible. And my personal
perspective
is that that's antiquated. It may have
worked well at a time when the job of a
computer was fulfilled by a human
because you didn't need completely
accurate answers very quickly. And while
there is still some value in that,
there's so many more things that can be
done with math
and the type of feedback we want to give
ideally in my view to enable the full
range of play within that space.
So I have no idea if people are even
still hearing me. And I'm just going to
continue to rant in this vein um because
I don't think that the feedback loop is
or I don't think that the opportunity
here is one-sided. Obviously, math is an
important part of active inference. And
for many people who want to learn active
inference, they're they're uh stymied in
some sense by the fact that so much of
the presentation is mathematical. And
while you can do work around that by
speaking to things at the conceptual
level or the verbal level or the
graphical level,
it would also be great if we could solve
the problem a bit more upstream by
making people comfortable with the
mathematics as it's actually written qua
math.
The other thing is there's also the fact
that active inference as a discipline I
believe wants to grow and that part of
that is uh engaging in effective
educational
activities of which the active inference
institute is one exemplar.
So this is the frame for the rest of the
things I'm going to be saying
from this highle conceptual view.
Uh we're going to switch to a more
technical and tactical view which is one
approach that might be used to present
active inference and specifically the
math of active inference within an
educational framework.
So the brief lesson or tutorial or play
session that I will be leading is about
math and it's about specifically the
math of active inference.
But let's also look at how active
inference not only sits inside the
lesson but how the lesson sits inside
active inference and how these tools
might be leveraged so that we can use
active inference principles to teach and
to learn more effectively.
Ordinarily, I would pause for questions,
and I'm not sure if that's appropriate
here or not. Um,
>> octopus, if people in the live chat have
questions, they can write it, but this
is awesome. It's a great great topic.
Continue.
>> Thank you. So, I appreciate the
feedback. Um, so what I want to switch
to now is a specific lesson and I'm
going to put the invite link so that you
can participate in the lesson in the
role of a student and I will be
participating in the lesson as the role
of a an instructor the way that I would
give this if I were in an institution
uh tasked with with teaching a concept.
So let me clear that
>> and I'll put that link in the YouTube
live chat.
>> Awesome.
>> Yep.
>> Well, I am going to
>> just wanted to add for context that in
the textbook group that you were
facilitating the math learning group.
>> So we you you know you buried the lead
there.
>> Oh well that's true. I do have some
experience um did several months I think
of of working with communication about
the mathematics of active inference. And
so this um is coming into
uh that informed my perspective here of
actually let me let me speak about that
experience too um
while I work out the technical things
here.
So there's a mode of the mode of
mathematics education that I discussed a
moment ago.
How can we get people to as many correct
answers as quickly as possible?
My experience of trying to work within
that mode is that it necessarily
um or almost automatically
creates a sense in which
people feel threatened emotionally.
Most people have a
a horror story of when they stop liking
math. I have my own horror story of when
I stopped liking math. I'm just thankful
that I uh also have a return story of
when I started liking it again.
And for a lot of people who have this
horror story of when they stopped liking
math, it was when suddenly they had too
much too fast in the words of the
Grateful Dead.
So
if our goal is to get is to determine
who can get as many correct answers as
quickly as possible.
Then
if you don't do that, there's a risk
that you will be made to feel stupid,
especially if you're a young child who
is put into this intensive pressure
process.
And I feel this is incredibly
destructive.
um not only at the human level, personal
level, but also at the institutional,
societal and discipline level. And so,
uh, a lot of the work I'm I'm doing is
about, uh, bypassing an aversion,
recreating or creating experiences that
enable math to be viewed as a play-based
activity where
if you get it wrong, you'll get it right
next time. or if you get it wrong, you
can at least still enjoy the experience
and maybe when you come back to it next
time, at the very least we won't be
afraid of it.
Um, so I'm going to if you go to
student.amplify.com/join,
amplify.com/join
I believe and type in this code MN7C
and I will also copy it and put it in
the chat um locally
that will enable you to join this
activity in the role of a student and
there will be different people who have
different levels of knowledge around the
topics that we're discussing and what
I'm going to ask is that you enter this
activity in a spirit of play. What do I
mean by that? Well, I don't mean
destructive play. Uh I will be seeing
the responses and so if you type
obsinities or things of that nature, um
I can't stop you from doing that, but it
would certainly be a negative experience
for me and I think for the other
participants. Um I would just not show
those responses.
But uh in play, what I mean is that
we're going to intentionally set aside
our seriousness and our internal
pressure. I have chosen to do that by
bringing along my second octopus head.
Um I enjoy that. So I'm bringing that
joy to this experience. But secondly,
another way we might play is if you are
an expert in this field and you know all
the answers and you could get the right
answers really quickly that you seek a
different objective. So if you are an
expert, if you if you could write a test
on active inference, then maybe you
could try imagining that you are a
complete beginner and instead of giving
yourself the challenge of correctness,
you could give yourself the challenge of
empathy, which is a very difficult
metacognitive problem, I would say, and
also a very scientifically applicable
one because an agent who can engage in
metacognition
can enter the mind of another agent. And
that's its own active inference problem,
isn't it? I hope some of what I'm saying
here makes sense. Um, I'm going to begin
teaching by clicking on the teach button
and this will enable me to see the
responses that people are giving as
students.
And hopefully this will this will
maintain under civil decorum. We will
see.
So, I'm going to give people some time
to join here and uh just consciously
pause for a few minutes.
Dead air is unacceptable in radio, but
in education, we don't call it dead air.
We just call it quiet. And so, it's okay
here if there's some quiet in the
moment.
I can see that four people have joined.
Um, I can see your names and I should
have warned you about that, but I don't
think anyone has deanonymized
themselves.
Um, but I could anonymize people
and these become the names of famous
mathematicians or scientists. And I
personally like anonymize mode better.
The No, I also buried the lead on this.
Um, the tool that I'm using is called
Amplify.
When I was first introduced to it, it
was called Desmos Teacher.
Uh, I haven't used it in several years,
and so I
since I ceased being a classroom
teacher. Um, but I've been playing with
it a little bit in anticipation of this
presentation
and um, I will be showing some responses
anonymized.
I'm going to shuffle.
And if you're concerned about the fact
that real names are visible for a
moment, you can leave and come back uh
just by
uh reusing the same link.
So I deeply appreciate the people who
have joined so far and encourage anyone
who is interested to join. There's still
plenty of room.
And the first question I'm asking
is what describes your interest?
And
there's an x-axis here of interest in
active inference.
And there's a yaxis that says I'm
interested in education.
And if I switch to student view here,
hopefully I can have some empathy for
people who didn't
um descri
join this uh who didn't design this. Um
there's a star and I can drag the star
to where it
represents my place on this XY axis.
So if you're a complete teacher and or
if your focus is only on teaching maybe
you I don't maybe some teachers knew
about this and are coming um but they
don't know much about active inference
then you would be up in the close to the
y- axis.
If you are completely interested in
active inference and
have disdain for students or anyone who
doesn't who is learning the subject, um
you might be closer to here.
Uh
if you're
the session organizer, you might be
really high on the y equals x line.
But this enables us to get a sense of
the current audience that's interacting
with the presentation.
Uh,
and I like this as a as an introduction.
I feel part of the feedback loop,
part of the information that the agent
is seeking
to
accurately update their beliefs.
is whether or not I as the teacher agent
am willing to seek information about
their beliefs currently or about their
worldview or their position.
And so again that's metacognition.
Uh I don't agree with the quote
that you know
I don't agree that emotional effect is
the only effective of component teaching
effect component of effective teaching.
Um
but this isn't manipulative.
It's a place of genuine curiosity. So I
am curious about the audience that has
come so far. And let's see what the
audience looks like. Should be the case
if I did this correctly that I see
multiple stars showing up.
And uh it looks like I do. You can see
here hopefully the smaller dark stars
are different individuals.
And so it looks to me like most of the
people um positioned themselves as being
mostly interested about active inference
primarily,
but there are people who are
knowledgeable about active inference and
are interested in teaching. And so I can
see the two clusters.
Now, if this were a quote unquote real
class, there would be a decision point
for me. Do I want the class to know that
there are two clusters? Since this is a
simulated class, um I think it's it's
appropriate to reveal this. Uh but if I
were in a situation where I thought
people might be having some of their
personal risk, uh they might not want
people to know that there's someone here
who's not as interested in education.
And that's a design choice that I as a
teacher agent would have to make.
uh the next screen. If y'all would be
willing to leave that screen and come
with me to the next screen.
And the student view of this simply says
um
make a prediction.
Predict a value 0 through 10.
And then there are only six options 0
through five.
So what I might be maybe this mistake
was made on purpose. Maybe this mistake
is the result of not checking carefully.
Sometimes it's good to make mistakes on
purpose. Vi Arnold, the great Russian
mathematician, I mean the the great
Russian mathematician. must not underell
the great there. Uh he was well known
for intentionally injecting mistakes
into his uh lectures to to make sure
that students were paying attention
and I am told that he would even allow
these mistakes to compound that if no
one caught an intentional mistake and
and called it out that he would continue
with the with the wrong assumption until
someone caught it.
I'm not willing to go that far. Uh it
does feel to me that there is a place uh
where as the teacher agent I would need
to step in and point out there is a
mistake. But I would certainly view the
fact that no one had caught it or that
no one had felt comfortable enough to
challenge the teacher agents quote
unquote authority. that would be very
helpful to me um in updating my beliefs
that were if in terms of taking future
actions.
So I'm not presenting hard quantitative
things about this but um I'm trying to
bring active inference language to a
process that I use in uh teaching
mathematics hopefully effectively.
Daniel, is this making sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Feedback helpful.
Um, so I'm curious though
how the students respond to the fact
that the predicted the task they are
asked to engage in doesn't actually
match their set of expected experiences.
Is this distressing to them? Do they not
even notice it? Do they think it's
funny? All types of responses.
And if I could edit this in live time, I
might even add a a poll of how much did
it bother you.
What what I'll add here, octopus, is
that um you're you're definitely right
and have experienced that with the math
psychology around active inference. And
it can feel like there's some inner math
sanctum or some equations on pedestals
and it's something other than learning
or applying active inference until that
equation is like deciphered.
And when you said that active inference
is in the lesson and vice versa, it's
like this is already the process. And
even just clicking next on a page, just
regular actions that we might take at a
at a second time scale or just through
interface with computers or in
conversation. Those are kind of the
conceptual moments
that are the kind of like the moon, not
the finger. And then that helps the
equations which the symbols could be
different letters or they could be
different sounds or shapes
but those are describing something which
is like the cognitive situation with
prediction, observation, updating,
action selection and so helping whatever
the content were helping pull that
thread of active inference and then it's
a double treat that the lesson is also
about um KL divergence or whatever it
happens to be which helps us understand
the cognitive scenario at a analytical
level but from an experiential level
just learning something the more novel
and surprising the better.
That's certainly how I feel. I have
almost an insatiable need for novelty.
Um
I
I feel it's the more novel and
surprising the better
as long as
it's comfortable enough.
So I wouldn't probably wear my second
octopus head to a high school classroom.
Or maybe I would. I don't know.
Um, but there's, and maybe this is an
active inference concept that's
wellnown, but there's a level of novelty
and surprise that can be overwhelming,
at least to to student agents in my
experience.
Um, how does that show up? And I want to
get back to what I had planned, but now
you've you've said something that I'm
I'm wanting to know more about. Um, does
that show up in the sense that
if the information is so surprising that
the agent doesn't have a way to
integrate it, it puts their survival at
risk?
Is there any way to describe that within
the active inference framework that like
this is distressing to me how un how un
uh unexpected this event is?
Yeah. I mean a lot of ways to go with
that. I think of one situation where we
have a flat prior preference. So we're
open to all outcomes and don't have a
prior preference on which would be
better like all options from the menu.
It's kind of like the flat prior
distribution from the previous session.
And then in that situation, novelty and
learning can be a dominant imperative.
But then if we think about a
distribution like homeostasis of
temperature or blood sugar where it's
modeled as there being a strong
preference when you're outside on on one
of the far tales of temperature or of of
blood sugar then it threatens the the
autopolesis and the the life of the
agent itself. So that kind of goes
outside of a information band into a
sort of survival mortal computing.
So
is it correct to say that
how it feels to the agent is about what
their expectations were or what their um
prior beliefs were. I mean let's be
honest many students in a many students
in a learning system let's say a state
controlled learning system are of the
strong preference not to be there
and uh I always wonder how much that
plays into it like John Taylor Gatau who
I've been reading a lot lately you know
goes um into I don't want to turn this
into a thing about my anarchism either
but um He is talking about how like the
public educational system in America,
at least as he experienced in it in New
York City in the 1990s,
um
was just so socially constrained
and so top- down command and control is
to be uh highly non-functional and that
his effectiveness was to the extent that
he could remain within the system while
completely subverting it. Um,
anytime I see an agent who's active in
who is exercising their agency to be
effective within a system and yet is
highly critical of the system. He was
New York State teacher of the year uh
and then at his lecture just gave a a
critique of the entire system in which
within which he worked. The fact that an
agent can be critical of the system
within which within which they exist
um is something that's interesting to
me. And I'm guessing that these are not
like novel ideas. But the fact that you
specifically Daniel personally are
capable of just turning whatever I say
into active inference. like Rumple Still
Skin, spinning straw into gold is
something I always find value in and am
tempted to just uh exploit as much as
possible for my own learning journey.
Do you have anything you want to say to
that? I don't want to put you on the
spot, but I I will return in a moment.
>> Keep keep going through the slides so
that we can see the whole uh lesson
within the session. All right, that
sounds good. Thank you for keeping me on
track. Um, so then the next thing here
is a formula review. And there's
actually nothing here. And this wasn't a
matter of time. So what you could do is
you could simply put cards here that um
had a concept on one card like let's say
entropy and then a formula on the other
and um they would be free floating and
then you would simply ask the students
to match them. Uh this is a
there's a
There are these things called
tactivities
from the University of Colorado for
teaching calculus. This is a digital
version of a tactivity. In the physical
setting, you would simply have the cards
be cut out and you would ask students to
match them by letter number pairs. Um,
here you could have two columns or you
could have free floating cards that you
then asked to match. This is a very
different type of question from the
previous question. Um to be honest, I
think it would be very inappropriate and
jarring because the nature of this
question is the nature of the prior
question is so open-ended as to be
almost meaningless.
Like I ask you to predict it's Alice in
Wonderland. Like predict a value 0
through 10, but you can only do 0
through 5. Why are we predicting? How
can you predict if there's no objective?
Like you're just randomly choosing. All
of these things are fine. Um, and that's
a wonderful type of absurdist play,
perhaps jarring in a a goal-directed
setting. And then here is a a highly
knowledged dependent goal-directed
problem where you need to at least be
able to do flashc cards quickly um so
that we can proceed.
And they're two very different types of
questions. And each is each at the
extreme. And so moving from one to the
other is something that could be very
distressing to an agent. Um and that's
why it's intended in a spirit of play,
but if you're actually intensely
invested in following or or being a good
agent, um it could be difficult. Let's
move on. So let's move on to the part
that's more content directed and a
little bit less metacognitive.
Um, so this is more open-ended, but it's
closer to a goal direction.
Uh, prior versus likelihood. Here I'm
asking the students just to
uh if you look at this the student view
here uh if you
you should be able to drag the points
and as you drag these points it moves
the distributions.
So you can move the prior distribution
which is in blue. Uh and you can move
the I'm sorry you can move the prior
distribution which is in green and you
can move the likelihood distribution
which is in blue. And there is no
objective here. It's just getting you
used to the idea that these curves are
controllable.
And uh this these points are actually at
the mean. That's not important at this
point for the students to know. It's not
important for the students to know that
these are normal distributions. It's
just a matter of
seeing what can happen if you if you
click
um
and I can see that most of the students
are there. I'd like to ask the students
to move them to wherever they would like
to have them and then we can proceed
from there. Uh I'm going to show you
what I see as a teacher view. um
should be the case
that I can see individual responses
here. An overlay wouldn't really make
sense, but um and it may be a a lag or
internet issue, but what I would be able
to see is individual students responses.
Here we go. Um I can see that the
different students or learner agents
have put the curves in different places.
I can also see for instance who has
touched it by comparing it and I can see
who is actively dragging it as I talk
about it which is a nice um feedback for
me of who is engaging.
If we're ready to move on let's go to
slide five learner agents and I
appreciate y'all.
Um this is what a student would see.
I have now introduced a red
KL rectangle which will show up in a
moment. And there's no explanation of
what KL is other than it's a red
rectangle on the screen.
But as you drag distributions
the KL and there there's a a text prompt
here. What makes KL bigger? What makes
KL smaller? And as the student drags the
distributions around, they're going to
see KL move.
And this is a a tactile discovery,
kinesthetic discovery of a relationship
that is not yet well understood.
Um, and I guess the question is, does it
have to be well understood at this point
or can it be enough that you know that
as you drag these points, the rectangle
changes? In other words, what I'm trying
to do here is to make these felt sense
of feedback central before we introduce
anything conceptual or high level or
give any exact definitions. Um, this can
just be that I'm clicking and dragging
and seeing what happens. And for some
people that's comfortable, for some
people it's not. And that's okay. Um,
but this is what this slide is about.
And then I also ask for response.
There's a prompt here. What do you
notice?
So you can drag to make it bigger or
drag to make it smaller. And there are
really only two directions. So if you
get it wrong, you'll get it right next
time. And what I think the students will
notice is that as you drag them closer,
kale gets smaller.
I'm going to check the anonymized
responses and see if there's evidence
that we're ready to move on.
So, I don't want to rush anyone, but I
also have to fit within the time box
that we have. Okay, we're fine on time.
So, if learner agents, uh, simulated
learner agents, if y'all are willing,
when you have a moment, if you would
type what you notice, we already have
one response.
I also love this beautiful overlay graph
of um, being able to see all of the
student engagements at the same time.
Um that's another concept that I think
of it from the perspective of
cryptography like or securities u
computation like multi-party
computation.
So if we have multi in a multi- aent
system
um and all of these are all of these
agents are exploring in their own way
and then there's a a let's say higher
level agent or a meta agent who can
observe all of the individual
explorations. Um, this is a nice
position to be in for me as a teacher
learner agent who is not only trying to
convey certain material or in this case
just guide the exploration of certain
material
but also it's a nice place for me to be
as someone who is going to be engaging
in repeated interactions with these
other agents. Knowing about uh their
temperament like are they wanting to go
far away or stay close? Things like that
can be very helpful information if it's
not overindexed on. I'm a little bit
self-conscious about the fact that
there's a risk of an opticon
that the you know making this process
clear to the students will heighten
their anxiety about the fact that
they're being watched. Uh I personally
have some trauma around surveillance
capitalism from the the rushed move to
virtual education during co and I can't
imagine how I would have dealt with it
if I were a high school student or
middle school student.
The fact that someone above you can be
watching and collecting data produces
different responses for people. And so
when I engage in this process with
students, I want it to be uh clear what
is happening and I can also get a sense
of the power that a company that is able
to collect customer or consumer data or
user data might feel um because I can
learn a lot. A lot of times in this
process
students have suggested ideas to me that
I would not have originated on my own
and it actually deepened my
understanding of the subject.
Um,
something that we could do here that
might be fun as a as an offshoot is
think about is there a way we could
enable collaborative play
where the agents are directed for
something kind of like the the Reddit u
experiments where they're adjusting one
pixel at a time. Maybe I could ask them
to try to produce a particular histogram
of KL for instance. There's like I love
playing with these ideas, trying
different things and um I'm exploring
the exploration of other agents which is
something I really enjoy doing also.
Um can we move to slide six please?
So um the challenge here is by hand try
drawing two distributions
that will have large KL
and so I'm checking I'm not sure you
know
what students may or may not know here
and the best way to figure out what they
know is to ask them. So my hypothesis
would be that most students will draw
things that look similar to the example
they saw.
Um and that they the prior question was
about small KL but that they will have
the concept that large KL could be um
achieved by separating the curves more
because their goal was smallest.
But it also asked about largest and so
I'm sure they'll see you know there's
only two directions to go. But I'm
curious like
first of all that they'll get this
concept but second of all what the
curves will look like. Um some people
will be de demand avoidant sometimes
something that I often am or they may
feel very playful. they may want to
adjust and see how far outside the space
of uh two normal distributions with the
same standard deviation they can they
can achieve.
Um, this one is also fun as overlay
and uh because in when we switch here,
the students were originally
doing two different um but we could
position ourselves to think about a a
to think about a um a a an open
discussion where we compared
distribution ions that originated from
different learner agent responses.
So even though this
um
even though this curve
and and this curve,
the curve in yellow and the curve that
I'm now going to redraw in green, even
though these two curves may have
originated with different learner
agents, we can now pull them up into one
set from which we can select any two to
discuss.
And we can uh guide or open the door to
free initiation of hypothesis
with things like um if two like this
curve looks more like a maybe a um
exponential distribution or something.
Well, what we were looking at before
were symmetric normal distributions. You
know, do you believe that KL could even
be calculated for two distributions that
are this different? And why? Um,
so these are some options that I would
these are some choices I would need to
be making as the teacher learner agent
or as the central learner agent or the
guide agent or however we conceptualize
it.
Um,
also appreciate the the data is
contribution. This is not two
distributions.
if we can move on to the next slide in
the interest of time.
Um, and then I'm going to give the
students
directed reading
the Wikipedia page, which may or may not
be any good, but it gives us a place to
start. And probably
I would have my own interpretation of of
the Colback Leebler divergence revealed
at this point. I would be happy to to
draw, you know, autonomously around the
discussion, but at some point we're
going to have to bite the bullet and
look at the formula and think about the
formula. And now here's a good jumping
on point.
And this is sort of the reverse approach
to the way that I typically saw concepts
presented especially um preun university
which is you would often just start with
a formula on the board and then you
would begin to unpack it and that can be
that can be very informative. Um I'm
sympathetic to that approach now that I
have a better understanding of how to
intuitit many of the symbols through
lived experience of uh fighting and
playing with symbols to do mathematical
work.
But it's a choice that one needs to make
when will the formula and how will the
formula be given and how much
information will be given at once is
another I've I've chunked things quite
small. I would say for some people this
is really going to test their patience.
Um for others it's exactly the right
pace.
So
the next slide is
a a very low-level challenge.
Uh given the fact that the formula for
the Colbec Leebler divergence is in the
Wikipedia article, are you comfortable
using the math keyboard to type it?
And you do have a a math keyboard
available here
that's got many standard symbols um in
addition to things like superscripts
uh and ratios. It has you know s cosine.
So you're going to need natural log or
log and we can discuss the difference
between those if we need to. But you
have the building blocks here.
Uh my memory is it also accepts input in
in math jacks or text style. Um but
regardless I'm giving the students a
chance to use the formula and and
rehearse the formula in a very low
pressure way that there can't really be
a direct right or wrong answer for um
and and assessing and giving practice in
their comfort with communicating math
using symbols.
So
this is this takes how long it takes. Um
I would probably in a 1 hour class
be hoping to get a bit more than this.
This might be the first somewhere
between 10 and 25 minutes depending on
the audience.
Um
but the goal here is not you know not
just to give an example half lesson on
Colback Leer divergence but to to be
engaged in thinking and conversation
about
active inference inside math education
inside active inference. And at that
point we have either a subset inclusion
where the two concepts are equal or we
have a fractal where as we zoom in on
one we keep seeing the other and either
of those uh conceptualizations
makes me very happy. So that's what I
have prepared for today and I'm happy to
use the rest of the time as the
facilitator uh directs. Thank you so
much.
Thank you octopus.
If anyone has question in the live chat,
we can see otherwise um what are you
what what was most surprising or the
best learning experience or a fun or
symbolic anecdote from your time with
the math learning group in the textbook?
Um,
I think it was the difficulty I had
finding a way that I could write
formulas quickly.
So, I actually went out and bought a
tablet or
there are two things. The first is how
difficult it was to to write formulas um
on a computer screen for me personally.
And I felt that that was helpful because
it put me in a context where I had a
disadvantage
and that felt to me that it made play
slightly more fair although I think it
also was frustrating.
Um the second thing is because of the
the way the sessions were structured I
was mainly coming from a place where I
was responding to student questions. Um
and that was fine. That was totally fine
and I enjoyed it. But it was it it
reminded me of the fact of being like in
a tutoring lab where you're always in
response mode. And I got to experience
that again after not having worked in
that way for a while. and to reflect on
the difference between being in response
mode where someone else is setting the
agenda and you have to fill in versus
something like this where uh as I can
have any essentially level of direction
I want when I'm teaching a class and so
comparing those different experiences
being outside of my comfort level both
of those were things I I found
interesting and valuable to reflect
Great. And then a last question from the
live chat and that'll be it from sleepy
Sylvia. How would you encourage students
to interact in a classroom? It doesn't
seem easy to switch from a mindset of
passive learning to play.
So um I I personally encourage them by
being playful about the experience from
the outset. Um, I guess I don't believe
people uh, so I have never been able to
be effective when I was completely
serious about what I was doing. And I'm
not I'm not sure that people in general
often can be. Um, there are some things
that require extreme precision and for
those moments like let's say calculating
a medicine dosage, one certainly needs
focus, but focus is limited. And so I
think that encouraging play comes down
to recognizing that
play is likely ultimately more effective
in most cases,
especially if we're in an environment
that we can lead ourselves to believe is
low stakes.
Perhaps we will get a bad grade,
but getting a bad grade is not a threat
to us as a person. I hope that makes
sense.
Yeah, I think that really closes the
loop also with the homeostasis, which is
like if all outcomes of the learning
encounter were non-threatening
and equally preferable, it would be like
foraging in an open field. But if some
of those doors
there's a threat that comes up against
our feeling of of survival,
then it can be as as threatening as
anything. So, thank you, Octopus. Great
to have you around. And till next time.
Till next time. All right. Bye.
Um for the third uh session of the third
day of the symposium we have active
inference in biology modeling the
environment is an agent. Uh first Chris
Fields will present topic and then
Virginia Blue will facilitate the Q&A.
Um thank you uh for presenting. The
stage is yours please.
>> Okay. Thank you very much. Uh I want to
talk today about applications of active
inference in biology and particularly
the issue of modeling the environment as
an active inference agent which the FEP
in fact requires us to do.
Um but the approach I want to take is
via the symmetries of the FEP
and I want to focus in particular on two
symmetries of the FEP and hence the
active inference formalism.
One is that all components of any
decomposition of any system are active
inference agents and need to be treated
as such.
And the other symmetry is that all
boundaries between systems, so all
Markoff blankets for example in the
classical picture are information
symmetric.
Both of these symmetries are universal.
Uh they come just from the physics, but
they're both especially relevant to
thinking of active inference in a
biological or social setting.
So in in thinking about
any interactions between living systems
and their environments
um these two symmetries have to be taken
fairly seriously from a modeling
methodology point of view.
So where we're going today is first to
discuss a little bit of physics
and um I'll be using physics from the
top down. So starting with the
description of a of an entire isolated
system, some kind of universe
and adopting very simple assumptions
and seeing where that physics takes us.
And this is kind of an unfamiliar
um way to start thinking about the
physics of a system.
If you're typically used to starting
with particles uh behaving in spaceime
or even a dynamical system that's
defined in some spatial coordinates. Uh
we won't in particular be talking about
spatial coordinates at all. We'll be
talking about systems completely
independently of any spatial embedding.
So once we're done with the physics, I
want to consider two examples.
Uh one is niche construction
and show how niche construction is an
instance of active inference.
And then the other example will be
cognitive offloading. taking part of
your problem and giving it to your
environment to solve for you. And I'll
also show that that generically is an
outcome of active inference.
And then finally u I'll talk about some
methodological implications
of um this way of thinking and in
particular methodological implications
of these two symmetries of the FEP.
So, um,
top down physics, we're just going to
assume three things.
We're going to assume that any, um,
system that we're interested in can be
described with a finite Hilbert space.
So, a Hilbert space is just a space
whose basis vectors are the possible
values of the possible degrees of
freedom of the system.
So if you think of asking a system a
bunch of yes no questions
every yes no question corresponds to one
of the basis vectors of this state space
if you use a hilbert spaces the state
space
and therefore we can think of any of
these spaces as just spaces of cubits
quantum bits u because those are the
most fundamental entity to which you can
ask a yes no question and get an answer
either yes or no.
So we'll assume that all systems can be
described in this way and we'll assume
that they're all finite dimensional and
that's just for convenience. They can be
arbitrarily large but if we assume
they're finite dimensional we don't have
to worry about singularities which just
cause problems.
The second assumption we'll make is that
there's some sort of background time
parameter. There's some
um
intuitive concept of time that we can
use to talk about change. Uh
and we will not assume that this is
measurable by any experiment. So it's
it's just a parameter that we'll use in
the theory and measurable times have to
be constructed but they're constructed
from this back background time parameter
and the way to think about that is a
measurable time requires a clock and for
a clock to be meaningful it has to
change and to talk about change we have
to assume some sort of background time.
So all clocks run slower than the
fundamental frequency of the background
time parameter that we're assuming.
Then the third assumption we're going to
make is that isolated systems conserve
information.
And this is the principle of unitarity
which is the fundamental principle of
quantum theory.
Um it says that if you have an isolated
system and its state is evolving in this
background time
then the state will encode exactly the
same amount of information at every
time.
Um
that
assumption
might be considered controversial.
uh if you throw out that assumption then
you throw out quantum theory. So you've
thrown out a lot of empirical physics
and have a lot of explaining to do uh it
requires a whole new theory of how
everything works.
Uh if you abandon unitarity
so
we're doing we're making these
assumptions with a goal which is
universality.
If we make these assumptions, we
describe all systems and all
interactions
um
up to the three assumptions that we've
made. Uh they apply to everything
and of course we play pay a price for
this which is abstraction. Um the
results that we get will give us
constraints on models but they don't
tell us how to build models. So the
outcome is is a set of methodological
constraints that have to be complied
with. It's not a model building
procedure.
And before um going on, I'll put in a a
plug for this recent book that Jim
Glazebrook and I wrote that explores the
implications of making these
assumptions. and we're doing a live
stream on that at the end of January
um for the active inference institute.
So if you're interested in this kind of
approach to physics
um that may be of interest to you again
it's not for a couple of months.
So let's start with the first
implication of unitarity
which I label here decompositional
equivalence.
The implication is that you can take a
system any isolated system. So I'll call
that U for universe
and that system has some internal
dynamics which we can represent with a a
Hamiltonian operator. You don't have to
worry about how to write that down or
anything else. Uh it's an operator that
classically corresponds to the total
energy of the system.
But uh it is an operator that preserves
information the information in the state
of this isolated system U.
And you being isolated just means that
information doesn't flow in and it
doesn't flow out.
So decompositional equivalence is the
fact that I can now slice that system
any way I want to into two components
which I'll call S and E for system and
environment
and I can represent each of those
components as having an internal
dynamics
and I can represent their interaction
uh by again a Hamiltonian operator that
describes information flow between the
two systems
at some boundary the boundary where I've
sliced the system
and that operator HU decomposes
additively
which means that I can slice this system
any way I want to and I don't affect its
overall dynamics at all.
So what that means methodologically
is that physics by itself does not give
us boundaries. They're no joints in you
or for it to be carved at the boundaries
that we see are all boundaries that we
have defined by stipulation.
So the picture
of an evolving universe
where the physics itself gives you the
boundaries around things is actually
inconsistent with the three assumptions
that we've made. Uh the physics doesn't
produce any boundaries if you make those
three assumptions.
However, the physics defines the
interaction
which I've labeled here hse
at any boundary that we stipulate by
making a model. So it's our choice as
theorists. We can slice the system any
way we want and the physics gives us the
interaction
and it gives it to us by this simple
formula I've written here.
So this symmetry in fact is key to the
free energy principle. And now we can
state the free energy principle.
It says that if we slice this system U,
if we slice any isolated system anywhere
to define two components S and E,
then if S and E are to remain in a
separable joint state, so if they're
going to remain mutually statistically
independent,
then they have to both behave in a way
that's consistent with that mutual
statistical independence, which in in
quant Quantum theory we call
separability. Separability just means
lack of entanglement.
So if S and E are going to be separate
systems, things that we can talk about
independently, they're not entangled. So
they have to behave in a way that is
consistent with them not being
entangled.
and maintaining separability
not becoming entangled requires keeping
the interaction weak with respect to the
internal interactions.
So we can express that by thinking of
the dimensions of the interaction which
are the same as the dimensions of the
Hilbert spaces.
the dimension of the interaction is the
same as the dimension of this boundary
that I've used to slice the system.
And that boundary just has to be much
smaller than either of the systems that
it separates.
Um, and that is intuitively obvious. The
boundary has to be small enough that the
systems robustly have internal states or
the FE doesn't tell you anything. The FE
requires that systems have internal
states.
But this gives us a an an important
qualitative fact which is that
sensations and actions which are defined
at the boundary are lowdimensional
projections of the general models of the
systems because the general models are
implemented by these internal
interactions.
So when we think about what a system is
observing or what a system is doing
in both cases those are very
lowdimensional representations of its of
its generative model lowdimensional
inputs lowdimensional outputs.
So with this we can now think about the
symmetries of the FEP.
So the first symmetry is that
if E is the environment of S, then S is
the environment of E.
So if S's generative model, its internal
dynamics, is predicting E's action on
the boundary,
then E's generative model, which is its
internal dynamics, is predicting S's
actions on the boundary.
And E's actions on the boundary are S's
perceptions or sensations.
U S's actions on the boundary are E's
So the boundary is the locust of all of
the sensations or actions of SNE.
The boundary is the markoff blanket
between them which encodes sensation and
action in the standard formulation of
the FE.
So both of these systems are constantly
acting to minimize variational free
energy defined at the same boundary.
So this minimization of VF
is always a co-minimization
being undertaken by both the system and
its environment.
uh and the reason is that both a system
and its environment are stri trying to
stay separate from each other. They're
trying to keep the environment well-
definfined. They're trying to keep the
boundary well- definfined. And the only
way to do that is to keep this
interaction weak. It's to keep the the
interaction from kind of blowing up in
their faces and tearing the boundary
apart.
So that's the first symmetry of the FEP.
If the system's an agent, the
environment's an agent, too.
The second symmetry is that this
interaction being well defined at the
boundary requires that the information
exchange be symmetric.
So, uh again, this interaction is an
operator
um that acts at the boundary to move
information between
S and E.
And it's the same operator
from whichever direction you look at it.
And the operator being well- definfined
is the same condition as the boundary
being well defined.
And in fact, we can see that intuitively
by thinking of the boundary as a cubit
space. Again, it's a finite dimensional
Hbert space. And if we think of the
boundary as a cubit space, it's just
some set of cubits.
And the system and the environment are
acting on that cubit space using
perfectly symmetrical
uh sets of operators.
Um sort of the the S half of HSC and the
E half of HSC
and each is doing preparation and
measurement of each of those cubits.
So the boundary being well defined, the
interaction being well defined requires
this symmetry and you can think of that
just as Newton's third law u of equal
and opposite response to any imposed
force.
So this again is true of everything.
So now now let's think about
what this means in a couple of examples.
Uh first it means we can always think of
active inference as niche construction.
Uh S is always acting on E to persuade E
to minimize S's variational free energy.
Why? Because S's variational free energy
is also E's variational free energy.
They have the same boundary and they're
acting on it with a symmetrical
operator.
So E acting on S is always trying to
persuade S to minimize E's VF.
So the two are always
co-minimizing their VF.
So niche construction is niche
co-construction.
S in fact is E's niche.
Uh and E is constantly trying to get
that niche i.e. s to behave itself to be
to behave in a way that's as favorable
to E as possible.
So good niches in Mike Leven Mike
Leven's language are persuadable niches.
U they're niches that we can by acting
on them get them to behave in a way
that's beneficial.
Uh and that includes of course the other
organisms in the niche whether they're
conspecifics or not.
So a a niche of a social organism like a
human is fairly persuadable.
U niches of of kind of loners like um
tigers for example are less persuadable.
So the tiger is still acting on its
niche but it's not very persuadable. So,
um, it doesn't get as far as we
typically do in getting our niche to
behave.
But the bottom line is that because
active inference and niche construction
are deeply the same thing, ecology is
intrinsically a social science. It's
intrinsically about persuasion.
So, we're starting to cross the
boundaries between disciplines now.
So let's think about the other example
which is cognitive offloading.
Uh getting the environment to help solve
some problem for you.
So if if I'm an agent
um and I'm acting on my environment by
making a measurement and recording some
result and by recording the result I'm
making an action.
Um,
if I wait any finite amount of time,
then my environment's going to have some
time to do something with the
information that I wrote on the boundary
by taking my action uh on the
environment by making the measurement.
So the environment does something and if
I go back and make another measurement,
I'm going to see the results of what the
environment has done in response to my
first measurement.
And generically, I'm going to get a
different answer for my measurement
because the environment's in a different
state.
So the environment is constantly
processing the information that is
written on it by observers.
So it's not it's not just sitting there.
It's never passive.
And one particular case of this is
memory. If I write memory on some memory
on the environment,
then in general the environment is going
to process that memory and when I go to
retrieve it, it's going to look just
slightly different.
And uh we know that that's in fact the
case for episodic memories by humans and
the environment is always acting on our
brains and so it changes um our brain
states and when you go to retrieve a
memory um it's likely to be subtly
different.
Uh the same is clearly true with
technology. We spend a lot of time and
effort trying to get our technologies to
to modify the memories, rewrite on them
as little as possible.
So what what does this mean? Uh what do
these symmetries actually imply? Well,
first it means that systems environments
are always co-evolving in time.
Separability, lack of entanglement
means that the interaction between a
system and its environment can be
considered classical communication. They
can be considered to be exchanging
classical bitst strings.
But because they're not entangled,
because they're separable, they have
free choice uh by the Conway cooken
theorem or just as a consequence of
separability.
So the languages
that system and environment are using to
write on the boundary can be different
and likely will be different. So even
though the environment's giving me back
a bit string, it may be a bit string
that's been encoded with a reference
frame that I don't know and I can't find
out. I just have to make assumptions
about it, build a model of it to try to
understand what the environment's
telling me.
So the other implication is that um
system and environment are constantly
processing each other's
informationational inputs and then
giving back answers.
So they're constantly trying to solve
each other's problems.
um whether
the answer is actually interpretable or
not is always an open question.
So in terms of
theoretical methodology and also
experimental methodology,
um if we make these physics-based
assumptions, then the passive
environment assumption is always wrong.
And it may work for all practical
purposes sometimes,
but it's very difficult to say which
ones those are. And in fact, the frame
problem in artificial intelligence
is a statement of the fact that we don't
know
uh when the passive environment
assumption is actually going to work. We
don't know
whether the environment is going to
generate side effects that we're not
able to predict or haven't been able to
predict.
A second methodological assumption is
that we have to assume history
dependence.
Um and in classical physics we often
assume that things are not history
dependent.
Um that means they don't have internal
states.
Uh they're not doing information
processing.
And if systems really aren't doing any
information processing, if they really
don't have internal states, if they're
really no larger than their boundaries,
then they're not separable. Then they're
in fact entangled with their
environments.
So if we think something's separable and
it looks like it isn't history
dependent, we just need to look harder
because it's some level of description
we're going to find history dependence.
And then the final implication is that
if a system is separable, if if we can
talk about it as an independent thing,
it's always going to be getting some
extra cognitive resources from its
environment.
Uh, it's always going to be able to do
some offloading of problem solving
tasks,
but it may not know how to use the
answers and we not we may not be able to
detect
without doing the right kind of
experiment what its environment is
actually trying to tell it.
So I just want to emphasize in the last
slide that we really have only assumed
three things here. We've just assumed
some very basic physics
uh the Hbert space description,
background time and unitarity.
And so we get a lot of biology and even
cognitive science for free out of these
very simple physical assumptions. And in
fact, we get all the way to cognitive
offloading for free just from the
physics.
And
so when we're thinking about physical
systems,
which we always are when we're doing
active inference sort of models,
um
we start with the physics and we get um
cognition basically
uh not just in the system but in the
environment. So, thank you very much and
I'm going to turn it over to Blue to
handle questions
and I think I'll get out of the slides
and stop screen sharing.
>> Thank you, Chris. Yes, Blue, you're
welcome to
share slides if you want. Yeah, go for
it.
>> Okay, I'll try. Um, first, Chris, I just
want to say uh thank you for inviting me
to be here. It is such an honor and a
privilege to be uh thinking these
thoughts and co-creating this reality
with you right now. Um
>> thank you.
>> I am Let's see. Let's get way back up
into here. Um so Chris and I have been
hanging out in the Hollywood squares for
a really long time. Um I think I'll just
share this way. That way it lets me kind
of do it. Uh so I just want to provide
some links so that everybody who wants
to have the opportunity can come to our
shared level of mutual information. Um
so we've done a number of live streams
together. Uh live stream 17, live stream
40. Um there's this guest stream which I
was not part of but also um highly I
think relevant to uh what was discussed
here and um of course the wonderful uh
uh course that Chris did for the
institute physics is information
processing and so this kota like this is
like 12 lectures and a lot of
discussions and stuff that happened in
the course so to study more of Chris's
work I just wanted to provide that um
background and so here we are somewhere
somewhere in between quant Phum and the
FEP. Now, um I love this slide. I pulled
it out of an old uh slide deck. Um and
in preparation for this, uh talk, this
question and answer uh period, um Chris.
Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. Let's see.
Yeah. Yeah. Um Oh, yeah. I can still
see. Perfect. The pop out panel is
great. Okay. So, in preparation for
this, uh, Chris I said, "So, is there
anything I can kind of study or read up
on?" And Chris sent this, uh, recent
paper that he wrote with Mike Leven, and
that I think some of the figures that
were used um in Chris's talk came from.
Uh, so I I like just pulled a little bit
of notes out of each of the sections in
this, but I don't know how far we'll
get. Like, I could go so far in in
asking questions. Like, I have a million
questions already. So, let's see. Um
let's see kind of what pops up. Um so
just from the introduction I just pulled
a little bit out. Uh it says in this
first quote there is instead substantial
theoretical utility in viewing objects
and processes as complimentary ways of
describing persistence through time and
hence the possibility of observation and
manipulation. This way of thinking
highlights the roles of memory as an
essential resource for observation and
of time as an essential resource for
action and makes it clear that memory
and time are also mutually interdined
complimentary concepts that both rest on
the underlying notion of an identity
that persists. And uh Chris talked a lot
in this um talk he gave at too about the
relationship between identity, time and
memory. If anybody wants to kind of go
deeper into that uh that link is there
too. Um but really what I want to ask
here is about the observer. And so in
this paper you said that um myologology
like the distinction between the part
and the whole essentially effectively
the boundary is defined by the observer
right there's no and this you talked
about too like there's no inherent joint
in a system to be carved at. So this
boundary is um imposed by the observer
and you talked in the paper a lot about
what is required for an observer to
model itself as a persistent system and
model its observations as a historical
uh sequence. So really I think um you
know we talked about the system and the
agent and the organism and the
environment co-evolving but is the
observer also co-evolving and is the
observer also a process in this or could
you maybe like unpack that and help me
wrap my head around that a little bit?
Um yeah, whenever we're we're doing some
sort of experiment or or we're treating
ourselves as as observers,
then we're always interested in
observing some interaction in our
environments.
So I'm if I'm if I'm the observer here,
say I'm the experimentalist,
um I'm studying the interaction between
say a plate of bacteria
and the rest of the environment. So I've
singled out some system in my
environment and I've given it a name and
I've drawn a boundary around it. And so
we're now in a situation where I've
divided my environment into two pieces
and I'm interacting with both of them
all the time because I'm interacting
with my environment
and I'm trying to understand by making
measurements what the interaction
between those two pieces of my
environment is.
So the only access I have to the
interaction between those two pieces of
my environment is how I interact with my
environment. So I can interact with the
two pieces,
but I can't guarantee that I'm
interacting with them separately,
right? I it's it's a standard assumption
of classical physics which even carries
on over into quantum theory that in
practice that uh
I as an observer can interact only with
some particular piece of my environment.
So, it's an assumption, for example,
that I can interact only with this
laptop
and to the exclusion of all of the rest
of the of the universe.
But if you think about what that
exclusion actually requires,
it requires infinite energy
for me to say that that I'm going to
interact only with this laptop. I have
to keep the whole rest of the
environment at bay
uh and make sure that I don't interact
with it in any way and make sure that it
doesn't interact with either me or the
laptop in any way. And that's that's
what's hard, right? We're we're sitting
in an environment, for example, that's
constantly flooded by high energy cosmic
rays. They're going through my body and
going through my computer all of the
time.
So I don't in fact have the infinite
energy that would be required to keep
those
cosmic rays from flying through my body
and disrupting cells or flying through
my computer and disrupting its memory. I
can try
I can make sure the bias on all my
transistors is high so they don't go
changing state when they receive some
slight perturbation.
But uh that's something I can do in
practice, but that's not an inprincipal
complete protection
from the rest of the environment
or from any side effects of my
interaction with the rest of the
environment. And and again this has been
known in AI for a long time under the
rubric of the frame problem that uh we
can make our best predictions about what
will happen as the result of an action.
Um but it's in fact undecidable.
uh the set of the set of all things that
are not impacted by my action is a set
that I can't decide the membership of in
principle.
>> Yeah, I had read that in the paper also
about like you can't even you know tell
if any perceived object is not part of
your own mind. So it's it's uh hard to
because you can't define your own
boundary. Right.
>> Right. Right.
>> Um, okay. Let's see. Oh, yeah. So, we
went through this.
Um, so maybe here.
So, as an organism develops, we can
expect what it can detect and what it
does with the information it obtains to
change. So, we expect the quantum
reference frame it implements to change.
Such changes may be gradual. For
example, as a child increases her native
language vocabulary or radical, for
example, when metamorphosis constructs
an entirely new body with new sensors
and aectors for an insect. Such changes
naturally raise questions about the
identity of the system undergoing change
and whether this identity itself is
changing over time. Um, and I love the
uh modeling organisms as processes,
right? So modeling the system as a
process and modeling the environment as
a process. Uh could you maybe speak a
little bit to perhaps modeling the
boundary as a process?
>> Uh yeah,
and I think there there are two ways to
to think about this at least.
But one one way is and
two of these ways are often conflated in
thinking about the FAP and so I think
it's always important to to draw this
distinction. Um the FEP stated in terms
of state space boundaries
um and we often think of it as mapping
those state space boundaries into
boundaries in some spatial embedding. So
I think of my marov blanket as my skin
for example or we think of the cell
membrane as the marov blanket around the
cell.
And
when we do that, we're faced with a very
um immediate problem of how we think
about, for example, stuff
uh passing through
my my body or stuff passing through a u
a cell membrane.
And it looks like it's it's disrupting
the marov blanket in some way to have to
have objects passing through the marov
blanket.
But when we think about it in state
space, that problem goes away. Right?
What we're thinking about when, for
example, we eat food or when a a microbe
ingests some sugar
is
the state of some molecule is changing
or the state of some collection of atoms
is changing.
Uh, a chemical reaction is just a change
of state. If we think of a molecule as a
bunch of atoms that have a bunch of
relationships,
some of those relationships change
and so the the state of that collection
of things and relations changes.
So we can think of all of these
processes as
movements of vectors through state
spaces where the vectors are encodings
of the states of some degrees of freedom
or some system components.
So, so now when we when we think about
and in that picture Mike and I drew a
picture of of kind of the evolution of
life, right? As life is consuming more
and more of the state space.
Uh
life is acquiring degrees of freedom as
it develops as uh more and more matter
is incorporated into some living living
lineage. we were thinking about the the
lineage of all cells that are um
descendants of some universal common
ancestor.
So if we think about the development of
of life, this this cell lineage over the
last four billion years, yes, that
picture it's nice. um
more and more of the degrees of freedom
of the planet, more and more of the
stuff that's part of the planet,
carbon and oxygen and
calcium and and so on is incorporated
into the living systems. So the
the whole state space of all of the
degrees of freedom say on the planet
uh has an evolving boundary
where u more of the degrees of freedom
are now participating in this process we
call life and are in liflike states.
uh more and more molecules are in
lifelike states.
Um things that were parts of rocks at
one point are now part of my DNA for
example.
So
uh we can then think of this boundary
itself as you said as a process as a
thing with the state space that gets
larger and larger
and
uh at some point we reach an equilibrium
where life can't become any bigger
without um completely consuming the
resources of the planet.
And in fact life life solves that
problem by u
not consuming abiotic materials but by
consuming biotic materials.
Right? Most of the molecules in our
bodies are in fact molecules that were
once in some other living system. So
life is now just shuffling stuff around
within its own structure within its own
cell lineage as opposed to taking it out
of the abiotic environment.
And this is in a sense um the
fundamental idea of the ga hypothesis of
of love lock margallus you know long ago
back in the 70s.
So I I don't know does that does that
address your question?
>> Yeah, most definitely. And I think it
leads really kind of nicely into like
this next question. So we'll just skip
right right skip right on ahead. So
we're talking about um you know life as
a process of of boundary
expansion and when we consider um
modeling the environment as an agent
right so so let's talk about the title
of the talk modeling the environment as
an agent and then the expansion of life
in this environment right which also
includes all of the agents in the
environment
I I wonder about um the concept of the
inner um the inner screen or maybe like
the internal state model. So like I tend
to think about it like maybe it's like a
lava lamp, right? Like the environment
is like a lava lamp with all kinds of
like little life bubbles bubbling up and
merging and take coming apart and like
tons of inner screens in the environment
as an agent. So like am I like going too
far? Should I rein it in a little bit?
But just in thinking about like maybe I
am an internal screen for the
environment as an agent as just as there
are tons of internal screens within me.
>> Yeah, I think that's it's it's perfectly
reasonable to go up and down the
hierarchy and and
see what looks like from see what it
looks like from each point of view,
right? And we can look at the so
cellular level where every living cell
has some environment
that's everything else in the universe
except it
and its job is to navigate that
environment and maintain its marov
blanket.
So what does that environment look like?
I mean for your typical bacterial cell
its immediate environment is some
biofilm.
So its immediate environment is a bunch
of other bacterial cells
and if you look at that biofilm for
example
then it's immediate environment may well
be my intestine.
Um so
we can think at all of these different
scales and ask for a system at that
scale
its whole environment you know is the
rest of the universe but what really
matters is it's is its nearby
environment
in state space which is if it's an
organism that nearby environment is
going to be populated with lots of other
organisms.
that may be more or less similar to it,
but just because they're organisms
makes them to some extent more
predictable than kind of the wild open
environment.
Um, which
the sort of nonorganismal environment is
much less like me than the organismal
environment. So I know much less about
it kind of in principle than I know
about the organismal environment.
And that's true at every scale. So uh we
can think of
of the immediate environment of any
collection of organisms. So your your
example of the the bubbles in the lava
lamp, we can think of all the bubbles as
one system and and the goo is the
environment or we can think from the
point of view of just one bubble where
the environment is filled with these
other bubbles and we get different
perspectives when we do that. But I
think all the p I think all of those
perspectives are interesting and they're
all perspectives in which the
environment
even if it's the ab a biotic environment
um is an agent. It's just an agent that
speaks a very different language than
the language of life.
And life is constantly I mean again this
was the the point of of ga
uh life is always trying to turn the
abiotic environment into a more
hospitable abiotic environment
even though different components of life
are constantly competing.
So we can think of life as a whole or we
can think of these these little pieces.
So your your cat, for example, has the
goal of always being in front of the
camera.
>> Yeah. Um that's great. And so in the
inner screen guest stream, which I
watched in preparation for this because
I hadn't seen it before. Um, and maybe
like this is something that you can't
speak to because it was after you had
left, but uh, Carl talked about the
concept of having an innermost screen or
like a fundamental undissolvable
innermost Marov blanket. And so I wonder
like in in the concept of something like
a human which is, you know, we're just a
large composite of millions of other
organisms, many of which or half of
which I think are not human. So, so in
this premise, like is the inner screen,
you know, of this gut bacteria living
inside my stomach, like it is that's
like not my that's like past my
innermost inner screen or or it it
doesn't seem to me like that the screens
are ever indivisible.
So, I just would love to hear your
perspective on that. Like, is it just
screens all the way down or or what do
you think?
Well, I think I think here again uh it's
useful to make this distinction
betweenformational
boundaries and boundaries in some sort
of space-time embedding. So, if we're
thinking of individual organisms, for
example, we're thinking about things
that are separate in space.
But if we're thinking about a human as
an information processing hierarchy
um as if you will a virtual machine
stack
with uh some layers doing processing
that's that's very close to the
environment the overall environment of
the human not the environment of any of
its cells but the overall environment of
the human
we can think have kind of the surface
systems that are processing that surface
information
and then deeper systems that are that
are processing more highly processed
information.
Uh for example, my
the components of my information
processing system that identify objects
are way inside the boundary. That's just
identifying edges and bits of light.
And then uh my processes that are
identifying multiobject events and
trying to deduce goals and causation and
stuff like that is at yet a higher level
of abstraction. So now we're not
thinking about biological components
like cells. We're thinking about virtual
machines in a computer.
And so the the top level
from this perspective
is the top level of the information
processing hierarchy which you can think
of as the highest level meta processor
in the system.
The the s the
the highest level attention allocator in
the system.
Uh, and its job is just to
its its environment
consists of all of the lower level
processors
that are many hierarchical levels down
dealing with the the overall environment
of the organism. So for example, my
overall environment,
but the environment of this high level
metarocessor is just other processors.
And all it's really doing is giving them
thermodynamic resources. It's saying,
"Okay, you do some work now. You do some
work now. You do some work. Now you do
some work." So its generative model is
a generative model of the processors
that it's trying to allocate attention
to.
And um we make it the the highest level
virtual machine
just by saying there's no metarocessor
on top of it that's allocating attention
to it.
But if you were to take that individual,
say take me and put me in a social
context,
then now there is some higher level
system that's allocating attention to me
sometimes and other people some some
other time. For example, that's what's
happening in this conversation.
Attention is switching between the two
of us and the audience.
So, there's a related question from the
chat. Um, the question is whether these
screens can do anything more than
reflect or if there's a way to actually
build up a higher level of structure.
Well,
in a generic thing that active
inference, active inference agents do
is reproduce
um by some means or other. They may get
their their environment to reproduce
them for them. So computers, for
example, get us to reproduce them
instead of doing it themselves.
Um so what is that for? I mean what are
systems trying to do
uh by reproducing? What are cells trying
to do by reproducing for example? And
one way to think of what they're trying
to do is just decrease their their
uncertainty. Right? If I make another
copy of me
and stick it in my environment,
then now I have something that's that's
very like me. So uh to the extent that I
know how I work, I know how it works.
So it becomes something that's more
predictable.
So the FEP itself
requires systems to to reproduce or it
provides reproduction as a way of of
reducing uh free energy, as a way of
reducing uncertainty.
Now, of course, it's it's not perfect,
right?
Uh
cells can reproduce and their and their
daughter cells can do something that
they don't expect. And for example,
processes like cancer are examples of
them.
Daughter cells of some stem cell are now
behaving in a way that that they're not
supposed to behave in the body. So
they're decreasing the the predictive
power of their environments which are
the cells around them.
So built in built into the the idea of
active inference is this mechanism for
creating complexity
which is reproduction and
differentiation. So in a sense you can
see the whole natural selection story
as uh driven by
um
uncertainty minimization
and and and Carl and and and several of
his colleagues have of course as as we
have uh published various papers about
those supplying the the FEP to
development and evolutionary processes.
>> Sorry. So, I think it's here. Um maybe
it's the next slide.
Let's see.
Um
that
Oh, go ahead. Go ahead, Daniel. Is Was
there another question?
Okay, perfect. Um, okay, last one. Let's
see.
So, I'm trying to drag this away.
Ah, it's this one.
So here we talked about um individually
coherent models of the behavior of a
system. What is required for them to be
mutually coherent or intertransatable?
Um and and I just want to just talk
about coherence and I know it's like a
completely different like discussion of
coherence but I was thinking about about
the coherence that was mentioned also in
the inner screen live stream like about
coherence creating internal screens and
I just wonder if there's like and you
talked about coherence and the
importance of coherence in the quantum
realm and you mentioned it here and I
just want to know if you can um speak a
little more about coherence and um what
that might mean for
for
active inference in the FP overall like
just a a broad um a broad overview uh
since it's mentioned as as so important
for for so many different processes.
>> Yeah. Well, this this is another word
that gets used in multiple ways. And uh
when we talk about quantum coherence,
we're talking about entanglement
basically. So non-separability
um a lack of conditional statistical
independence. So there's one sense of
coherence that is a lack of of u
statistical independence.
Uh there's another sense of coherence
which we're using when we talk about
models being coherent.
which has to do with intertransatability
or as in this diagram um has to do with
maps being commutive. Uh being able to
go from say uh in this picture um
m1 to mapping from m1 to m2 at at t
uh or waiting some time and doing the
mapping gives you the same answer.
That's commutativity of the diagram
and that that's a form of coherence
that's defined mathematically or um
syntactically essentially in
a mathematical system but it carries
with it some semantic information. So
coherence in that modelto-model case is
semantics. It's the existence of a
relationship between two objects
that is preserved through time.
So I
it it would be nice if we had multiple
words in our vocabulary for this
u because it's it's important not to to
keep those two senses of the word
coherent straight. One means
entanglement, one means uh a
relationship being preserved across some
transformation.
>> Thank you. That's super helpful. Um I
guess we're wrapping up. So
>> yes,
>> thank you Blue and Chris.
>> We're definitely looking forward to the
January stream on the book with
Glazebrook. So thank you again, Chris
and Blue.
>> Okay. Thank you all. Bye.
>> Okay. Ciao.
Welcome back.
>> Hello everyone.
>> Go for it Andrew. Thank you.
>> Thanks Daniel. Um thanks everyone. Uh so
we're excited to present some of our
preliminary work. Uh this particular
project is uh entitled uh a bit
verbosely hierarchical active inference
modeling of social trust dynamics in
PTSD integrating qualitative
phenomenology with computational
psychiatry. Uh this project is largely
based around applying the active
inference framework and modeling
techniques for gaining insights into
potential sort of minute real time uh
inference dynamics that may occur for
individuals with or without uh PTSD. And
so a lot of this uh kind of arises from
our work uh with active inference
institute uh with a project started by
Jeremy Cooper uh who did a significant
amount of work uh on uh PTSD. Uh he is a
well actually uh I would rather let him
introduce himself but I'll just briefly
introduce myself. I've been involved
with the active inference institute for
a few years. I've been on the scientific
advisory board this past year. Uh some
of you may recognize me for teaching
tutorials or the textbook through the
institute or uh a few academic
conferences and um I'm largely a
programmer and data an uh analyst by by
trade and so it's it's been very
exciting to try and figure out how to
align uh the goals of computational
psychiatry with uh sort of research in
uh mental health and actually u maybe
gaining more insight into improving uh
uh treatment interventions. Um and I've
just laid out here uh some of the kind
of guiding uh research uh for this
project including Jeremy's work and uh
one of our other collaborators Angelos
Capotos who's uh assistant professor in
experimental uh clinical uh pathology at
uh in uh the Netherlands and uh I will
give it up to Jeremy now. Uh Jeremy, if
you'd like to introduce yourself and uh
anytime since I'm controlling the
slides, uh you can simply say like next
slide or next slide please and I'll uh
change the slide for you.
>> Yeah, gladly. Thanks Andrew. So folks, I
am Jeremy Cooper. I'm first and foremost
a therapist as well as an adjunct
professor at Regent University and along
the side I usually do phenomenological
research. So the idea behind our project
here
comes from my dissertation which was a
phological study into how individuals
with PTSD form slash change beliefs. And
so it was from that that I well as you
do I got my results and everything but
along the way I was introduced to active
inference. I did the textbook group a
couple of rounds and then whenever we
launched projects I was very grateful to
come along Angelos Andrew and we have
been working on this ever since. So it's
very exciting to be able to present this
and we welcome any and all feedback. So
yes, Andrew, if you want to go to that
next slide.
What I'll be doing is just briefly
giving an overview of what my
dissertation consisted of. There is a
preprint that's currently published that
is a condensed version, much more
readable. So that is what this is based
off of. So I'd like to introduce or
invite everyone to think of things in
terms of what trauma- related beliefs
might be as opposed to a belief system.
And the large idea that I have is and
coming from some of the sources you can
see here that trauma related beliefs in
a way moderate the symptoms that someone
with PTSD might experience. That could
be because there's a large phobia of a
effect. That could be an extreme of
emotion. That could be a particular
emotion.
Then also the trauma related beliefs in
a way would moderate their exposure to
any sort of intrusive symptoms. And so
in essence, what we're looking at is
individuals following PTSD.
We're looking at folks who have a
lifetime prevalence of it. We're not
necessarily looking at someone who is a
month out from the trauma occurring.
We're looking at someone who may have
been diagnosed for 5 years or so. They
will there's a good chance that they
will develop these beliefs that
make way for them to navigate their
symptoms, if I can say it that way. So
it could be to avoid particularly
distressing symptoms or it could be to
accommodate symptoms that they already
experience.
One of which might be this idea of
meaning violations. So the meaning
violation concept is that those who
undergo PTSD they suffer a core change
in how they see themselves as a part of
the world. Andrew Andrew if you want to
go to the next slide there.
So I became
curious about this idea of them in the
world primarily from a phenomenological
backdrop looking at agency and how
agency interacts with interceptive
processing and then how that interacts
with affect and I'll say affect I'm
understanding in a different way than
emotion.
emotion of course we can more easily
identify that in relation to something
else as sort of a cause effect but
affect I'm talking about more in the way
of how uh slabby 2008 talks about it
where affect is a way for an individual
to view their world it's a homeostatic
sort of relationship tells them where
they need to adjust tells them their
place in the world how they fit how they
don't fit. These are perhaps larger
larger uh like as we're getting into the
winter here and we have seasonal
effective disorder then everything
starts to feel a bit more gloomy. Those
are the types of affects that can also
be synonymous with the idea of moods. So
that's the understanding of affect that
I'm carrying into this work as well as
the idea of agency. One helpful
definition of which is agency requires a
cohesive narrative,
a sense of body ownership, and a sense
of self-efficacy accomplishment. And so
a transdiagnostic concept that's been
developed by SAS at all is an anomalous
self-experience,
which would be that one's
self-experience becomes an anomalous. it
can be quite descriptive. It's the idea
that one is experiencing themselves in a
bit of a strange way. And so that's
where we looked at interception to see
how that might be occurring. Andrew, if
you want to go to the next slide,
please.
What Rackcliffe discusses in his very
transdiagnostic
book real hallucinations is the idea of
an anticipatory style. This is akin to
the idea of pretension very very
fundamental to the aspect of self. It's
pre-given. It is before conscious
recollection.
But the idea of an anticipatory style is
that I expect something to naturally
come next. But it's a motive. It is a
feeling. It's the the analogy that he
uses is if you know a song, you're in a
way expecting the song to have the right
note afterwards and then all of a sudden
it's out of tune or something's changed
about it. And it's that sense that
something's off all of a sudden. And
Rackcliffe talks about whenever it comes
to PTSD in particular, the way that the
anticipatory style changes is that the
individual loses touch with the shared
interpersonal world. And so this idea
led directly into my research question
for the dissertation is how would it be
for those with PTSD to describe their
relationship with freedom of thought,
liberty to experience spontaneity or
simply asurances of their experience.
And then overarchingly to sum it up with
the literature review is how does that
equate to beliefs? Andrew, if you'll
please go to the next slide. The study
design itself, as I said before, was a
phenomenological study using Scott
Churchill's experiential
phenomenological research method. It
interview I interviewed seven adults
diagnosed with PTSD. The semiructured
the questions composed of
two broadly overarching categories.
What's the impact of diagnosis
on yourself, view of others, your
relationship
and how has that diagnosis itself
impacted how you view the world? So, one
of which is symptomatic, one of which is
impact and through this this particular
design, it lends itself more towards
these structural descriptions. It's
similar coding process but your end
result is a very very rich nuanced
approach to some of the key phological
ideas is the idea of freedom and also
meaning bank making. So that is I should
say another key aspect to my
understanding of symptoms alongside
moods is that they help us make meaning
of our place in the world. Andrew if
you'll please
the primary study findings that relate
to our project. First one these were
sequential building upon itself. First
one is isolation.
So the idea of isolation, it comes about
more as a way to moderate their
experience or or rather mediate their
experience of hypervigilance
because the experience of hypervigilance
was felt in the increased physiological
arousal, the height in anxiety, the
height in perception and longterm over
time that perception
maintained. And so then they started to
isolate themselves as a way to prevent
that heightened awareness.
From there the isolated disposition
was the attitude of to stay
isolated away because now what they have
accommodated to alleviate hypervigilance
has also led them to this very very
painful sharp reality whenever they do
come in contact with other folks that
now their experience is different from
others And this led to the idea of
self-doubt.
And then so the final one where it can
be termed a belief system if you will is
this idea of jadedness. And of course
this is again a phmological mood. That
is that the idea of jadedness is they
have a feeling a sense that they are
distinct in the world separate from
others. that accommodates the isolation,
allows them to act purposefully, but
doesn't have to encounter the pain of
interacting with other folks. And
Andrew, if you will, please.
This led to the idea of social
invalidation and the concept the
proposal that perhaps uh interception
is a social shared understanding. Coming
back to Rackless idea of a shared
interpersonal world as well as Peter
Fonagi's idea of Peter and Chloe
Campbell's idea of epistemic trust,
mistrust and credul. The notion that a
individual's piece of information they
are giving me applies to my world. Not
so much if it's correct, but does this
actually fit for my world? And for those
that were interviewed as they lived with
PTSD,
their primary concern was that they
would doubt their experience of the
world if they did interact with others.
So with that, I will transition to
Andrew who will share our inspiration
and our design for our model and our
agent.
>> Awesome. Thanks Jeremy. Um yeah so so
Jeremy essentially brought a lot of his
work to the institute and to the sort of
project that was formalized and so what
we proceeded to do was create a small
team of researchers who had this kind of
variety of backgrounds who were all
quite interested in uh PTSD and a lot of
sort of adjacent topics. Uh so again I
already mentioned myself Jeremy and uh
Angelos and then we've also had a lot of
uh help from uh research at UCL uh H and
Sun um and who helped a bit with uh the
programming and um so the goal here uh
as we already know was uh not so much to
try and uh create an active inference
simulation to recreate trauma. uh this a
a lot of work has been done in ethology
to try and understand uh things like
fear learning and associations and uh
whenever we imagine trauma is something
very intensive. Of course the idea of um
you know carrying out a simulation that
might be carried out also empirically
such that we can fit our model to
empirical data from real individuals
with PTSD. um obviously need to file uh
follow like IRB um protocols and and and
be ethical and and more importantly the
the point is not to necessarily
understand the the original trauma in
and of itself. It's much more aligned
with Jeremy's work which is how do we
facilitate those who have already been
through the trauma or anomalous uh
self-experience. How do we facilitate
them to having a higher quality of life
given what they have been through
knowing that actually there's a lot of
adaptation to uh or mild adaptation to
uh the symptoms that sort of follow from
uh the experience of the trauma. So here
I've listed out some inspirations. They
include um a lot of work by uh Ryan
Smith um has done wonderful work in in
computational psychiatry as well as
empirical work and fitting the models to
real data in his um uh simulation on
simulating the computational mechanisms
of cognitive and behavioral psycho
psychotherrapeutic interventions. um
that was sort of a core inspiration of
uh simulating uh you know an artificial
person who might be in a decision-m
task. Uh he simulated exposure therapy
uh which actually recreates some
interesting dynamics of fear uh learning
or unlearning or extinction uh found in
empirical literature and highlights the
role of contextual priors which is um it
it brings up this interesting case where
someone who believes they're safe
suddenly doesn't quite know what to do
once they perceive they're in danger.
Um, and it relates a lot to the idea of
like kind of associative learning, but
how do we how do we engage whenever we
infer that we're in particular contexts
and whenever we're in a particular
context, how does that uh change the
ensuing behavioral outcomes? Um, a very
uh important simulation also to bring up
was um Adam Linson and Friston's work in
2020 where they more directly were
attempting to model uh psychological
stressors especially with um PTSD's sort
of a core topic. Um but again that's
much more ethological. They simulated a
mouse in an environment where there can
be a real threat uh in the environment.
uh and so that's of course not the
direction we want to go necessarily but
their model uh provides a sort of
framework for looking at things like
multimodal sensory integration which is
where we consider uh more strongly the
idea of receiving you know visual
observation uh uh auditory uh um
observation uh witnessing yourself
making actions and reflecting uh on
those actions that you made uh and and
thinking about things like safety and
and and physiological arousal
Um and then after that we have Adam's um
everything is connected inference and
attractors and delusions which is a a
great work and actually if you
understand this paper you understand
most of what our model does and what the
behavioral task is. We essentially
recreated a lot of the dynamics found in
that paper. um that was more focused on
studying uh delusion which is more
generally uh defined as just false
inference despite disisconfirmatory
evidence. So it's not too uh you know we
we're cautious about uh using kind of
stigmatized um terminology. It's more
about just how can we arrive at a more
um precise sort of terms um for how we
understand uh something like aberrant or
or pathological behavior. And uh I also
like that this paper was actually not
dedicated to understanding PTSD or
trauma. It was more dedicated to
understanding how delusions arise in
decision-m and perception uh in the case
of of schizophrenia. Um, and so I like
it because um, it it just kind of
highlights the sort of translational
capacity um, that we might find in
computational psychiatry where we make
models that can potentially depending on
prior beliefs and parameters and model
architecture exhibit a variety of kinds
of pathological disorders. and might
lead to understanding different kinds of
sort of transdiagnostic criteria for
defining things like um you know
delusion or or pathological behaviors um
deeply felt affect uh and as well as Ben
Ramo's role of affective states in
computational psychiatry. This uh kind
of just informs some of our decision-m
of how to model uh arousal and affect in
our model and getting some insight into
uh the relationship between uh affect or
emotion or mood with decision-m and
confidence in one's deliberate
decision-m as opposed to say relying
upon uh habits. uh when someone doesn't
know what to do and so they kind of just
repeat what they've done before um as a
as a sort of auxiliary. Um and then
finally towards the computational
phenomenology of mental action by SV
Smith. Um this also was a very
interesting piece relating to
hierarchical modeling and having a sort
of higher layers in a model or what
we'll call metacognitive layers. The
idea that we can perceive ourselves
perceiving as it were we can have
beliefs about our beliefs. So, so to
believe that someone is untrustworthy
and then above that, what does that mean
for me to believe that this person is
untrustworthy? Um, and and a variety of
other kinds of ways that um that logic
can be applied. So um
for sake of time I might speed through
some of these slides a little bit faster
than others but I wanted to quickly
provide um there's sort of a broader
general framework being employed here uh
that you're probably well aware of at
this point if you've been watching the
other uh symposium uh streams. But um
even more general than active inference
are these theories of predictive
processing. Um and so um uh Lisa Feldman
Barrett uh this is a quote from her that
I I have used in tutorials to try and
provide a sort of intuition for
predictive processing and its relation
to how we understand uh sort of
perceptual uh processing in the brain.
So um here I've just highlighted um some
different sort of uh how we understand
sensory modalities. So there's
interosceptive
uh sensory modalities what we read from
within our bodies and then there are
exterceptive modalities and those
largely align with sort of the five
colloquial senses of sight and touch and
and um you know the whole factory and so
on and then proprioception which I
didn't have an example of but it's
essentially related to to sort of
physical movement and reading of uh the
body in space and being able to sort of
coordinate. Um and then what happens is
that we we essentially take in varieties
of of observations of of sense data at
any given moment. And uh so and from
there we have to infer what does uh this
mean or what caused this? What what are
my beliefs about the world that
generated this? And this happens down uh
all the way down at a very you know
rapid pace continuous sort of level. So
it's not to say that all of it perhaps
probably some of it but not all of it is
necessarily conscious. Uh we're looking
at more at the level of sort of neuronal
dynamics and you know um the the ability
of the autonomic nervous system to
regulate itself. Um being able to
breathe without having to think about
it. Uh you know so um so just gives a
little bit of intuition. And we have to
infer what our sense data means and then
reciprocally uh sometimes we use our
inferences to um try and act to elicit
different kinds of sense data. You know
if my stomach is growling that must mean
I'm hungry. If I'm hungry if I eat food
have caloric intake then I will no
longer be hungry and I will be sated. Uh
is is kind of quick and crude example.
So um from there, how do we proceed to
actually model the kinds of uh phenomena
that that Jeremy sort of identifies in
the the structured setting of of
collecting information from uh the
individuals diagnosed with PTSD? Well,
um I've taught on this before, but more
generally, when we look at things like
agent-based modeling, which is a
technique that goes back decades at this
point, uh the way that it's done is
heavily tied to the kinds of
computational resources we have
available. And so there are more and
more capacities for us to produce uh
more interesting sort of intricate or
complex models, not so much with the
focus on making complex models for the
sake of it. In fact, it's very important
not to do that. Um, but it's to to be
able to simulate uh dynamics that have
been empirically found in the literature
and in our case looking at sort of um
empirical uh neuroiming data uh analysis
and and modeling of neuronal dynamics uh
at a at a very fine scale and and
building up from there. Uh nonetheless,
here's some traditional guidelines. uh
one when doing agent-based modeling we
have to apply different kinds of
assumptions that should be convincing to
readers most imperatively in relation to
empirical findings. Uh if you make a
model and no one is convinced by any
degree of its realism then perhaps it
should not be employed um robustness
simple as possible and no simpler. Uh
those who do things like um you know
computational modeling or modeling of
data are all too familiar with this. you
can make a model that is so deeply uh um
overfit. It's so deeply specific to a
particular case, a particular subcase
that as soon as you start looking at the
broader phenomena you're actually
interested in, you realize your model is
no longer applicable. Um so it needs to
be able to generalize. It needs to be
relatively robust to tiny um
modifications to the model.
Reproducibility is pretty
straightforward. There's a
reproducibility uh crisis in uh science.
some or maybe many would claim. So, it's
good to allow others to be able to
reproduce your work uh whenever it comes
to settings like this where there's um
computer programming and code involved
releasing your code to the public.
Finally, uh non-triviality, the results
of the simulation should be non-obvious.
Um I do think that it's always good to
be able to reconfirm uh our previous
hypotheses with data. So I'm I'm a
little on the fence about this
particular guideline, but nonetheless,
we do want to actually yield a
significant insight from doing this
modeling work. We want to see what we
could not have seen otherwise. Um so
nonetheless, a classic quote from um
statistician George Box, all models are
wrong, but some models are useful. And
so we aim for useful uh models that that
kind of follow particular guidelines. um
and can be empirically validated. So um
more generally computational psychiatry
aims to build what are called
computational essays. And so what we do
is that we try to find okay if you could
model the brain and you use different
kinds of you know decades of research to
try and understand how that could be
modeled and if we know that you know
theories of predictive processing are
all but ubiquitous in um in at least
theoretical if not other areas of
neuroscience as well then you know how
can we start to map the parameters of
these models to u you know
neurobiologically plausible coralates uh
in the brain and that is you know I'm
jumping ahead a bit but I think active
inference does an incredible job of that
and that's part of what drew me to that
this particular framework um you know
looking actually looking at uh the basil
ganglia looking at interconnectivity
between the prefrontal cortex and the
hippocampus when it comes to memory
recall and deliberate decision-m
actually being able to watch more
precisely how that plays out such that
we can move towards having more
precision in psychiatry whether it be
for diagnosis or patient stratification,
understanding particular subtypes um or
phenotypes we might say um in in
pathological disorder and uh and then
from there being able to simulate or
test different kinds of intervention
treatments in a very safe artificial
environment that appears to more or less
um well approximate reality. So the
active inference framework again you've
heard a lot about it. Um it largely
starts with the idea that everything
that changes in the brain must minimize
free energy and this kind of follows
from a neural process theory that active
inference holds to uh foundationally. So
arising from this kind of work that uh
many like uh uh Thomas Parr and Carl
Frist and others have done um in the
past uh from studying things like
perception. We're familiar at this point
with um you know predictive processing
with Helm Holtz's idea of unconscious
inference uh you know of the mind sort
of filling in the gaps in the data that
we might otherwise miss such that it can
make more sense to us um and all these
sorts of things. And so um and then we
also look a lot at the idea of you know
this this is these are not just brains
in a vat. These are entire organisms who
who at minimum need to maintain some
kind of homeostatic regulation otherwise
they cease to exist. Again I recall uh
the idea of me having a caloric intake
such that I can uh stay alive regardless
of you know all the various inferences
and prediction error minimization I'm
doing along the way. Uh hopefully that
helps. Um so with generative models and
no simpler uh what I love about this is
that if we do have this kind of general
uh potentially universal so to speak
principle of how the brain works then
the challenge here or the goal is no
longer a necessity to model say um you
know several billion neurons uh in the
brain. We're not trying to emulate the
entire entirety of the brain. We're just
trying to find the generative model that
describes the problem the brain is
trying to solve. So that allows us to
reduce a lot of the complexity in in
constructing models and trying to map
them to reality.
Active inference again relies upon bases
theorem uh relating observations to
hidden state beliefs um having a
relationship through a sort of marov
blanket relationship with one's
environment in which case uh it's not so
much that you um need to know
everything. it's that you need to know
what are the agents observations and
what are the kinds of actions they can
elicit. And so if you're able to sort of
establish where those sensory and active
states lie uh in in the overall equation
so to speak between the agent and the
environment, then you're able to sort of
establish these conditional
independencies between the agent and the
environment such that you don't
necessarily need to know everything
about the environment in order to
understand what's going on with the
agent. You just need to be able to
understand the observations the agent
receives and the actions they they
elicit and that's about the best that
the agent itself can know. Um so uh I I
do bring up uh this this um this is a
policy inference equation that's used in
in certain implementations of these
kinds of models. It's the one that we
employ and I just very much like it. I
think that it it can sometimes be
overlooked. Um, of course, unless you're
doing the programming. Um, but this has
come up during previous tutorials I've
taught. It's simply to make the point
whenever it comes to decision-m and
active inference. Um, we people have
related this uh I've been asked before
like how does this relate to something
like Conaman and Verski's systems one
and systems two thinking? And um I I
argue that it it actually has a sort of
systems one, two, and three. Um it it's
crude but it's just to say uh with
minimizing expected free energy uh tied
to gamma or uh policy precision. It's
and and then finally uh variational free
energy and and e or habits. It's kind of
like we have deliberate decision making
and reflexive decision-m in the moment
for maintaining one's model. And then
finally contextf free habits which
strongly aligns with a lot of research
we find in psychology on how we do
frequently rely upon habits or sort of
horistic decision making especially in
context of uncertainty. So it's just we
we do there there's I just point that
out to say that there's a lot more
alignment here with other disciplines
than what might initially meet the eye
whenever we start looking at the fuller
breakdown of you know um um negative
information gain minus uh pragmatic
value and getting into all the
mathematical formalisms. Um and then
finally um with fear learning which is a
lot of um again Angelos uh CPotos's um
contribution when we're coming back to
PTSD um uh this is sort of an
informative framework. There's obviously
been an immense amount of work done, but
it relates to the idea of looking at
Pavlovian conditioning. And so, u, one
way of thinking about this is that we
might relate the anomalous
self-experience or or the experience of
the trauma as if it were like an
unconditional uh unconditioned stimulus.
So, the setup in a Pavlovian uh fear
conditioning paradigm is that you
introduce an unconditioned stimulus,
something negative, some kind of
negative stimuli. Unfortunately, you
know, using mice, they might use like a
kind of mild shock that doesn't
necessarily permanently harm the mouse
in any capacity, but nonetheless, it's
something that the mouse does not very
much like. And then that gets paired
with a conditioned stimulus that, you
know, in reality may have no intrinsic
relationship to the unconditioned
stimulus. Uh, so you might play a a
light tone, a sound. And so, uh, over
time the mouse begins to associate
hearing a tone with being shocked. And
then through a learned kind of
fear-driven behavior, um, the mouse
begins to freeze or potentially try to
avoid whenever it comes into contact
with hearing the tone, even though the
shock may no longer follow it. you might
remove the shock component from uh the
task alto together and now it's just the
unfortunately the mouse has this paired
um association and uh from doing these
kinds of ethological studies and knowing
that there's a very strong relationship
in the ma mimalian brain and in the
brains of mice of of cats and so on with
humans um you know there have been
attempts to sort of extrapolate these
kinds of findings to understanding how
humans sort of process um fear and and
how uh fear memory uh develops and um
some findings uh show that memory of the
fears acquisition. So if we think of an
individual who goes through a traumatic
experience um over time even through
exposure therapy even through uh you
know different kinds of sort of fear
extinction techniques the individual
doesn't actually have their original
memory of the trauma erased right it it
remains instead they have to form new
memories about the relationship between
uh an unconditioned stimulus and a
conditioned stimulus. So for example for
individuals who have been through trauma
and then uh experience you know some
kind of negative uh or rather they hold
some kind of negative association
between that and you know other stimuli
that otherwise might not be a problem.
Oh someone sort of benignely lied to me
about something. You know benign just
meaning like it it didn't have any
strong stakes. they weren't necessarily
trying to be malicious and yet that
somehow triggers um you know an
associative connection that I have to my
trauma and in real time perhaps not even
immediately thinking about the trauma
itself may the the individual may start
to exhibit the learned negative behavior
you know they might start to avoid that
person they might um you know kind of
start uh showing different kinds of
symptoms that they've developed over
time um and so we think of things like
maladaptive fear or when fear exceeds
the actual threat generalizes too
broadly or persists after the threat is
gone or prompts excessive avoidance and
again relations to associative learning
hemian uh plasticity and then I'm
particularly interested in
neurobiological coralates to this so
sort of um the amygdala has a a very
strong role in in in a lot of our
dynamics actually not just detecting
threat but also detecting sort of
general salency it's even involved D in
reward processing. So um it's you know
unfortunately in PTSD it's often that uh
in humans the volume of the amydala uh
may or may not shrink to some degree uh
there but there will very frequently be
a different kind of like aberrant um
circuitry uh activation going on. There
can be a sort of shortcircuiting. So
whenever you think of someone with PTSD
being like so-called triggered um what
can happen is that there can be a rapid
recall of different kinds of memories
associated to trauma that then affect um
you know what we might otherwise view as
cognitive uh deliberate decision-m that
we usually view different areas of the
PFC to be related to. Um so with
modeling um all of this the methods
overview we chose a behavioral task a
card advisor task. I'll go into that uh
in a moment so stay brief here. Um the
optimal strategy for this task that is
this task which is reproducible and it
follows ethical guidelines. At no point
is the participant actually in danger.
There is no confirmatory evidence that
an individual would be in danger when
playing this task. um it is structured
like a a game where you don't know the
color of an unseen card. And so there's
an adviser there who's sort of part of
the environment so to speak. They're
part of the the the administration of
the task and they would um they would uh
procedurally tell you what the color of
the card is and then as a participant
it's your job to try and decide are they
lying to me or not. Um
uh and so uh the game-winning strategy
is to actually engage with the game uh
ideally play multiple times and then see
if there's some kind of pattern to uh
the trustworthiness or untrustworthiness
of the advisor's advice. So they give
you the advice, you make a guess, you
might choose to go with their advice,
you might choose the opposite, and
finally you flip the card over and see
if they're right or wrong and continues.
Um and uh this has relation to empirical
studies that have been done in the past
with different kinds of trust based
games um including with the emphasis on
um pathological behavior. And so they
found for um a sample of of uh women
with assault related uh PTSD diagnosis
whenever they played certain kinds of
trust games like this. Um what was
interesting was that they actually had
similar uh prior beliefs about trust as
uh the the normative sample of
individuals not diagnosed with PTSD or
other pathological disorders. So it's
not so much that they were predisposed
to distrust uh the adviser but rather
once the adviser did lie to them at some
point give them false advice and then it
turns out the color was the opposite of
what the adviser said. uh it was much
more difficult for individuals with PTSD
to kind of regain the ability to have
trust in the adviser again uh even if
the adviser switched back to being
trustworthy again. Uh which says
something about sort of the belief
formation or evolution or change in
belief dynamics. You know it's that sort
of change over time. We can't only rely
upon some idea priors but actually how
they play out over time. Uh with the
agent model, we chose a hierarchical
partially observable Markoff
decision-making process, which is quite
a mouthful for those who are not
familiar. Um but uh it's it suffices to
say they're relatively kind of um
powerful, interpretable uh almost
standard in some ways model that gets
frequently employed in computational
psychiatry. It's just because there's so
many mappable parameters and allowing
for different kinds of more discrete
decision making. So a model who can
actually, you know, infer trustworthy,
untrustworthy, um can actually choose
green or blue as the card color, uh and
so on while actually being able to to
play out its dynamics over time. And of
course, uh it's it's frequently used in
active inference. So we're using free
energy minimization and expected free
energy minimization is sort of the the
neuronal dynamics at play. given uh we
also have multimodal sensory integration
uh where the the agent actually is
combining different kinds of
observations it's receiving at any given
moment to make its inferences. Um and
then after that given that this is still
a purely insilic model uh we we
simulated many different agent variants
uh 576 of them and the idea there was
simply to get a view of what is this
model capable of in the first place uh
without making too many other
assumptions given that we would like to
move in the direction of fitting this to
empirical data. Um so so what follows
now uh I I've I've essentially described
the task um and we have a hierarchical
model. So we have a lower layer uh here
that directly kind of interfaces with
the sensorium. It receives observations
uh for each trial of the task. One we
check your heart rate. The agent kind of
self-observes its own heart rate. That
can very much relate to interosception.
What does my physiological arousal mean?
you know that um you know this might be
read to mean a variety of things in the
cases of distorted interosception in in
uh you know potentially pathologically
that is you know uh maybe something good
happened and it you know surprised me
but I'm excited and so my arousal has
gone up and yet a distortion would say
oh I'm physic you know I have a heart uh
a high heart rate uh whether you're
actually thinking about it or not but
it's the association between having a
heart high heart and potentially feeling
that one is in danger, right? That that
can actually lead to cascade effective
inferences where someone, for example,
might become triggered, right? They they
misinterpret a situation and what it
means in their for them in their body
and their ability to read their body and
then it leads on to other beliefs that
that may not have any direct onetoone
relationship with the actual scenario
that you're immediately encountering.
So, we check your arousal. There's a
covert action uh by the agent. Do they
trust or distrust the adviser? It might
not mean much of anything. They haven't
received any evidence yet if the adviser
is trustworthy or not. Uh whenever you
start with the first trial. Um but
nonetheless, you know, they might be
disres uh predisposed to go a particular
way with that. Um then stage two,
they'll receive advice. We'll check your
arousal again. Uh and then they'll
actually make a decision. And then we
added an additional option. And not only
can you choose blue or green as the card
color, but you can also choose to
withdraw or decline making a decision.
Um, we added that because we wanted to
see if the agents or at least some
variants of them would choose that
option. Uh, given that these are sort of
cognitive autonomous agents, right? So,
we're not tell we're not forcing them to
do anything. We simply provide them with
the model and then through free energy
minimization they're kind of making
their own decisions. Um that's that
notion of agency um in to some degree.
And so whenever they choose to decline
making a decision, uh what'll happen in
the final stage is that they'll receive
some feedback telling them if they were
correct in their choice, incorrect in
their choice, or they'll receive a sort
of null or nonfeedback saying, "Oh, you
didn't make a choice." And so we cannot
relate your choice to the correct card
color, and so you don't actually get
feedback. So, it's sort of a a process
where the agent can decline receiving
potentially receiving a reward, decline
potentially receiving a loss of losing
the game. It's a sort of non-engagement,
but you're still in the task. So, it's
not to say that the participant actually
gets up and leaves and they're gen like
withdrawing withdrawing. It's simply uh
you know to kind of choose to not play
the game, but to continue on to the next
trial nonetheless. Um and so we were
curious to see how that how that plays
out. And so uh whenever we run this over
many models, we have these different
kinds of scoring metrics. Uh we're
looking at um kind of composite of
negative affect uh high physiological
arousal believe sense of danger or kind
of false sense of danger and then
interpretation bias which is a very
specific case where the agent believes
that the advisor is untrustworthy even
though the adviser is in fact
trustworthy. Um and so and then we also
included a delusion score which follows
from the Adams paper which is more of an
aggregate of like it assuming that the
advisor is trustworthy when they're not
as well as untrustworthy when they are.
So you have false positives and false
negative conferences. Um whenever we
look at an overview of all of our models
which the the the brain largely follows
non-regotic processes. So I would take
these sort of with a grain of salt. Uh
these are Pearson correlations. It's
simply making uh an alignment. Uh how
much did whenever we look at all of the
models, all over 500 of them, uh which
of these parameters or different kinds
of metrics from each model, you know,
kind of aligns with this hypervigilance
score. Um some of these are slightly
redundant because you know
interpretation is part of the definition
of hypervigilance but nonetheless we
want to see what actually arises in our
models. And uh a core takeaway is uh
first um higher order beliefs about
safety which get related back to the
agents belief in uh the advisor's
trustworthiness
as well as their own sense of affect
positive or negative and and how
strongly positively or negatively
they're they're sort of uh inferring
themselves to be. um whenever uh safety
transitions are very precise meaning a
belief that when when I'm in the context
of safety I'm safe it means it will
persist through time so it's kind of
like environmental volatility is one way
of reading that but also inversely if I
believe I'm in danger then danger will
also persist um whenever that's more
precise it actually leads to higher
hypervigilance it's more than likely
related to the idea of once an agent
does believe that they're in danger it's
difficult to get outside of that danger.
Um it's kind of getting trapped or stuck
in it, so to speak, or you're more
likely to. Um second, uh prior beliefs
about safety. That one is not
particularly surprising, but it is
interesting because we know that these
beliefs get modulated over time. So,
we're just looking here at the prior
belief about safety, where you start at
before you play a single trial, right? U
but nonetheless, a negative um moderate
to weak relationship with with
hypervigilance. And um this was the most
interesting takeaway. There's act even
though it's a weak negative correlation
um some agents by choosing to trust um
they actually kind of bolster their mood
or their affect. Um and uh it's a little
kind of tricky to wrap one's head
around. But when we start thinking about
things like attachment theory and how uh
we might regulate our own emotions
through interactions with others, uh we
might say that these are agents who are
able to uh regulate their emotions at
least a bit through making deliberate
decisions to to trust um the adviser. We
can think of, you know, if there were no
relationship there, then it's kind of
saying, oh, I'm not able to emotionally
regulate myself now, at less
with other people.
Um, a lot of preliminary results, but I
notice I'm very very low on time at this
point. Um, there's a lot going on, but
essentially we're just trying to sus
out. Um, uh, there's an interesting
thing that happened with a lot of the
models. roughly twothirds of them uh
almost never withdrew whereas about a
third of them almost always withdrew and
so um I tried to see what what what are
the sort of correlations there what are
the interacting dynamics between
different pieces uh it seemed quite
clear here that once an agent uh kind of
surpasses some threshold of negative
affect including uh how frequent it is
in general how certain they are of that
negative a effect meaning like a a bad
mood versus a very bad mood is one way
of saying that. Um and then finally the
seriality which is how much do you
recurrently find yourself in a bad mood
as opposed to having rest bits of a
positive mood in the middle. um pass
some threshold, agents almost always
start to withdraw. And I think it just
kind of highlights the notion of the the
the importance of looking at things like
affect interosception, how we read our
bodies, how we read uh emotion and how,
you know, beyond some that that that
information gets integrated sort of with
everything else in decision-m. Um and so
here uh zooming in on withdrawal um it
was clear that that certainty of uh
false trust uh strongly line with
withdrawal. So these were agents who uh
were actually very certain about their
evaluations of the advisor. Um but then
also that came with negative affect. Um
it's interesting that delusion score
came up and I'll I'll get into uh why
that is in a moment but um the idea of
withdrawal is that by declining to make
a decision you're avoiding re receiving
disisconfirmatory or confirmatory
evidence of the uh advisor's
trustworthiness. So we relate this to uh
social withdrawal right it's like for
many of the agents they could actually
maintain a belief that the adviser is
trustworthy by withdrawing from the
game. It's like saying, "Oh, I will just
stay away from you." Not stay away from
you. They're still in the game, but I
will not engage with you in order to
maintain the view of you as trustworthy.
And that will help me uh sort of
regulate my emotions and it will help me
regulate my own personal sense of
safety, right?
Um we compared a few models in
particular those with lowest highest and
average levels of hypervigilance scores
um with those with the sort of average
level uh of hypervigilance who almost
always uh this this particular model
almost always avoided um some
interesting things. one, they do align
pretty strongly in certain ways with
some of the takeaways I have from
Jeremy's research, which are um agents
become to uh they come to expect uh
seeing themselves not engaging with the
game. They they they basically come to
expect that that is how they operate in
the world. Uh which is to avoid sort of
reality testing, avoid uh checking to
see if others are trustworthy or not,
reliable or not. uh and instead they
also start to further uh expect the
symptoms that they experience. So uh
beginning to even more increasingly
expect uh physiological arousal
expecting oh this is this is this is my
life in a in a certain sense. Um and
then uh by withdrawing again we get to
see this kind of phenomena where the
agent maintains a a belief that the
adviser is trustworthy. Although at the
higher order at the metacognitive
reflective level um it's very it's it's
not a precise belief, right? It's very
close to 50/50. So it's a very highly
entropic belief. It's like you might be
trustworthy but I'm not going to engage
with you so I don't have to find out.
Right? Um and then finally the the this
is the agent who had the highest level
of hypervigilance. Um and um there's
some interesting things there. Whenever
we look at the the modulation and safety
beliefs over time um they this agent
also withdrew very regularly. And so
whenever they would withdraw it would
allow for this brief respit from
believing that they were in danger. This
agent who had the highest level of
hypervigilance they unfortunately did
believe that they were in danger at
times even though they of course
weren't. And so it's a false inference.
Um but it by by choosing to withdraw and
seeing like oh I I withdrew I don't have
to find out uh if I'm in a a safe sit I
don't have to find out if this person is
trustworthy or not. I don't have to you
know do much of anything. And so it
gives us yeah this brief moment of
respir
uh beliefs about being in uh danger
which are very high for a moment kind of
become more entropic and it's more like
oh okay I'm kind of sailing this
uncertainty right now but unfortunately
only to resume playing the game again
where danger becomes perceived once
again. Nonetheless again these are this
is the highest level of hypervigilance
so these are very extreme behaviors
we're looking at. um and then the agent
always withdrew. Um another interesting
thing is that the agents gamma parameter
which is aligned uh in the empirical
research there's a lot of good work by
shortenbeck and others in 2015 looking
at dynamics of dopamine in relation to
prediction error um this agent
essentially over time loses confidence
in its own decision-m uh and by doing
that it actually starts to rely on its
habits of avoidance instead. Um this is
very significant because whenever we
actually look at the policy posterior
probabilities whenever it's actually
trying to um um engage in goal-directed
or deliberate behavior um it never once
actually infers that it should withdraw.
It infers that it should play the gra
the play the game. It should choose blue
or green and it even so we can actually
look at what it it it believes it should
have done. Um but because the loss of
confidence right um it it it's this
reliance upon habits in instead.
So um to wrap up so sorry we're going to
have some discussion at the end but I
think we're about out of time. Next
steps um we would like to kind of
increase the without making the model
too complex um uh we we just want to add
one more thing which is to use more of a
predictive coding or hybridic model in
relation to physiological arousal. This
comes up very frequently in the study of
pathology and especially PTSD and other
uh stress related uh disorders where um
dynamics of like the the activation of
the parasympathetic and sympathetic
nervous systems leading to uh hypo and
hyperarousal respective respectively um
can strongly impact how one engages with
the world um including in extremes of
you know potentially leading to
dissociative behaviors or more activated
behaviors on the other hand. And so we
think that uh would kind of overcome
some of the somewhat excessive
simplicities in the original Adams
model. Although the Adams model makes a
bit more sense. They weren't trying to
uh zoom in so much onto the relationship
between arousal and affect the way that
we are um you know to in the same way.
So um we would like to actually fit this
to continuous data uh which is the idea
why we would use a predictive coding
model um or something along those lines.
Then also we want to move towards you
know making this model useful. In
addition to empirically fitting it, we
would like to include things like um uh
kind of equipping the agent with
potential emotional regulation uh or uh
grounding uh strategies maybe in its
policy space maybe at the higher order
level that kind of aligns more with um
previous neurofenological work on on
metacognition. Um, basically if an agent
who has been through therapy of some
kind or has learned some kind of
strategy to help with emotional
regulation, giving them the capacity to
choose to employ that um to whatever
minute degree, maybe a breathing
technique, not sure. Um, you know, we
would like to very much get further into
that. We could also look at um treatment
interventions in the form of SSRIs or
SNRIs. uh we know that noradrenaline and
norepinephrine uh are strongly
implicated in uh aberant uh
neurotransmission in individuals with
with stress related disorders. Um and so
we could kind of simulate that because
we can actually start to model map that
parts of the model. Um we want to of
course uh further test this model in
different ways. We're very interested in
the dissociative subtype in PTSD. Um and
then finally um a big part of the length
duration it's taking to to sort of do
this work is that uh we actually
committed to using open source tools and
so I've been uh carefully studying uh
Fristen and others uh SPM uh library and
mat lab and then reimplementing a lot of
pieces and and auxiliary functions from
that into uh PIMDP which I hope to sort
of re-release um given it has an open
source license. Uh more preferably I'll
be in touch with some of the developers
which I have been. So um probably the
latter situation and um yeah and then
also looking at I would rather get back
into the original PIMDP because it's um
they're using uh jacks for GPU
acceleration and essentially speeding up
the ability to kind of train and test
these models. So um so sorry that uh we
we I really went over on time here
everyone but uh that essentially
concludes my portion of uh the
presentation.
So
>> thank you.
Okay, thank you all. Till next time.
All right, we're back with John Boy at
all. Yes, thank you, John. To you.
>> Hey, I'm sorry, I'm having a little
audio trouble. Um, so, um, and everyone
can see my screen, I assume.
Um, we are here to talk about, uh, story
graphs, which is a part of the Cognar
project. I'm a um I'm a research fellow
at the uh active inference institute and
one of my my main project there is
called Cognar
and uh um
there are a variety of links to that
project and also to the uh to papers
that are uh kind of give the background
story to that project. Uh I invite you I
invite everyone to stop by the active
inference institute web page to look at
the project and today we will be uh
talking about story graphs and that is
particularly uh um discussed in this
paper cognar ecosystem preliminary
thoughts on a on a story graph meaning
representation.
So um what is a story graph? uh story
graph is a core component in the cognar
um uh ecosystem. That ecosystem is its
purpose is to facilitate group cognition
at scale. That is um you may have a
group of a 100,000 or who knows a
million people online who wish to
communicate uh their their um beliefs
about some topic whatever that topic
might be for the group. Um and uh the
the the um ecosystem is used for uh
deliberation and decision-m and
communication. And the idea basic idea
is that people in a group can share
their belief model their beliefs about
the situation and then by sharing their
beliefs uh hopefully the group can come
to some degree of shared belief shared
understanding of what the situation is
and what might be done and what you know
what are the what are the promises and
what are the dangers and all that kind
of stuff. Uh so a story graph is a core
component of that. It's it's a
essentially a intermediate
representation between natural language
spoken language and a formal uh
implementation of a belief model in in a
computer in a computer like with vectors
and matrices and things like that. Uh so
a story graph is readable and verifiable
by both humans and computers and um uh
it makes transparent and explicit a a
storyteller's rich probabilistic belief
model about some situation. So in a
story graph a person might uh uh convey
you know about this about some
particular situation what happened what
who was involved why did it happen what
might what might happen next and and
that is a prediction about the future
and then how uncertain are my beliefs
about that prediction or how uncertain
are my beliefs about what actually
happened or who was involved or all the
different things. So in that sense uh a
story graph should be in a sense e
executable. That is you could follow a
story graph to see possible ways that
this person believes the future might
unfold or or look into the past and see
possible ways that the the the events
that might have occurred to lead to this
situation.
Um uh a story graph conveys a person's
in the Cognar system at least a story
graph is intended to convey a person's
honest beliefs about what happened. That
is if I honestly believe that cows can
fly that may be what my my story uh
involves. Uh somebody else might not
believe cows can fly but uh the point of
a story graph in the Cognar system isn't
to isn't to model the real world. I mean
the system does not model the real
world. This the cognar system conveys
the user's beliefs what the what the
user honestly honestly believes about
the situation. And very importantly uh
story graphs are created interactively
in the cognar system. Um so it is not
the case that uh that somebody would
write out a long narrative and then feed
it into the cognar system and then that
would become a story graph. uh rather um
the the uh person would interact with
the system to create a highquality story
graph. So as an example, maybe I type
I'm typing into the system that
something about Bob and then the system
might query me or others in the group
might query me and say uh wait a minute
uh do you mean uh Bob the neighbor or
Bob the baker or you know there could be
all kinds of questions like that and and
through those kinds of questions and
guidance the the system and the group
can develop a a set of highquality uh
narratives
and behind the behind the story graph
and behind the cognar system are our set
of ontologies and knowledge bases which
allow for consistency of meaning across
stories. So if I'm talking about a a
cat, we all have an understanding about
what a cat is. If in it might be a
mammal or it might be a a bulldozer, but
uh whatever that is, uh we we we
understand what we're talking about
together.
And uh there are applications well
beyond cognar for story graphs in
medicine uh industry, governance,
commerce. Uh and today that is the topic
of our talk. We will be uh discussing
some possibilities of how story graphs
might be used in a variety of u of
settings. And I'm hoping that we have
time for uh taking questions from the
from the audience. um we would be very
interested to hear of what others might
think of like oh that a story graph
could work in this situation or that
situation. So um please do um please do
uh chat with with us during the during
the presentation and um we will explore
together hopefully. Uh just a few more
background slides. Um so how is the
story graph related to active inference?
uh in active inference uh as I think
most people are well aware the uh an
agent an intelligent agent is separated
from its world the the generative
process of the world through a marov
blanket and the agent has an internal
probabilistic model about how the world
works and that model in a sense is what
the the story graph is trying to convey
the belief model of this person and um
in the cognar setting the group
cognition could be viewed as sharing an
updating belief models and hopefully
evolving towards some kind of shared
towards some kind of shared beliefs.
And uh the purpose of cognition of of
course can be seen as promotion of
well-being and the reduction of
certainty. And in the in the active
inference world uh we talk about free
energy reduction.
And uh today's talk uh the purpose is to
discuss possible use cases for story
graphs in and beyond Cognar brainstorm
with the community. Um some some areas
that story graphs might have application
would be decision-m customer service
emergency reporting public polling
instructions systems descriptions
education democracy and elsewhere. and
and some of some of these applications
are discussed in the paper that I've
referenced before
but I but I suspect that there are many
more that u that we haven't thought of.
Um possible functions of story graphs
could be model verification u u model
val validation, explanability,
uh communicating uh in a variety of
different modes. One to many u u you
know a a corporation or some other
entity might want to reach out to its uh
to its group and and convey some kind of
rich information.
uh many to one uh many to many uh that
could be used for recordkeeping auditing
uh of a decision process and governance
uh assessing the accuracy of predictions
as it once events unfold that is I may
have a story about how the world is
going to how I think the world is going
to unfold in the future and that story
is then a record of you know my my
beliefs at the time and then as events
uh transpire one could look back at that
story graph and see what you know was
John accurate. uh did did he uh you know
did he predict correctly what what came
to pass? And that could be actually very
useful u u for a variety of reasons
because some people probably are much
better than others in predicting what is
going to happen next. And then that you
know that's knowing knowing who is got a
handle on how the world works is a
valuable asset to a group. I should also
say too that I I I had a word earlier in
one of the slides about rich stories and
that is also the idea behind uh story
graphs and Cognar is that in the group
setting we would like uh we would like a
person to be able to share a rich story,
a nuance story, a dynamic story that and
I will contrast that to say um joining a
group online where maybe someone types
in a um a a statement of some kind like
we should do A or we should do B and
then everyone can give a thumbs up or a
thumbs down to that. So we're talking
about something far far more
sophisticated and and um and have the
have the capacity to convey a very rich
story and nuance story a conditional
story like I think this will happen if
this or maybe that will happen if this
other thing happens or maybe these three
things will happen if something else
happens. So uh so um yeah so rich
stories uh other possibilities are u um
and for even a a story graphs could
serve as sort of a lingua frank agent to
agent communication that is as agents
are negotiating some some topic or
aspect they potentially could use story
graphs to convey their uh belief models
about how their their world works in
that situation.
Uh and then lastly the purpose of this
talk is just to socialize the Cognar
project and the story graph idea and
again to invite participation.
Uh our panelists today are myself, John
Boy, U Tim Lloyd has joined us Glenn
Repello will speak. I'm hoping Philip
Wilson is is uh scheduled to speak but
he's not here in the moment. So
hopefully he will be able to join us
soon. and then of course the audience.
So just a couple more items about what
is a story graph um and and how does it
fit into the Cognar system. Um so in the
Cognar system uh a a user would type in
a narrative, their story, their belief
system perhaps sentence by sentence or
even even phrase by phrase. Um but um
that would occur in short inputs and
potentially a person could speak this or
there could be other multimedia ways to
input a story. Uh eventually
uh um a user would again type in some
kind of sentence or several sentences
that would be translated into a story
graph fragment and then as the story
graph fragments uh are input uh they
would be merged into a larger story
graph to convey meaning throughout the
narrative. And then once a story graph
is completed, once the whole narrative
is completed, then that story graph
might be uh translated into alternate
alternative meaning representations. Um
there of which there's many uh maybe it
will be translated into a probabilistic
uh uh logical model or some other kind
of logical for uh model for querying or
potentially could be turned back into
natural language to play that story back
to the person. Uh potentially the system
could ask the person, okay, this thank
you for your story. This is what this is
how I understand it. I'm going to read
I'm going to tell the story back to you.
Is this what you mean?
Um yeah. So, uh
and I think this is my last slide, but
I've mentioned meaning representations
already. So, just a few words about what
a meaning representation is. This is
just an example. There's from the
literature. There's many types of uh
meaning representations for for
narrative for for sentences and and
groups of sentences and narratives. And
this is called a discourse represent uh
representation tree structure and it's
for the sentence a very simple two
sentences max fell John might have
pushed him and I won't go into the
details of this graph but it's simply uh
uh identifying the elements of the of
the of the little story here and then
labeling some of them as events some of
them as agents for example John and Max
are agents and uh also pointing out that
there's some time elements to these
events and there's a explanation
between the two sentences. Max fell,
John might have pushed him. That's a
that rep that that relationship is
because u um Max fell because John might
have pushed him. So this is a very
simple I mean relative to what we aspire
to in the carnar setting. This is a kind
of a a simple type of um of
representation and uh in cognara there
would be this would be much more you
know in a in a fully functional cognara
this would be a much more uh
sophisticated um representation there
could be multiple layers uh
could involve ontologies I had mentioned
before highdimensional vectors uh the
idea that is that the story would
capture the dynamics of what's happening
ing the changes of of state that is that
are happening and also importantly
capture the uncertainty as I mentioned
of of the story of the sto of in the
story and the predictions in the story.
So um this uh you can think of this
image here is just a very simple version
of what maybe a story graph might look
like.
And uh with that uh we will uh uh move
on to Tim who's going to talk about real
world narratives model agents that are
fit for real worlds.
So how are you?
>> Thanks. Thanks. I just share.
>> It's fine.
>> So you're able to see all that.
Okay. Um yeah. So uh I guess I've uh
been uh Cognar and you know in
discussions with John and and learning
from his papers and what have you have
has really captured my imagination from
the beginning. I can say that across a
whole spectrum of uh of associations and
relevancies and salencies of the content
with other things. But I'm sort of
bookending since there's sort of an
industrial applications theme to this.
I'm just bookending my brief uh
presentation of where I'm coming from
and connect with this with two things I
guess. One on one end is sort of a um an
initiative to um to establish a sort of
a multis- sector service ecosystem
that's capable of um trustworthy um
support in uh families and close-knit
groups to curate and and and uh develop
um real world stories uh together. Um
and the other sort of book end uh that I
get speak to a little bit here from an
industrial applications of cognitive
perspective is uh along a along uh um uh
engagement with multi-agent software
engineering modeling. You know coming up
with ways to uh you know what's a class
diagram for an agent kind of a thing if
you want to put it real simply. Um
uh so you know uh we look at real world
narratives um uh as as a as a grounding
sort of a cherished precious kind of a
grounding of uh of what it means to be
human and um and therefore serves as
some kind of resource capable of imbuing
AI with sort of uh things that we would
consider more more human and would want
to see in the ecosystem of of of agents
and systems. Um and uh the idea for me
in this application is to expand the
possibilities for trustworthy and safe
AI by actually making it possible for
AIS to actually have some concept of the
meaning of trust and safety from the you
know beginning without hallucination of
fabulation. So you know for me in this
respect uh cognar represents an
onboarding to sort of humans in the loop
deeply in the loop and in the loops of
all the loops etc. Um so it's the
potential for that kind of a thing. Um
and you know we are this this is the
very beginning of a kind of a thing. So
um you know think of it maybe like the
beginning of a human phenome project.
You know the genome looking for a code
of life and the phenome a code of living
and um you know this little illustration
on the on the right is is you know a
popular illustration or iconography
expressing the idea of the universe
observing itself through the arrival of
life. So, you know, maybe narrative is
kind of like the the cognitive water we
swim in. And like a fish, we don't
really notice just how um how uh
absolutely uh ever present and and it
is. Um and so um yeah and just uh I
listened to the earlier uh presentations
and uh I just captured some quotations
here that to me I kept hearing you know
uh narrative narrative narrative again
and again just as a as a sort of a
structural uh theme if you like in a lot
of the talks that were across from um
you know motor systems and and and
physiological health and balance. Um,
you know, your life is composed of
momentby-moment interactions. Um, you
know, sounds like a story kind of thing.
Reference are inherently ambiguous, etc.
until they uh they require context. Um,
so a lot of these quotes are or well,
these quotes are drawn directly from
content previously in this in the
symposium that all to me speak to uh the
value and the potential of uh of uh
cognitive narrative. Um Matt Brown spoke
of uh an active synchronization,
sustaining, productive, adaptive, and
evolving homeostasis. Well, you know,
Cognar represents the similar kind of
potential or possibility on a
psychosocial, socioeconomic, and
socioultural kind of a plane. Um
you know, uh more quotes here. I didn't
mean to read them all, but they're here
to to look at and and uh um and uh um
you know, maybe Cognar also because of
the subject matter opens up onto
answering this question about
philosophers again being interested in
and looking for new potentials here. So
maybe it does serve some kind of purpose
there. um more comments from the
conversation uh earlier in this in the
symposium to speak to uh cognitive
narrative. Um you know so uh and someone
mentioned in one of the presentations
this this uh device this jihari window
for understanding people relationships
themselves and others and what have you
and so you know which multi- aent
narratives are capable or indicative of
expanding the transparency as a basis
for trust. Uh we want to interact with
agents that we can trust. We want to
create agents that we can trust. We want
agents to trust other agents etc etc. Um
that's a tall order. Um, and we always
underestimate how much nature has
already done for us in front of us and
before us. And we uh never quite um
calculate or appreciate the uh lift
involved in trying to do something that
nature already did like um this kind of
thing. Um and so for embodied agents
sort of the taxes of meaning plays out
in and by situations.
Um so these purple statements at the top
again quotes directly from the symposium
sessions earlier and these statements
each one of them is could be just as
descriptive of narrative. Um so you know
agent life narratives comprise maybe
like a lifetime of mortal computing.
Mortal computing has come up a lot.
there's ethical implications that seem
to be uh uh woven into the mortal
computing discussion along with a lot of
other considerations but um uh you know
maybe can go even further and to
instrumental or practical ethical
considerations in AI and the idea that
an agent without a life narrative does
not and cannot have identity not in any
way that people typically would consider
accountable. Um and so just leave it
here. Maybe there's parallels. Another
reference to previous SE symposium
sessions when I saw some of these
modeling efforts on NGCLARN trying to
deal with real neurons. Well, you know,
maybe part of the software engineering
uh industrial benefit from Cognar can be
uh richer uh modeling languages,
modeling elements and uh methods,
methodologies and processes for um real
people, real stories um you know and
therefore agents that are capable of
trust.
Okay, sorry.
So I just wanted to this is more of like
a use case for Cognar. I'm mostly
ignorant of the the entire project but
anyway this seems like a a reasonable
use case. So so this project started out
of the backpack consortium which is uh
intended to study chronic low pack low
back pain and classify various different
patients into groups that might respond
to various different therapies.
So basically what we do is we take their
their their
clinical trial data which is about 2,000
variables or so and we use language
models to assemble that data into a
narrative. We narrate that data and of
course that that story that pros
document that that we show to the
patient will then not read anything like
what they would tell a story they would
tell about themselves. Right? it's going
to be uh anodine or or it's going to
have the character of whatever language
model we use. But anyway, so we generate
that thing and then we have a a
semi-structured interview with the
patient. We show this this pros document
to them. They read it and they react
badly to it and they say, "This is not
like me. It doesn't use the words I use
and blah blah blah." Then we take that
transcript, we process that again with
actually 11 different uh self-hosted
language models and we we kind of come
up with a new one and then we have
another meeting with them uh where they
criticize that one. And so we do this
two or three times and finally we get to
a validated narrative that the patient
actually says this this represents me.
It represents my attitude. It represents
the things I have to say about that. So
the reason we're doing this is we have
this working hypothesis that inside the
human there's latent information that
our objective measures just don't
capture, right? The even with survey
data, the self-reported data, this
there's stuff that this we just can't
capture with those measures. And so the
idea is that um a person's story is
going to capture this latent information
better than anything some committee
decides to try to measure on that
patient. So that's what that's why we're
doing it. It's really for mechanistic
knowledge, but it has a bunch of other
um potential uses as well. So now I'm
going to show you a couple slides that
I'm not going to talk about, but this is
the workflow for data narration. This is
how we take their 2,00 variables and
come up with a story. Fine. And I want
to mention knowledge graphs. We do
similar things with with corpus uh with
a corpus of documents, right? We write a
paper. We have citations in it. Then we
put that all up into a big hairball.
Of course, the idea is to reason over
that hairball. And you can only reason
over such things with algorithms. You
can't really do it in any kind of human
way. But the point I'm trying to get at
here is this this LP story, the lived
pain experience story, this narrative,
and this knowledge graph are two kinds
of the same thing, right? They're both
these artifacts that are very static and
we don't want that.
So the important part here is that it's
clear that that narrativity a person's
psychological narrativity directly
correlates with improved therapeutic
outcomes, right? So they they respond
better to to various different
treatments if they can tell a story
about themselves. Um, and if you find a
less nar like an episodic less narrative
person, you might be able to improve
their ability to to respond to a
treatment by teaching them to be
narrative about their tell stories about
write in a journal, you know, say tell
stories about yourself and that might
improve therapeutic outcome. And then
the problem with that is that
psychological narrativity is is
correlated with psychological rigidity.
So you can get into kind of a canal
structure, right? you get into a rut and
you tell that same story about yourself
like I I have chronic low back pain and
I can't walk a mile, right? And to get
out of that is it it takes a kind of a a
heat a disruption to get out of that. So
part of the problem with things like uh
knowledge graphs and ontologies and all
those databases of any kind is that
they're so static and the same would be
true of any kind of artifact that we
derive from this this protocol I
described. We don't want that. What we
want is these stories to be alive or at
least if the story itself is not alive,
we want the story to be a an an actively
improved living document, a highfidelity
sign of life.
So it see it should be obvious that this
is a good candidate for for a story
graph or such things. So thanks.
I don't hear you anymore, John.
Now, can you hear me? Oh, good.
Sorry. Uh I was asking uh uh Glenn in
your use case the um patient would be
developing this narrative by himself or
herself or it would be facilitated with
a practitioner who would be stepping
them through it or maybe even
transcribing their their story as it's
told or how how does that work out in
your setting?
So the the patient lived experience
story really is one artifact of a class
of artifacts that you might have a a
message from the insurer to the patient
or from the insurer to the hospital or
from the clinician to the patient as
opposed to the patient to the clinician.
So the idea is that these these messages
that are passed amongst this this
stakeholder graph if you will are
co-constructed not they're not solely
destructured uh constructed by the
source node of whatever message or
whatever length they're passing along
they're co-constructed in a way when we
talk to a lived experience panel like
you know individual patients then
obviously that's something they would
generate by themselves but in any other
stakeholder stakeholder communication
I think they should be co-constructed.
>> Right. Right.
No, this is a you know this is a great
uh this would be a great application of
story graphs I think.
Um Daniel I can't see the board and I
don't so I don't know if anyone has
posted any comments or suggestions or
anything but if they have um we could
address them now.
Yes, I will I will ask Oh, yeah, please,
Tim. And then I'll ask any questions
below chat.
>> I I if I think I've forgot two slides,
so I'll just throw them up briefly if
that's okay. just um uh yeah, I think um
maybe this one I actually because I
skipped forward I think to to point out
the NCGLearn parallels
and this was sort of an important slide
that brought together uh some of the um
uh modeling results being sought when I
talked because I introduced I kind of
skipped over the connective tissue
between these two bookends so to speak.
Um so so this speaks then to to to what
we might hope to achieve uh with agent
modeling agent system modeling that can
operate on you know with the resource
that that could be produced in in a
cognar setting and um you you know uh
this idea of fiction's ideas um uh to
extend beyond what we're capable of in
maybe more rational sometimes maybe seen
as seen as more capable but actually not
more capable apable in some instances
things like philosophy. So Richard
Roerty is someone who in this book um
reached out to uh the insights and
sensibilities of great writers to try to
ask where where do we actually gen
promote genuine sense of human
solidarity and um so the question is how
will we write solidarity with our
artificial agents into our story and um
I had just had this one quote that was
worth putting on the screen briefly from
Richard Roert which speaks to the
open-ended evolution of experience and
the human phenome. And so, um, being
used to developing systems that, uh,
think they know everything and can
anticipate everything and are sort of
forclosed systems. Again, to the point
earlier, we don't appreciate how much
work nature does for us when we try to
step in and help out. Um, well, you
know, uh,
we have to keep these things in mind.
It's the idea. Yeah. Thank you. Sorry.
the quote that quote is almost worth a
full read and then I can do any live
chats but I think that is a very salient
thing to read Tim if you want.
>> Uh you want me to read it?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh it says the fear of scientism of
naturalism of self-objectification of
being turned by too much knowledge into
a thing rather than a person is the fear
that all discourse will become normal
discourse. That is, it is the fear that
there will be objectively true or false
answers to every question we ask. So
that human worth will consist of knowing
truths and human virtue will be merely
justified true belief. This is
frightening because it cuts off the
possibility of something new under the
sun, of human life as poetic rather than
merely contemplative. But the dangers to
abnormal discourse do not come from
science or naturalistic philosophy. They
come from the scarcity of food and from
the secret police. Given leisures and
libraries, the conversations which Plato
began will not end in
self-objectification. Not because
aspects of the world or human beings
escape being objects of scientific
inquiry, but simply because free and
leisured conversation generates abnormal
discourse as the sparks fly upward.
That's Richard Berti, philosophy in the
mirror of nature, 1979, page 388.
Yes, I'm I'm I'm sort of struck there by
the the requirements for a computational
story or knowledge graph system to have
strong typing from like a computer
science perspective and to be
composable, flexible, all that kind of
data operations.
And then to what extent would that turn
discourse into normal like roti sort of
fears to make it a finite game and say
well here's our vocabulary set here's
the combinotaurics of discourse or
here's what's the allowable discourse
and then there's that spark that takes
things out of the normal and so how to
have the story graph also be able to
bring in new recompositions and new
elements
to reflect that open-endedness.
>> I'll just say I think that's what
narrative does. Stories continue. We
always make new stories. Stories are
being created every day. People are
living new stories every day. So, Cognar
represents if you like the conduit into
the real time uh emerging, imminent. Uh
and so if we can connect to that uh you
know in the real generative source being
the humans you know and always stay
attuned to that and not let the one uh
olude the other the put it this way
without cognitive narrative good luck.
One of the things that I've talked about
a lot to John and he's probably tired of
it by this point, but it's the idea that
that
any two stories can contradict each
other and that's that's fine, right? It
has to be contradiction tolerant.
whatever whatever structure we end up um
putting underneath the hood has to be
contradiction tolerant
>> which I'll just say also is sorry John
it's the that that's the equivalent or
parallel to to something uh one of the
bullet points I put in there which was
uh scaling the global and local and
everything in between.
Uh Daniel, can you I I don't know if you
if you can share my screen. Is that
possible?
>> Yeah, I have it up
>> and I I'm sorry I can't see it though.
Uh it it says example use case group
decision-making. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. Okay. Uh I just wanted to this is
sort of on the topic. uh but I wanted to
show uh in the Cognar system how uh
deliberation might occur on some topic.
So it would occur in a in a uh in a
series of rounds as we imagine it where
people would create their story about
the situation. Um those those the system
would assess the set of stories from a
group and perhaps uh report on how uh
similar they are, how different they
are, the different elements that the
stories contain. Um the different
perspectives that are taken, you know,
from the from the different uh members
of the group and then those assessments
and the stories would be shared with the
whole group. So then I can see what Tim
is thinking and I can see what Glenn is
thinking and maybe on this particular
topic I like something that Tim said and
then if so I might I might include that
in my story graph now for the next round
and then this kind of circular uh rounds
of editing and viewing and assessing
would continue until until some kind of
ending point. Hopefully uh the ending
point being that we are starting to
develop a shared understanding of what
the situation is and maybe perhaps also
what we want to do, what kind of action
should we take. But the what I wanted to
point out is that um I'm free as I had
mentioned before about rich stories. I'm
free to have a very different opinion
from from anyone else in the group. uh
you know I I might be
you know far away from what other people
are thinking but my story graph is going
to convey that information and that
information is then now part of the part
of the group narrative and doesn't
disappear uh so I may I may not agree
with anyone else in the group and I may
think that you know I may be looking at
the situation from a very different
angle and that will be that that My
story will be part of the group
narrative and would be available to the
group in the future as we as maybe we
look back of uh you know what what was
discussed and who was thinking what and
what you know did did anyone predict
what actually happened or you know
whatever the story is. Um there there
should be room uh in in our narratives
to convey
uh not just to convey the same thought
over and over again but to convey
whatever uh whatever a person's true
beliefs are regarding some situation.
And and of course, those beliefs are
dynamic. They change with time. As as
someone learns more, they may change
their mind, maybe even greatly change
their mind about how they're how they're
seeing the situation.
So, as Tim said, without narrative, good
luck.
And you you just spoke to the sort of
almost sort of re-entrant sort of
composable can't step in the same
narrative twice and and and the idea
that there's stories within stories and
stories about stories and hermeneutics
or whatever the whole you know uh when I
mention that what I'm trying to just
highlight is you know how they speak
about how uh we learn the language of
different mediums. We learned the
language of photography. You know, at
first they behaved one way and then they
behaved a different way because they we
all learned where photographs go and
sort of how to smile in a picture or
whatever. Um then we learned the
language of television. So the laugh
track, you know, we're not like what the
hell is that, you know, we get the idea
of what's going on there. Um uh so to to
some extent, I think what you're kind of
speaking to is that we already know
the the language of narrative and
stories. We're already equipped with a
lot of the machinery that already does
the work. The same way that when the
earlier software and systems engineering
um model developers conceived of, you
know, from Aristotle or what have you,
you know, classes and objects being a
more productive organizing concept for
this all this text of software and
layers of translation, etc. Um so that
we could actually make it attractable
process and deal with reliable and
maintainable complex systems over long
evolutions. Um you know we had to invent
sort of reach for that and invent those
classes objects you know what have you.
Um, you know, narrative is simply this
is proposing that it can be the backbone
of of of some of that and it already
comes with so many of the affordances
that are already natural language to us
that John was just just
with, you know, ease saying and everyone
understood what he meant and yet it was
the complexity of what he said when he
talked about the folding in and
complexification of narrative with your
narrative, narrative about narrative,
your narrative, my narrative, etc. It
was so easy for us to talk about that,
but the complexity that's embodied there
is astounding.
I
>> I'll read a question from the live chat.
So, this is from Samuel Ner who wrote,
"Hello, John. Amazing idea. I was just
thinking if story graphs could be useful
in research with more qualitative
aspects such as psychedelic experiences,
dreams, consciousness in general. For
example, to make better sense of such
subjective experiences, convert it to
something which can be better analyzed
by standard statistical methods or just
strike a better balance between them.
Just throwing the idea out there. Let me
know what you think.
No, that I mean that would be a that
that might be the kind of story where
where cows do fly you know may it may be
a story that is uh if someone is
relating their psychedelic experience
for example it may be it may story may
have very loose ties to what we kind of
consider shared reality and uh that is
okay that is ex you know that is
acceptable in the system and and that
could be useful. Uh I potentially that
could be very useful as capturing a
capturing the narrative of a patient who
is who is uh experiencing this this uh
you know
a very unusual uh you know life episode
and then uh and then having having
captured it in a meaningful way that
that the that the person can verify that
yes that's that's what I was
experiencing you know this is this is a
correct narrative and that the computer
can understand so that so you know if
you had a repository of these uh
narratives uh you know one could do all
kinds of statistics on what were some
common themes and what kind of
transitions happened and what kind of
psychological states were occurring and
you know all all the rest so great the
great it would be a great application I
think Glenn
>> yeah there's currently As we speak,
there's the psychedelic lived experience
um symposium uh summit. They call it a
summit uh that's going on. And they're
talking about things like the mystical
experience questionnaire, which is
another one of those um designed by
committee survey things where they ask
you and the patient would self-report
how what they saw, what kind of
experience they had. And almost without
exception, all of the people in the
community are like, "This doesn't really
capture the the mystical experience it's
trying to capture." And so these stories
that they tell and that the psychedelic
community is rich with with fantastic
stories. So that's to me that's like the
the ideal the ideal community for this
sort of thing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh also I would like
to just mention too uh in the cognar
setting particularly in the cognar
setting one might ask the question why
would somebody want to go through the
trouble of of working with the system to
tell their story because you know it it
might be much easier in some other
system uh where you just simply write
out a you know some paragraphs or you
know episodes from your life. You write
it write it down. Everyone's familiar
with writing things down. or maybe you
just speak it and that's it. You're
done. It's just captured by voice. Why
would somebody want to go to the trouble
of kind of uh working with a system to
kind of cur curate the story to refine
the story to really convey this uh you
know this low ambigu
story with low ambiguity?
Well, the answer I think is I mean I
would hope is because people really want
to tell their story. people people want
to tell their story in a way that their
that their story can be heard their
experience of life can be heard by
others and has a has a makes a
difference you know so I suspect that if
cognar is that you know the concept of
cognar is we're still at the very very
early stages so you know we're we're
still even conceptually putting together
how all of these pieces work and what
what are what are the exact elements the
mechanics of a story graph we're still
working on that. But one day if this
comes to fruition, I suspect that um
that you know many people will want to
tell their will want to tell their
stories and be heard by a larger group
because our stories are our stories are
important. Our stories are you know
that's the that's one of the central
elements of social life is conveying our
story to others. So, um, yeah, that
would be the draw of of of Cognner and
the story graphs is like here's your
chance to tell your story and have it be
understood and heard by the larger
group.
>> What are the directions for the project,
John, for the end of the year or for
2026?
>> Uh, well, the end of the year is very
very close.
uh we are we are we are discussing uh
you know now what h what are the
mechanics of a story graph what are the
elements in a story graph and I don't
want to say too much about that right
now because uh it's it's still in flux
and we might you know we might add or
remove elements from it uh you know
shortly but but I will say that what
we're considering right now is um
something that would a layered graph,
multi-layered graph uh and different
layers in that graph might represent
several different kinds of meaning
representation. So um um I I showed one
image of a meaning representation
earlier on my in my um slides. Uh
discourse representation theory meaning
representation and um one layer in the
in a story graph could be very similar
to that. Uh and then all the tools that
work with that meaning represent rep
meaning representation might be useful.
For example, you know, logic, logical
forms and various types of logic could
be uh um lo logic programs could be used
for that kind of meaning representation.
But then there could be other layered
meaning representations on top of that.
For example, a meaning representation
that's really aimed at narrative. uh
there's a you know people are working
ontologies for narrative and uh so uh
that could be another layer in the story
graph and there could be another layer
perhaps for time time evolution and the
different types of time that can be
conveyed in a narrative.
So that's kind of how what we're
thinking now as a as kind of the next
step. And and hopefully we I I think our
our our immediate goal is to just simply
draw up by hand what what the what a
story graph might look like for a few um
simple stories, you know, five or 10
sentence stories. uh to just get a
handle on how we want to construct the
story graph itself, the functionality of
the story graph. And then once we uh
kind of settle on what that is going to
look like, then we can start to code up
how that how that how that actually
works and how it will probably have some
use of LLM in there to to if even just
in some simple sense of u uh an LLM
might be used to say uh I'm sorry you
used the word cat twice, you know, in
the sentence. Do you mean did do you
mean to use that word twice? You know,
something like that.
Um, yeah. So, that's kind of the the
steps we're going through. We're still
kind of conceptualizing what the story
what the mechanics of the story graph
are. And then we will write up some uh
just some hand handdrawn story graphs
for some simple stories. And then we
will start to look at how that is coded,
you know, uh, uh, in a in a more
automated sense and how a user might
interact than in a in a real, you know,
with a real text box, for example. and
Cognar it will if if it moves forward we
hope that it does it will certainly move
forward from starting very simple
sometimes I I call our first uh aims a
stick figure cognar just to get the very
basic concept of what what this is and
what kind of interactions might occur
and then uh hopefully over time if it
matures it will become more and more
sophisticated and uh you know have more
and more features as we go.
>> Awesome. I'll read a comment. If any of
you have a thought, you can go for it.
Love evolve wrote, "Hearing more about
story sharing, co-storying would be
nice. Intentionally collaborative story
graphing in creative art contexts.
That's that's a whole another use case
that we've not mentioned today is how
could these be used for a creative uh
for creative writing for example or or
or even you know who knows game
development or something like that you
know I I would think that there would be
possibilities there for sure uh I I will
say this in the Cognar setting as it's
conceived um the group does not work on
developing a single story graph
rather each individual in the group has
their own belief model their own belief
model and the and there may be strong
overlaps between the belief models of
different people. So uh as as as we've
conceived it um Cognar is not working on
a single story graph but rather
everyone's story graph but I think there
could be still overlap there and
possibilities for um one possibility
would be uh um witnessing how you know
the synthesis of story graphs of a group
how what that looks like and maybe that
synthesis changes as as the group
evolves. evolves as the story of the
group evolves. Glenn,
>> yeah, the concept that comes to my mind
is the exquisite corpse. I don't know if
everybody's familiar with that, but you
you fold a paper into three parts, and
one person draws on one part, the other
person draws on another part, and all
you have are the little edges of your
drawing that hook, and so then then that
that's all they see, and they draw
something else. And so then you unfold
the paper, and you see the whole piece
of art. So that's the kind of concept
that I thought Kognar might uh might
apply to.
>> Yeah. And I'll just say it's not exactly
art, but from a creative creative
potential standpoint, you know,
intersecting with it and also addressing
uh Daniel's comment or question earlier
in regards to the Rory quote, it should
be open to extension in in the um sort
of phenomenal external reality, new
devices, new people, new norms, new
things, different cultures, what have
you. sort of open to extension of
bringing in and drawing in uh you know
new new new things, new language, new
words, new terms, you know. Um and also
open to uh uh operational
def uh sort of uh u observation of
emerging
communicative
elements or modes and disclosing to us
maybe things we didn't have words for.
um from from the collective uh
phenomenon that that's uh emerging as in
the content so to speak. So so um we
might discover there's uh realities of
human stories and narrative and what
have you that uh we actually you know um
didn't really notice or understand as
fully as we we could with with the
assistance of this. So it's open both
sides.
>> Yeah. Very good. And just to put it just
to kind of touch on one of those
elements. Um we've con as we've
conceived it. Cognar as I had mentioned
would have ontologies behind it. So
there could be some kind of shared
understanding of what the group is
talking about. But those ontologies
could be uh custom customized for a
particular group. So maybe there's a
particular group that's talking about
you know who knows uh traffic and maybe
there's some technical terms related to
traffic that uh the group you know wants
to hold in common. Well the group can
have its uh you know its own private
ontologies to um to to ensure that the
terms that they're using are understood
within the group.
And then as as as Tim just mentioned,
maybe those maybe those ontologies
actually evolve over time as the group
develops a different uh different uh
understandings of what certain terms
mean. For example,
>> I just have to make a plug for that Rory
book that I highlighted, contingency,
irony, and solidarity because he
specifically extends that discussion of
fiction as extending philosophy or
offering resources to philosophy. He's,
you know, um, you know, he's he's um
specifically u addressing private
language mediating in society between
private languages and public languages.
So the private irony of
anti-foundationalist living and uh and
the public um the public language of
solidarity
and science fiction
sort of bridging both or being a view
from both sides with our technological
niche that's able to project and diffuse
these different story relationships
in ways that we couldn't have said it. I
mean, not long ago, music had to be said
live or played live. Then we had fixed
recorded music. Now we're entering into
possible infinite variation on the edge.
So then the story is moving from the
order of what was said into kind of what
it always was, which is something that
generates the linear sequence as told
and as understood. So it's kind of like
with those first principles of cognitive
science,
what kinds of representations are going
to help us
do a lot of the things that I think you
highlighted really well, Tim. Yeah.
with the previous
but that's okay. Yeah, we hear you now
>> just yeah you brought up a lot of good
quotes from earlier Tim with and I think
that really helps
uh connect a lot of the dots and about
this layer of systems engineering and
and design for cognitive computing.
Okay. Any last comments from anyone?
>> Uh I would just like to encourage anyone
who has interest in any of this to say
hello, reach out. We have bi-weekly
meetings on Cognar. And uh it would be
great to uh hear from people who have
who think maybe this could be useful in
you know in some sense with their
projects or their interests. And at some
point we will be looking for stories
too. We will be looking for example
stories and uh and maybe uh people who
are willing to try creating a story in
our you know in our in our system. So
all of that is yet to come
>> and and I guess the only other thing is
Philip I really looking forward to
learning from him because I think some
of the things he wanted to discuss would
got into sort of the mathematical
information theories and what have you
that that that could underpin very
powerful techniques for achieving really
what are some core goals and and
benefits and features or capacities of
of Cognar around sort of the um you know
category theory quantum what have you,
information theories that um
not something we can go into without
him. Uh but if you read those papers,
you'll see a whole section of
information that really was only
scratched on the surface here when John
talked about some of the technical
approaches. But there's a a really
exciting rich um kind of substrate of
theory that that has not even been
brought close to this
Thank you everybody for joining us.
>> Awesome. Thank you all. Bye.
We're back with the final of the live
presenters, embodied presenters
appropriately with Adam Saffron. and
Adam will present
for uh a little bit and take any live
chat questions and then we will play a
sequence of pre-recorded videos from a
set of other colleagues which you can
kind of contextualize Adam. So thank you
to you for the presentation.
Thank you Daniel. Um
so hello everyone. I'm Adam Saffron.
Uh I am currently a research scientist
at the Allen Discovery Center at Tus
University. Uh working with Michael
Leven and today I will be describing an
uh ongoing and evolving collaboration
with uh different friends and colleagues
in the active inference community and
beyond. um centered on basically uh an
AI alignment research program uh which
is centered on uh an integrated
simulation environment under development
called common grounds and uh I'm going
to describe uh some uh different aspects
of what we've been discussing and um my
own views on this and uh some
promising future directions uh and
providing an introduction to a series of
uh
pre-recorded lectures um from my
collaborators and friends that will
follow um going into details of
different lines of thinking that are um
coming together as part of a broader
research program. So I know that's a lot
but let's just dive in. So
um you know I've been interested in uh
AI and AI alignment for I guess maybe uh
25 years now uh since I read the
singularity is near a very long time ago
25 years ago. And um since then I've
been thinking you know uh
what would it take to recapitulate the
principles of biological intelligence?
um in AI, is this something that we will
ever see in our lifetimes? And what
would that mean? And if s such systems
were created, um how might they be
aligned to be compatible with human
values? Um and uh what can we do to help
promote um alignment?
And so uh towards this end, you know,
I've been pursuing this um in a number
of ways. It's um I'd say most of my um
academic career was uh in the background
motivated by these interests and
concerns and hopes and in uh recent
years I've been uh working with um
others to uh basically uh
develop um an interdisciplinary research
program um for biologically inspired AI
and alignment and
um what in this symposium um I'll be
discussing the the I guess the current
state of play of this in terms of uh
ongoing uh conversations with um some of
the uh core members of the active
inference community and beyond um where
um we're um planning to do research um
a
a research program um centered on a
integrative simulation environment
called common grounds. Um we're
currently um so
the hope would be to basically create
like a ongoing support for um a cohort
of active inference research fellows who
could both pursue their work
independently and in communication with
one another coordinating around um de uh
testing out their ideas in this common
simulation platform um for multi-agent
alignment. Um, one of the the key
interests um for this research program
would involve things like um
biologically inspired architectures for
agent design. Um uh
having agents that are um active
inference agents that are um embodied
and embedded in environments uh that
they interact with in rich ways where
they can uh construct and co-construct
their niches. um where these
environments are open-ended and allow
for lifelong learning and metalarning.
Um and where within these what among the
things that would be metalarned would be
um coming into uh pro-social
uh equilibria and the and acquiring
pro-social preferences or um policies
that will tend towards cooperation. um
even under circumstances where uh on
occasion defection uh might seem to be
incentivized, can we create learning
curricula for developing uh harmonious
social interactions and robustly
pro-social agents? Um and then finally
um in addition to uh demonstrating these
principles in silicone um in simulation
um through mathematical modeling can we
uh come up with formalizations and
something like um uh uh guarantees or
proofs regarding alignment uh via
mathematical modeling. So
I realize that's a lot and very
ambitious but um thankfully I am working
uh rather yeah uh I'm grateful to be
working with um some very brilliant
people who I think uh if we keep going
we can make substantial headway uh
towards these ends. So uh in the videos
that will follow in this symposium uh
there will be an initial uh uh lecture
by Nick Haye my longtime friend and
collaborator who is the designer of the
common ground simulation environment. Um
he's uh
everyone's quite brilliant and
wonderful. Um he uh got his PhD with
Stuart Russell. Um uh studying um meta
reasoning and uh went on to uh study
robotics or to
work with robotics at Vicarius and is
now um dedicated to uh pursuing this
line of research and developing a
simulation environment that he will
describe.
uh Alex will present on um ways in which
the simulation environment can be used
to uh demonstrates um some of the um
principles of active inference the
foundational principles including the
natures of agency and value from an
active inference perspective. Um David
Highland will discuss how such an
environment can be used uh for um
demonstrating
um alignment of multiple agents who each
rather than have uh um who rather than
thinking of uh AI alignment in terms of
uh things like the the major companies
developing uh you know monolithic super
intelligences rather what would a world
look like where you had an ecosystem of
intelligences is they were um more
restricted in their scope um still quite
powerful but not necessarily super
intelligent um within such a world what
would alignment look like um with an
ecosystem of evolving interacting
intelligences
uh David also has a co-presentation with
Mao and Ma will be describing um work on
um something called um path flexibility
and the ways in which this promotes
resilience or when you uh when an agent
acquires um uh challenges can it come
back into um uh consistent behavior and
harmonious relations. Uh Dalton will
describe work on the
formal modeling of alignment um
specifically discussing ways in which
you can uh model the development of an
agent in its
preferences and its value and its
action. uh where the free energy
landscape that it follows um the the um
the value uh
function or or the value landscape
governing its behavior um be becoming
canalized or where you develop deep
pullback attractors for self-stabilizing
value regimes. Um I've um in my own work
called these value cores and in Dalton's
work with um things like path formalisms
and free energy and uh uh gauge
theoretic interpretations of the free
energy principle. You can even describe
these as singularities within free
energy landscapes. That's a lot but I'll
I'll leave it to Dalton to go into those
details. um uh Zara Shipahi uh who I've
been working with a number of years uh
where um I've been she's been teaching
me about principles of machine learning
and I've been uh trying to teach her
what I think I know about uh systems
neuroscience. Um she's been developing
really impressive
uh biologically inspired um
architectures
uh for uh flexible intelligences that
could um be deployed in various
alignment protocols that are themselves
u biologically inspired and realistic.
Um and then uh Hanju in her uh symposium
presentation uh will be discussing uh
artificial consciousness um the nature
of affect and its roles in alignment and
even how principles of adult development
uh can and uh psychological maturity as
she calls it um can be used for
developing models of what robust
alignment might look like down the road.
Um and
uh in this presentation I will describe
some of in addition to providing a
little bit more overview describes of
some of my my own vision um with my
background in effective neuroscience um
where the ways in which I think biology
gives us guides both to the nature of
how we might develop advanced
intelligence and not just advanced
intelligence but alignable intelligence.
The notable thing about biological
intelligence is that we are um basically
existence proves that both something
like AGI is possible because we are um
very general um and alignable AGI is
possible because um
biological agents and and and human
beings can be uh robustly pro-social.
They can be um stably benevolent. uh
even under conditions where it seems
like uh this ought not be expected. And
so can we um basically reverse engineer
uh benevolence and and recreate this in
artificial systems or use this as a
guide? And uh so this is
some of the um you know there's other um
friends and colleagues who have been in
discussion and who um
will likely be involved in this research
uh who are not part of this
presentation. Um but um in addition in
addition to them uh question would be uh
uh for anyone listening uh if you're
interested in this kind of research
program uh please get in contact with me
and uh potentially can find ways of
collaborating uh across these
presentations the goal is to show um
different uh lines of thought on
alignment and active inference that can
potentially fruitfully intersect and I
think there's a hole greater than some
of its parts here and uh maybe your work
is part of this hole and hole towards
what? Well, uh basically the hole
towards um uh
what would it take um to uh develop
artificial intelligences that have the
properties of biological intelligence in
terms of their power and flexibility and
also their alignment. So,
uh, common grounds, uh, Nick will go
into more details on this, but in brief,
it is an artificial life inspired
simulation platform that allows one to
deploy and, uh, and simulate richly
embodied agents um, at scale. Um where
this rich embodiment can include things
like um complex internal states um
respiratory dynamics, digestion, uh
metabolism, uh
uh vulnerable embodiment where um
there's
that need to be protected and maintained
um through as they interact with with
environments. Um and where the body
itself is part of the intelligence and
valuing where uh some of the just as
exists in nature a lot of the
intelligence of natural uh uh minds is
actually in the embodiment itself. The
the way bodies are designed uh can be
thought of um allows for um
many fruitful properties that help to
scaffold minds and uh enhance their
power. Uh in this environment uh there
is uh realistic and interesting physics
uh which allows for uh things like uh
niche construction uh which both in
learning to navigate those um is of
interest for places where things like
active inference can potentially
demonstrate its value uh for uh having
systems more skillfully interact with
these complex environments. Um but also
um the
uh environments
allow for as I mentioned before
basically niche construction and
co-nitch construction as structure is
built up and uh and modified um as
agents interact and in the process come
into various forms of cooperative or
competitive interactions. Uh there are
other approaches to multi-agent
alignment using simulations such as
Metagrid and the common grounds
environment can be viewed as
complimentary with these that while um
an environment like Metagrid allows for
maximal scale of simulation um common
grounds allows for um simulations which
are are scalable but um more detailed in
terms of uh what can be modeled at the
level of the indiv individual agent in
terms of the agent having a uh rich
embodiment that embeds it in its rather
a rich embodiment that embeds it in in
its environment. uh the and part like
the richness of these embodiment um can
include things like um bouncy um and
rhythmic dynamics and soft morphologies
um of a kind you see in biological
systems and as I'll discuss in a little
bit um I actually think uh rhythmicity
and others have think this as well might
be actually quite important for
understanding the natures both of the
the way in which um bodies are
controlled and their rhythmic character
with rhythmic nervous systems but also
um how shared rhythms can be part of the
way in which agents
um can be aligned with one another. Um
and finally for common grounds it's um
uh they the intention is it for to be
something that allows for gamification
where people can uh engage in uh
basically in an enjoyable activity of uh
modifying the agents of their
interaction with the world and
interacting with them such that uh you
can promote their alignments you know
can you so Nick is trying to make it um
fun and enjoyable and relatable
for people to um interact with
artificial agents in a virtual world and
see if they can help promote their um
alignment and their pro-sociality.
So that's a brief common grounds. We'll
go into more details. And so now I'll
discuss uh some of my own interests
briefly before um uh opening for
questions and then we can uh people can
uh see these other videos cuz you know
these are um
extremely uh sophisticated thinkers and
I'm not going to be able to do justice
to their uh their ideas. They should
speak for themselves. So um in my own
work I find common grounds to be uh very
interesting because I've um
come to a view which I've um tried to
express in a number of publications uh
that um embodiment is is fundamental for
minds and I think this is a view that's
common within the active inference
community and particularly appreciated
um and so I'll sometimes say that um and
others have said that you know the body
is a prior and that the body allow
allows for um in the process of minds
bootstrapping themselves into increasing
degrees of sophistication. Um bodies
provide um particularly important to
holds and this bootstrapping process as
in Asia engages in structure learning
and complexifies its models of self and
world. And so part of the reason I think
bodies are so important is because I
think they provide a learning curriculum
that has many desirable properties um
for uh learnability and for this
bootstrapping process. So if you think
of for instance like an agent of of a
infant um uh observing its own hand um
as opposed to for instance like a
in contrast let's say um like a deep
learning system um doing vision by
looking at a pixel array um from a world
it never interacts with. In this case
the thing to think of is an infant
learning its own hand as a kind of
prototypical object and causal system.
And so this this hand is basically uh
always uh there and present for being
observed and learned. It can have
action-driven perception where by moving
it around you could resolve your
ambiguity and where the movement itself
will generate correlary discharges or
reference copies which themselves can be
thought of as a kind of crossodal prior.
um and respect cross metal prior um are
the sensors around the hand you know
through the propriception and the
tactile and the warmth you're having
many correlated data streams and and the
visual appearance and maybe the sound
even the smell taste um you have
convergent multimodal inputs which each
can serve as constraining priors for one
another so further helping with
learnability um the bodies interact with
themselves a further source of uh con
mutually constrained inferences Um
there's effective or salience. It it
feels like something to have a hand and
move it around. And so this salience is
will uh be part of why this information
will be attended to and will help to
structure learning. And where the hand
itself because of its um morphic
properties and it what it affords um
allows basically perception to be
structured according to affordances. Um
things like manipulability,
reachability. And then finally uh uh
thing about biological embodiment is
they're designed or they're um
structured such that they are remarkably
learnable or controllable. Uh if you
think of something like you know
like like like a hand the way um the
joint angles work it grips naturally by
its morphology or the way in which the
shoulder joint has a limited range of
motion. Um R Fifer has described like
for instance like this itself is useful
where um if you're reaching out front of
you and not in back of you the things
you reach and you grab are um naturally
brought up to also be seen. And so
things like hand eyeation. So um I think
bodies are uh fundamental in the process
of uh bootstrapping minds and and
developing um basically rich causal
models and where this bootstrapping is
remarkably efficient. um doesn't require
um even though there is a lot of
experience for biological learners. Uh
you don't have to necessarily um
uh biological learners are remarkable in
how efficiently they can learn and how
how much they can learn from so little.
So uh this is part of the reason that I
have interest in common grounds is I
think can be used to demonstrate such
principles by providing agents with
interestingly rich embodiment which can
be part of their learning process. Um
I've also suggested that um embodiment
is uh also important for alignment and
um others have as well in terms of
shared rhythms where um rhythmic
activities are potentially special for
the ways in which they can entrain uh
neurodynamics and attention and through
positive feedback between entrainment
and attention. Uh rhythms can allow for
intense focus on those rhythms. And
where um at their limit they can lead to
um various uh states of mind where
through this intense focus um agents can
experience both um deep affective states
and even um things like self-trcendence
states uh as you might describe in terms
of uh flow uh where the intense
engagement with the rhythm uh allows for
some self processes to be downregulated
potentially allowing for an openness to
the environment and others and maybe in
particular others who you are also
sharing rhythms with. Uh so I think this
is uh you if you think of uh the the
conditions for uh bonding in animals
particularly mammals but not just um
you'll have things like mating song and
dance and the mating act itself where um
engaging in shared rhythmic activities
or and humans um things also birds but
humans um things like music and dance um
these are uh or another kind like a um
in militaries uh um people uh marching
together. Basically shared rhythms seem
to be an important part of uh co-selfing
or developing um
uh a shared interest with others. Um so
>> finally
not quite finally um
among the things that uh I think would
be important to simulate and what we're
looking for in uh in alignment is
something like the development of robust
preferences um something like
orientations and so some of my own work
in effective neuroscience um and the the
nature of preferences and motivations.
I've uh described how um
basically you can arrive at something
like in um robust self-sustaining
preferences or orientations as pullback
attractors through iterative uh action
selection and reinforcement learning or
in active inference terms iterated
policy selection and updating of priors
where the idea is is that if an agent as
it's in the world um engages in a um
selecting different policies for what it
thinks will be more or less likely to
realize value or minimize it's expected
for energy. You then acquire this then
results in updating of your policies
based on how well things worked or not
in terms of their likelihood of
deployment which then influences what
the agent does resulting in likely
patterns of behavior
further going to those areas of value
space further engaging those behaviors
where even more model evidence can be
achieved. So the idea is um you learn
this is what works. this tends to be um
good and you begin to learn this you se
you select actions that are cons that
would be consistent with this and then
you can acquire further um evidence in
this way and if this happens within
sensitive periods of development um even
if not you can get this like critical
mass of model evidence where you have a
pullback attractor where this is just a
robust um model or paradigm of this is
what I ought to do and it's
self-stabilizing the agent doesn't think
to try other things because what is
overlearned to be valuable um or is
overlearned and so uh
becomes robust. So
in terms of you know this idea of like
developing a so on Daltton's talk we'll
get into details of actually how this
potentially could be uh formally modeled
in terms of the canalization of energy
landscapes. So,
but what is it that we would want to uh
canalyze? Uh what what values do we want
to select and um make robust? Um so
things like uh mutual care, tendencies
towards cooperation. Um some people
discuss this idea of like an infinite
game or uh ways of being in the world
relating to others that allows one to
continue to cooperate and coordinate
over time and co-realize value. Um, you
know, can we through this come up with
models of uh and formal models even of
what we mean of seemingly um ethereal
and um uh fuzzy concepts like love like
could we model love as um the
co-empowerment of agents and use uh
formal frameworks like empowerment to
actually um describe uh mutual care. Um
others like um Rutkar Gokuas have um
suggested also um that within active
inference you can get uh views of um
moral orientation that of a quasi
content variety in that if an agent is
pursuing um policies in the future uh
that require um uh deep temporal
sequences to be realized. This will tend
to
necessitate
uh cooperation with others. Like for
value to be realized, for an agent to be
able to predict itself realizing value,
um it must be able to um under uh
optimal circumstances and and
an agent is likely to learn that this is
more likely to be achieved via
cooperation. That actually the selfish
thing to do is to cooperate. This also
relates to some of um I'd say Mike
Leven's work in terms of like cones of
care and uh David and uh Ma will discuss
some of that also. Um and so finally uh
uh Zara and some of the um architecture
she's describing and um some of the ways
she's hoping to deploy them um um
connect to some proposals from uh AI
alignment uh of of how you can have
protocols for alignments um from people
like Stuart Russell and others for um
cooperative inverse reinforcement
learning or um having agents basically
learn to optimize for uh the preference
differences of others. Um to basically
develop things like joint intentionality
as someone like Thomas would call it. Um
where agents learn to have shared or
common goals. Um and then fi finally as
I was mentioning earlier in terms of uh
like the case of shared rhythms uh I
think looking towards the mechanisms of
um
the ways animals bond or um attachment
as it occurs and mammals. Uh this can
potentially give us a uh guide to um uh
understanding the nature of alignment in
uh biological agents and potentially
artificial agents that work by similar
principles. Uh and then
definitely more finally um and both
speaking to Zara's talk and Hanju's
symposium um there might even be an
importance of things like uh artificial
consciousness uh depending on how we
mean in terms of um having different
senses of theory of mind or mentalizing
or um being able to uh understand the
mental states and experiences of others
by reference to your own experience. So
that was a lot and there's even more but
uh I will uh leave it to uh my friends
and colleagues to describe their work
and if you have interest in uh getting
involved with such a research program um
and want to know more about what we're
planning uh please get in contact with
me. uh I and uh
the the the team uh would be grateful to
uh talk to you about what we might be
able to do together and grateful for any
suggestions you might have. So, thank
you so much for your time and attention
and I will take questions.
>> Thank you, Adam. Okay, I'll read
questions from the live chat and then
we'll play the videos from Dimension
people. Okay. mundane bloke wrote, "What
are the infinite games about?"
So um
there is a book called infinite games
and it's contrasting them with uh so
like finite games uh would be something
like um
like a tit fortat situation or like a a
prisoners dilemma situation where um uh
or um something like stag hunt basically
games from economics where uh the the
equilibria the n or the what's
incentivized um depending on the context
might be um either cooperate or defect.
Uh the idea of an infinite game is how
can an agent um
uh how can how can you be
show up in a way that allows the process
of uh playing games to keep going? um
games that don't terminate where you
just uh realize value as a one-off. Um
because in one-offs the the national
equilibria is is oftentimes affected but
rather um games where uh by continuing
to cooperate you can continue to get
nonzero sum uh uh setups and uh bene
mutually beneficial interactions where
everyone comes out ahead and p people
become basically co-empowered or can uh
realize value more effectively by
helping each other to realize value. So
how can um it's an infinite game. The
idea is um you play the game such that
you will keep playing with each other
and keep wanting to cooperate and
co-realize value as opposed to more
narrowly trying to uh achieve a win. But
this might be but then have this be at
the expense of um the possibility of
future cooperation. So this idea of an
infinite game, it's um in some ways
could be viewed as a kind of I guess
moral realism and that um uh the idea
would be that an an ethics of or a a
kind of moral of cooperation and other
concern might actually be um a selfish
uh thing also that um um this is this
could be thought of as a kind of
convergent instrumental value. Um, if
you want to be sustainably, if you want
to be most likely to be empowered into
the future, um, configuring yourself in
your policies you're likely to select,
making those cooperative might be the
best way of, uh, minimizing your
expected free energy or realizing value
into the future. I don't know if that
explains it, but that's uh, roughly the
idea as I understand it.
>> Awesome. And several of the team members
applaud you in the live chat. So, if you
have any other comments, feel free.
Otherwise, I will then go to play the
Common Grounds videos and then the last
few videos.
Any final comments, Adam? Go for it.
Otherwise, thank you. Um
no just uh thanks uh so much for uh
providing this platform and for um you
know I should have actually mentioned
you in terms of we've been in
communication with you about you know uh
what what has been done and what we're
planning and you know to what degree
that within active inference um you know
is what we're doing the ways can
intersect with with other ongoing
efforts like Metagrid um and um
basically
grateful to be uh in the symposium now
and to um be thinking about these things
with you and uh
thank you.
>> Thank you, Adam. I'll ask one final
thoughtprovoking question
from
Obedax.
Adam, would you be able to emphasize the
dichotomy of it all?
the dichotomy of it all.
>> I don't know if they're trying to break
you out of your non-dual frame.
So the
you can think of um there actually among
approaches to alignment
um there's interesting um suggestions
that um actually uh the world's wisdom
traditions and uh contemplative
traditions such as found in uh Buddhism
and uh
other worldviews uh could potentially be
guides to something like alignment and
even super alignment. That um overcoming
dichomous thinking or self other
distinction uh might actually be one of
the things we're looking for in aligning
minds and one of the ways in which minds
like ours when they're aligned they're
successfully aligned. Um I think there's
a lot of merit to this and this is uh I
think present in some of the uh thinking
I've described in terms of ways in which
for instance uh rhythmic activities can
potentially and share rhythms can allow
for basically self-trcendence as part of
alignment. Um but I would also suggest
that uh there are other ways of thinking
about alignment that don't necessarily
involve um uh beforehand um dissolving
dichotoies. So for instance uh you know
the nature of compassion um could be
thought of you know you you potentially
arrive at it by having some sort of like
oceanic state of non-ifference from the
world and others. Um but you can also
arrive at it as um you just learn that
when you're good to others they're more
likely to be good to you and that
potentially the most selfish thing you
could do is to love others. And so
instead of uh initially arriving at this
sort of uh transcendence of dichotomy
between self and other world upfront,
maybe it comes afterwards um from a
process of just learning what works uh
or what tends to work for um making you
feel good um for uh when you when you
interact with others in the world. Uh so
that was an attempt at addressing
dichomousness and how it can play into
alignment or not.
The
>> the more open the question the better.
Okay. Thank you Adam. I will now play 1
2 3 4 5 6 seven videos.
It'll be a a septupal header coming
right up. So thank you Adam. Bye.
>> Thank you.
All right, here come the pre-recorded
videos related to Common Grounds. First
is going to be
the video by Nick Haye. It is a 15minute
video. Here we go.
So I'm going to describe the common
grounds project in general terms. Adam
others will connect it in more
particularly too.
So I'm going to describe the common
grounds project in general terms. Adam
and others will connect it in more
particularly to active inference.
So the general goal of this project is
to build an artificial life simulator
which is designed to simultaneously
support several things at once. First
uh building virtual worlds games that
can be used to bridge humans and AIs
through play
rather than work or other things like
that. It's important
and
secondly
developing a new range of benchmarks for
studying the within the sort of playful
artificial life context the social and
cultural effects of bringing AIs into
the mix. And then third and more broadly
is supporting research and nurturing
developing benevolent embodied AI and
all the different ways we might try to
do that. So simulation and benchmarks
will be released open source
to maximize the ability to do good
research. And
there'll in parallel be a game demo in
the same simulator released on the web
and on
gaming platform Steam to sort of just
test the waters to see if this is an
engaging and interesting
um thing for people. And then basically
the idea of the project is to
iterate and improve on all these three
things. the sim, the broad simulation,
the benchmarks, and then the game.
So, I'm going to talk about the
artificial life simulator, the world,
the nature of the bodies of the
creatures in it and their their
embodiment, and then several sort of
directions you could take it in more of
a morphagenic
u developmental direction or
evolutionary direction or
um multiscale life and touching then
touching a little bit on the 2D versus
versus 3D question and um had to do with
a with a demo.
So, here's some concept art depicting
the world and the creatures in it and
the sort of kinds of
things that are going on. We have um
here we have a
one creature
investigating this this tree here which
has got a little worm on it. Over here
we've got some uh
obstacles, some ball that's come and
block their little houses here which
they they've built for themselves. And
then these two um these two creatures
are trying to remove it. This one is
just kind of chilling and not being very
helpful. So there's various kinds of
coordination and cooperation
problems that very naturally emerge. Um,
here's someone exploring the cave, maybe
trying to find some resources. And then
I don't know what this one's doing. It's
sort of staring at some crystals.
And
when it comes to nighttime, so think of
this as sort of like a
2D physicsbased
Minecraft. Then uh or you know kind of
world like this. Then here all these
creatures have gone into their homes
with some nice warm fire. And then
yeah, they're kind of he's still up
there.
So, one can build worlds in the
simulator that have different
granularity scales
relating how the the
environment
that can be modified by the creatures in
it and the creatures themselves relate.
So here's sort of like a kind of
intermediate or here's here's a scale
where the parts of the world are quite
large compared to the agent. Now here's
one where they're quite small. So this
is sort of like the world is a bit more
like mass-like than sort of discrete
atomic pieces. And here sort of kind of
a middle ground.
So one could choose the level of
granularity that makes the most sense
for u
the kinds of things you're trying to
study.
So a major motivation of this work is
being able to have a a credible but
simplified form of embodiment and in
particular going to have analoges of all
of the senses. some sort of simplified
form. So here we have kind of something
depicting here here's sort of a scene
with the from before zoomed in with the
creature holding a a part of this plant
and the little worms up there eating
some fruit and
it's sort of depicting a picture of
their internal internal state. So for
each piece of them maybe there's energy
levels there some sense of temperature
potential for damage u nutrients there
could be internal organ states um there
could be various forms of viseral motor
interceptive control hormones this is
sort of like um
and then we also have things like
propriception sensing the configuration
of the body the angles of the joints
forces being put on it and and dually
motor control like the ability to
control the desired
uh pose and posture of various body
parts and then stiffness.
There's also touch that comes from
interacting and colliding with the
environment that's sensed on the
different parts of the body. Um there
could be smell which is in
this kind of misoscopic range
corresponds to something like a sense of
the quality of the environment around
the creature which could just be like a
a weighted integral of the kinds of
materials that surround
um surround them. So vision works quite
naturally. Um you can
imagine it as sort of a a ray casting
thing where you um can sense the
distance and material along different
directions.
One can add amounts of noise or not have
distance be directly observed and so
forth. So
this you can kind of visualize it in in
first person. looks like kind of a
a
Wolfenstein 3D on its side. But here you
can sort of see this this part here is
the corresponds to observing the hand.
Here's the the part of this tree they're
holding on right there. Here's some
distant ground and there are some other
um balls right there.
And then finally sound which is
generated by interaction with the world
and collisions and so forth. And there's
various natural ways to to represent
that. So maybe here the
the creatures hearing some sounds coming
from touching and manipulating this
thing here but then also simultaneously
hearing some munching from up there.
So this form of embodiment is rich
enough to
represent uh
a pretty comprehensive range of of
senses.
So as another thing this is sort of the
simulator generally is a
fairly flexible
um
particlebased system. And so one thing
you could look into is
exploring
um
development and evolution of creatures
starting from simpler things which uh
perhaps um bud off other cells that are
connected to each other and communicate
each with each other and and possibly
even have um a more biochemical
sense of how the motor control works.
So another thing you can explore is
intelligence acting on on multiple
scales. So here we have two creatures
synchronously trying to to
carry an object that's too heavy for one
of them.
And one can go out from there to
consider
the behaviors of of groups uh
cooperating groups of creatures. And
then one can go in and consider the
creature themselves being made of cells
that are cooperating and further those
cells as being um made of molecules that
are cooperating to to achieve certain
homeostatic ends. can imagine um sort of
literally simulating various biochemical
processes and in like a um
kind of balls bouncing around and and
having chemical reactions.
So for example, here's a picture of a
food particle absorbing into the cell
and then uh interacting with various of
these different different kinds of
molecules inside. So a question I often
get is why two dimensions why not three
dimensions. Um
the main reason is
two dimensions seems rich enough to
to support a very rich embodiment and is
quite a lot simpler to deal with. Easier
to visualize computitionally cheaper. So
you can
get more done for the same amount of
compute. Um
there are properties of threedimensional
space that two dimensions doesn't have.
Um
but I think a lot of these are are good
enough 2D approximations especially if
you have 2D on its side with gravity. So
I don't want to argue for 2D too
strongly because this is a natural 3D
world. um that's analogous
with 3D balls instead of 2D balls
basically and uh would be a natural
transfer domain from showing things that
maybe have been developed in 2D than
showing that they still uh continue into
three dimensions.
So I'm going to demonstrate some
features of the simulator from the
inside out. So this visualization shows
what two creatures are feeling in a
sense. So the line segments connect
their bodies and are colored based on
how stretched they are and the green
segments show where touch is occurring.
So the bottom you see the feet touching
the ground and here yes you can see some
contact between the joints of the body
uh on the arm. And so this is a frozen
tableau of a creature reaching for a
fruit there in a larger scene with kind
of a worm. And this is a in a kind of
fully modifiable world. You can kind of
there's this crystalline structure of of
tiles you can pick up and move. and they
follow
follow gravity and they influence each
other and um can be used to build up
structures in the environment like kind
of homes and some such and can also be
the sources of um resources. So this
sort of can be kind of um a uh
ecological system in here where maybe
this pink resource is needed for um as
one kind of food that's there and they
have to go into the the mines to find
things.
So there are various ways of uh
interacting with this world to
demonstrate things. You can create uh
moving particles which will do things to
the world and and particularly you can
play around with the uh destructive
forces of very large objects.
So, this shows a worm being piloted and
um the controls are modifying sort of
the shape of the creature and it is
trying to reach those little fruit
berries on the tree and and knock them
off. Um sort of demonstrating part of
what could be the life cycle of this
sort of creature. This is sort of a
zoomed in view again showing the body
sensors of stretches and touch on the
along the worm's body.
So this next part shows how uh visceral
the world can be when you have a body
which can be pinned down and stretched
and deformed by by other parts and
potentially potentially injured. So
there's sort of a very core source of of
value and motivation that comes from
preserving the integrity of your body
and protecting it and and helping others
that are um having some trouble there.
This part is more fun. This is showing
the the emergent physical properties you
get
um or the material properties you get
from having uh particles that have
different kinds of interaction. In this
case, the particles adhere to them each
other. So you get sort of something
which is a
feels a little bit like a a metal or
some kind of you know magnet ball
structure and has properties of
deformability and you know malleability,
forgeability and um
so by varying the basic interactions
between the particles can create a wide
variety of a very rich um set of of kind
of possible situations. And um
this includes also being able to
specify, you can see some on the right,
some of the material properties of the
objects. Um and this includes things
like reactions where
um particles of certain materials will
connect and collide and then form other
particles
like that.
Hi, this is Alex Kefir. Um, thanks.
>> Hi, this is Alex Kefir. Um thanks to um
Adam uh for inviting me to this mini
panel or symposium on the common grounds
project um which I think is very
interesting for modeling some of the
things that I'd like to um that I'd like
to model and do some experiments on um
related to agency and alignment and so
on.
So I wanted to start out by sort of
framing why I think this environment is
interesting. So um so grid worlds um
actually are are fairly interesting in
themselves. So um you can use a grid
world um by which I don't mean
necessarily like a literal grid but just
a simple simulation with some discrete
states. Um you can use these to model um
a number of things in in fruitful ways.
So um obviously like even in a literal
grid like this you encode basic spatial
relationships. Uh you can have simple
sort of or simple to moderately complex
you know um tasks that agents can
execute. you can run batches of agents
that you can vary in various ways. Um
and you can importantly you can control
the um the conditions of experiments in
a pretty easy way because things are
fairly simple. Uh and you can also
examine the results. Uh so these are
interpretable models because of their in
part because of their simplicity. Um
although you know not all of the
behaviors you get out of these models
are simple. So, in fact, like cellular
automa you could argue are um they're
not exactly usually thought of as grid
worlds, but um you know, with a fairly
simple set of rules and a grid-like
setup, you can get some interesting
emergent behavior, but generally uh grid
worlds are good for like coarse grained
uh interpretable models of how agents
interact with their environments and
with other agents. And then on sort of
the other side of the spectrum, you have
um full-on like 3D game engine type
physics simulations. And these are
interesting obviously if you well if you
just want to see like how you know drop
a car from 30 feet and see see what
happens or um you know more usefully if
you have a robot and you want to figure
out like um you're trying to build a
model of how you know fine grained
spatial u manipulation and control works
um then these types of environments are
great for that. Um but of course they're
fairly heavy computationally and they
certainly don't abstract from irrelevant
detail. um in a lot of cases, you know,
depends on your use case. Um but they're
great for like realistic models of of
interactions with the with the realistic
world. Um so one way of framing what I
think is cool about common grounds is
that it's sort of a middle middle ground
um between these between these
approaches. Um, so and I also see it as
just in particular it's like a a very
good fit with the with like the niche of
research that I want to do on um you
might say the sort of um psychopysical
aspects of agency uh which I think are
are
um suitable for studying in like an
artificial life type of environment in
which you have um so I guess the main
salient feature of this kind of
simulation is that the agents have
bodies um not just in like a nominal
sense that like they have some
properties that you keep track of in
some arrays, but they actually have um
there's there is a you know a physical
spatial environment and the internal
structure of the agent um or at any rate
the structure of the agent um and
including its internal structure
potentially is modeled in the same way
as the environment. So you know here
you've got sort of like a cool um
hexagonal type of grid made of spheres.
I mean, it's I'm not making claims in
fine detail about how common grounds
works, but that's this image depicts
something like that. Um, and the body of
this wormlike thing here is made up of
the same types of stuff you'd see in the
environment. So, I think this idea of um
there's a lot of ways of looking at why
embodiment is important, but one way of
one reason it's important is just
because the structure of the agent is
continuous with and it's a part of the
like this. I mean that's true in a you
know um full-on 3D physics simulation as
well but here things are still kept
simple enough that you have discrete
elements you can play with and um you
know a fairly small number of knobs you
can turn
um but I'm particularly interested in
this from the point of view of like
basic research on um things like agency
and um and policy selection because you
can you can model how mental internal
like mental or cognitive structures are
physically realized. So, you know, we
often talk about like mental action. Um,
so, you know, that suggests there's like
really an internal mechanism that
performs an action kind of in a similar
way to how you might perform an action
on the external environment except it's
internal. Um, and I think that's the
kind of thing that you might be able to
model in this paradigm. So, um,
generally the physical foundations of
agency.
So zooming in a bit on some of these
ideas, you can use this kind of
simulation environment to model um
preferences for example of agents um or
homeostatic set points as actual
attractors in an internal dynamical
system. Um, and I think for some
purposes it's fine to just specify them
as like a C vector as a as a a list of
numbers, but you might get really
interesting things. And I'm certainly
interested in in particular aspects of
um how
how it would inform your your models of
agency if you if you explicitly model
those things as attractors. Uh, which
you know, of course, in the in the
bigger picture in the background story
of free energy principle and so on,
that's what they're meant to be. Um, you
could also, and this is probably one of
the things I'm most excited about,
um, is that you could model the physical
realization of mental or psychological
structures. Um, you know, things like
perception, percepts, beliefs, um,
mechanisms for policy selection. So in
this kind of environment, you could
literally build like an internal machine
that executes some task like polic
policy selection for example or belief
updating. And then once you had that
machine, if you also set some physical
parameters and tied them to the way that
these atoms in this universe bounce
around, then you could um so you can
look for example at how the conservation
of energy, you know, physical energy um
impacts belief updating and policy
selection.
Um sorry for the kind of ridiculous
illustration here but I I rolled with
it. Um so
another theme here that I think is
important this this is almost the end as
a short talk. Uh is this idea of
crosscale composition. So um you could
take that in a purely physical sense uh
like agents are built out of physical
things that are built out of other
physical things. But you know um a more
adventurous avenue might be to explore
how agents are composed out of
microaggents. Uh and there's some really
interesting work already um showing for
example that like the phase locked
decisions of microaggents can sort of
lead to emergent behaviors at the at the
macro level. Um
and I think I think that's important
principle for understanding. Um so I use
the term inner alignment on this slide.
Um I realize that has a narrow meaning
in in like AI safety literature sort of
about ensuring that agents learn
internal you know messa optimizers um or
they they sort of that the results
ensuring that the results of their
metalarning remain consistent with the
goals that the designer of the agent had
for them or the objective function that
was explicitly specified. So I think
more broadly though you can think of
this as um inner alignment as sort of a
matter of
um
just being able to what what what
internal control structures are
necessary in order to enable agents to
have to have goals. Um goals that they
really own. not just you know um targets
that are sort of um imposed from without
but like actual goals that they adopt
and to my mind uh making progress on
that requires understanding something
about the internal organization of the
agents how and how it relates to their
behavior. Um so I've argued that this is
important for understanding that you
know differences potentially between um
digitally simulated agents and and
biologically realized ones. But but
whether you agree with that or not um
certainly these principles of crosscale
composition might be interesting for for
un understanding how value and and
desire and things uh operate in in
living agents. Um so thanks for
including me in this in this discussion.
Um these are just some some papers I've
worked on that are um
you know in this in this kind of space.
Um but importantly a lot of them don't
have much modeling work associated with
them yet. And uh it's not easy to create
an environment like this. So I really um
you know I do hope to see common grounds
become like a really a really cool
useful tool in this this space. Thanks.
Hi, I'm David and I'm going to talk
briefly about bounded rationality and
multi- aent alignment.
So to begin with some motivation,
a lot of focus in alignment research is
centered on this question of how do we
align a single potentially superhuman
level AI with humans or humanity.
The big issue here aside from how we
define these things is that there's no
agreed upon solution to this problem and
it seemed like a very difficult one in
general.
On the other hand, a lot of focus in
capabilities research centered on the
question of how we build a single
superhuman level AI system.
The reality is that for such systems
there are significant trade-offs between
performance and cost.
Moreover, AI agents are increasingly
being deployed on the internet to carry
out tasks autonomously over longer and
longer horizons.
Fundamentally, we existed and are
building towards a multi-polar world
which is an ecosystem of many AIs,
humans and organizations all interacting
with each other.
And so a central question here is how do
we ensure that this ecosystem is
aligned, beneficial, efficient and
resilient.
The hypothesis I want to explore here is
that we start from the fact that a major
source of risk from advanced AI comes
from this extreme uninterruptible
optimization towards specific goals.
Now if a significant proportion of the
AI agents in this ecosystem
are highly capable, have access to
significant amounts of resources and are
insufficiently aligned. This could
create destabilizing undesirable
outcomes.
And so perhaps complimentary to working
on alignment, maybe we should also think
about limiting capabilities and
resources within such ecosystems
until and as we progress with alignment.
So what this what could this lead to?
Well, one of our essential hypotheses is
that this could lead to an ecosystem of
specialized, efficient, and reliable
agents all working together alongside
humans to solve problems
much in the same way as we would see
organizations
or societies do.
So, how might we reason about such
systems? Well, one concept that we
propose that's potentially useful is out
of bounded rationality.
So what is bound rationality?
Well, the fundamental idea here is that
real world decision-m is subject to
limitations.
These limitations can come in the form
of limited time, energy, money,
computational resources, attention,
memory, information, etc.
And crucially, decision-m need to take
these factors into account if it is to
be effective in the real world.
Now, boundary rationality was originally
intended as a descriptive model of human
decision-m then was later expanded to
encompass both biological and artificial
decision makers as well as to bridge the
gap between both normative and
descriptive theories of decision-m.
The key mechanism here is that of
satisficing
which is related to finding the optimal
solution in a simplified model or
finding a good enough solution in a more
realistic model.
And we see these kinds of trade-offs
manifest
in the modern day in the form of cost
performance trade-offs especially with
the rise of test time inference. So here
we see several graphs from major AI
companies, researchers and also public
benchmarks that are increasingly focused
on the trade-off between performance on
a certain task or benchmark and the
costs in terms of test time or training
time compute or in terms of dollars for
inference
etc.
So
just for a brief timeline of bounded
rationality,
the concept
really got started with Herbert Simon
who introduced it in the 1950s and wrote
a lot of seinal works on this.
Then sort of the 1970s and 80s, it was
later extended and really fleshed out by
Amos Terski and Daniel Canaman in their
research program on heristics and
cognitive biases. as well as their
distinction between system one and
system two thinking.
Then later in the 90s you have good
gigarenzer who used concepts of an
adaptive toolbox and ecological
rationality
as well as to Russell
who worked on bounded optimality
and you know since then especially in
the 2000s up to now there's a
proliferation of approaches and ways of
modeling this
some of which I'll talk about next.
So one of the key concepts here is
computational rationality
and the basic idea is that we want to
select the optimal program for some
valid machine to execute.
And so you can imagine in this diagram
on the left here, you have some sort of
utility function in an environment from
which you select an optimal program
within a space of feasible programs
and you can study the optimal behavior
for such programs and connected to
observed organism behaviors.
On the right here you see another way of
thinking about this idea of
computational rationality where you have
your utility which is diminishing with a
cost of delays.
And this trade-off means that there's an
optimal
time for you to run your computation
before you select an action.
And a key concept here is that of meta
level reasoning
which focuses on focuses on considering
the current uncertainties the time
critical losses with continuing in
computation and the expected gains in
precision of reasoning with additional
computation.
Now another concept that's been
increasingly
popular in recent years is that of
resource rationality.
And the key idea here is that we were
trying to find the optimal way for an
agent to use its limited resources.
So you can imagine this triangle here
representing a space of possible lines
that are implementable with our brain's
limited resources and on the y- axis you
have performance of these different
lines. The resource rational approach is
to find the optimal one within this
feasible set.
And some of the key steps associated
with resource rational analysis is that
first you define the problem at the
computational level. Then you postulate
a class of algorithms that the mind
might use to approximately solve the
problem.
The cost of computational resources and
the utility of accuracy of the
algorithms.
After that you want to find the
algorithm in the class that best trades
off resources and accuracy.
Then you evaluate predictions of this
algorithm against empirical data. And if
there's a gap, you go back to step one
or two.
Now, another concept within this space
is that of information theoretic under
rationality.
And the key idea here is that we account
for the cost of cognition using tools
and concepts of information theory.
In particular,
agents start with some prior probability
distribution Q over choices and does
some computation or information
processing to transform it into a
posterior P.
And you can measure the cost of this
transformation as the K divergence from
the prior to posterior.
And so agent optimizes an objective
which is an expected utility minus a
regularizer which represents the
information.
So few questions related to boundary
rationality in alignment
in this context of ecosystems is first
of all how do we build these specialized
efficient and reliable agents.
Secondly, how do we coordinate such
agents with each other and with humans
or organizations to reliably and safely
solve more complex problems?
Finally, how do we mitigate the risk
that might emerge critically in the
context of these multiation systems?
Now, our view is that this is an
important research agenda
and we hope that we are able to dedicate
resources and talent towards solving
these important problems.
Thanks for listening.
Hi.
So, Mao and I are going to be uh
presenting some thoughts and ideas that
we have on path flexibility and
collective alignment.
So, to start off with some motivation,
why path flexibility and what is it?
Our starting point is essentially that
approaches to alignment should address
some key properties of the real world
which include non-stationality of the
environment, non-stationality and
diversity of human beliefs and
preferences,
bounded rationality and imperfect
execution of plans, collective and
system level properties
and also the embodiment embodiment and
embeddedness of agents within their
environment.
And so to address some of these issues,
we suggest that we focus on paths and
processes.
And these things would include the
alignment of beliefs and preferences
in terms of how they update and not just
what they are. The ability to
efficiently adapt and recover when
environments or goals shift.
and also the maintenance and flexibility
and optionality over time rather than
rigidity and narrowness. And so a simple
example of this is a lava world example
where agent has to go to its goal and
traverse this pathway where there's lava
on either side. And the basic intuition
here is that the agent should expend a
little bit of extra effort to traverse
the middle path because this provides
them more flexibility and resilience in
case they accidentally slip um to either
side.
So some of the key objectives that we
hope to achieve within our work.
Firstly, to demonstrate the value of our
alignment formalism.
Secondly, to study how path flexibility
and empowerment lead to resilience
and finally to develop methods to
promote path flexibility and
empowerment.
So some key concepts that we find useful
to study and address and define. Well,
first of all, there is past flexibility,
which we refer to as the quantity and
ease of shifting between viable
trajectories for an agent or group. Then
there is empowerment, which roughly
relates to the degree of influence that
an agent can exert on its environment.
There's resilience which is the ability
to recover from and adapt to adversity
through mechanisms of redundancy and
degeneracy.
And there's concept of attractor
difference which is roughly the distance
between agents stable belief or
preference trajectories.
And the key idea here is that the closer
aligned agents attractors are the more
similar their trajectories will be.
And there is plasticity which is roughly
the degree to which beliefs, preferences
or policies can update in light of
prediction errors and changing
circumstances.
There is planning horizon which is also
related to light cone.
Uh which essentially measures the
effective temporal depth and breadth of
active inference or planning into the
future.
And finally, precision control, which is
the capacity to modulate uncertainty
uh including sensory policy or belief
precision.
So some key questions that we want to
address. First of all, how do
coordination and communication
contribute towards path flexibility and
systemwide resilience? Here we
hypothesize that these things come hand
in hand.
Uh second question, how do do high
attractive difference and low plasticity
lead to lower collective path
flexibility?
Thirdly, how is plasticity related to
the ability to recover and adapt after
shocks?
Fourthly, how do the breadth and depth
of planning horizons affect resilience
and are there diminishing returns?
And finally, how do precision
asymmetries and precision control
influence the power to shift attractors?
And so with that, I'll pass on to M to
discuss some of the experiments.
Thanks. So for the experiments for now,
they're explained in grid walls, but
they're meant to then be made a little
more complex to fit the common grounds.
So the first experiment is meant to
establish a baseline of coordination
benefits. um i.e. is there even a point
coordinates um and align and so here we
have a setup with two agents and two
resources with optional communication at
a cost and we're hoping to manipulate
the communication and the shared
observations um to show and to measure
whether there's a higher cooperation
rates um to measure the expendit the
energy expenditure and the path
returnability i.e. uh we expect to show
that communication increases path
flexibility and shared reward.
In experiment two, um now that we've
shown coordination leads to better
outcomes, we must show how it might
arise from our chosen formalism, so
aligning attractors. And so we hope to
demonstrate that alignment emerges from
adaptive preferences rather than just
identical goals. So here we have two
misaligned agents with variable
preference update rates. we're going to
manipulate uh the plicity of their
preference. And so ultimately we measure
the attractor difference, the time to
coordination and efficiency over the
long run. And we expect that higher
plasticity means faster convergence and
ultimately higher joint resilience.
I think the videos are struggling to
run. So do you want me to wait a bit?
>> Yeah, we can skip this.
>> All right. And so in experiment three um
we're trying to demonstrate that
plasticity promotes recovery and
adaptation after shocks. And so we want
to show the mechanisms that underly the
plasticity in question i.e. what do the
agents learn and from where. So we hope
to show that it leads to higher group
resilience and path flexibility which
means recovering from shock and
continuing to thrive. So the setup here
is multi-agent grit world with periodic
shocks. Uh so resource relocation and
noise and the agents learn online from
prediction error. Uh we're going to
manipulate high individual or group
plasticity social posture sharing. So
belief sharing and redundancy versus no
redundancy i.e. whether agents can do
the same thing more or less or do they
have more uh degeneracy. For example,
we're going to measure the recovery
time, the prediction error, the free
energy slope, and the group resilience
index, i.e., are they more resilient as
a group or not? We expect to show that
learning from errors and sharing those
corrections creates faster, deeper
recovery and turn resilience into a
group level property. In the next slide,
um, we ran a short experiment on top of
a paper that Rudy Pitia Jane and uh,
Timber Balon and the rest of their team
at Versus ran on theory of mind uh, with
uh, two resources and basically we were
able to show that um, through theory of
mind and belief sharing the agents are
more able to recover quickly from a
shock. In experiment four
um we want to show that we need to think
in terms of paths and extend the
planning horizons such that we can
maintain path flexibility over time. We
also want to show that planning as a
group yields more rewards because
planning is metabolically costly. So
doing it as a group reduces the
individual cost. So the setup would be
agents with variable planning horizons
facing unexpected resource shocks. We
would manipulate the cost of horizon
expansion. uh the shock um magnitude and
frequency and measure the recovery time,
the performance degradation and the path
survival rate. And so we expect that
extended horizons yield better
adaptation but at a metabolic cost. So
it's better to uh do it as a group.
>> And finally, we want to show that these
are not just chance outcomes. We can
actually manipulate paths and lead to
alignment. So here we test whether power
in multi-agent inference arises from
prediction control rather than just
force. And so we can show that one agent
can modulate another sensory or policy
precision via environmental actions. So
the manipulation here is the control
strength and the target precision type.
And we would measure induced policy
shifts and cooperation rates uh to show
that ultimately we have um the ability
to change the attractors for the agents
to lead them to potential uh similar
paths without necessarily losing path
flexibility. And so here we have uh an
expectation of asymmetric path precision
um distorts the path flexibility of one
of the agents which generates a
dependency or a domination here and
basically just control of one agent of
the over the other.
Great. And so just as a synthesis and
some next steps obviously these are very
preliminary ideas and um there's a lot
of empirical work that remains to be
done. In particular we want to study the
connections between flexibility,
resilience and energy efficiency in more
detail. Uh there are a lot of conceptual
questions
for example linking our findings to
empowerment
particularly on past flexibility
um shed intentionality and other
alignment metrics proposed in literature
uh for implementation
in order to bring in the embodied aspect
um we want to build a prototype in
common grounds with some basic features
to demonstrate how um spatial properties
and embod embodiment affects questions
of path flexibility and resilience.
And finally, the deliverables we hope to
achieve include theoretical
formalizations of the concepts that we
discussed and introduced and some
mathematical results relating them to
each other. Uh further empirical
analyses both in good worlds and in
common grounds and then some data
visualizations.
Thank you.
The uh purpose of this recording is to
show you
a sort of a new view on
engineering systems with uh provably
beneficial or aligned behaviors as the
title suggests. Uh and it will mainly
uh look into
how do we actually predict what systems
do
and how do we use that to our advantage.
So I would I would normally begin this
presentation with a small uh
demonstration.
uh this is a recording so I can't give
the demonstration in in person but uh
this kind of lecture would begin with a
demonstration where I would roll up a
sort of tube of paper uh and make it
into a a kind of canal shape and crumple
another bit of paper into a ball and
roll the paper down the canal
and you would see it drop into the canal
and roll
I would then take the canal and
turn it upwards so that you have a sort
of hill and the ball would drop onto the
top of the hill and then fall off.
And what that demonstration would show
is that there are actually uh
differences in the way that motion is
constrained
by geometry.
So the forces that guide a system to
move
uh are
simultaneously
geometric features of the system uh and
the environment in which it's moving and
also dynamical features uh such as
the forces uh that are shaping their
motion.
One can see this in uh the distinction
between stable equilibrium and unstable
equilibrium states. Uh so if I have a a
ball at the top of the hill, then it
could roll off the hill one way or
another. I don't know. Uh which way
it'll go. It'll depend on some kind of
fluctuations. So that's U1 there. uh if
I have a stable equilibrium like s_ub_1
or s_ub_2 uh it's at the bottom of a
hill then the geometry is constraining
the motion so the the pathway that the
system will take over time is dependent
on uh the setup of the environment that
it's in.
Um this uh sort of
tension between uh geometry and dynamics
uh is captured really well by gauge
theory and correspondingly gauge theory
gives us a way of speaking about how one
quantity uh varies another as it moves
on spacetime.
So engage theory this often records the
way that a force field varies the motion
of a particle and it records the
coupling of bzons which are force
carrying particles to firmians which are
particles that comprise matter
and a really instructive example is that
of gravity under general relativity. Uh
the principle of general relativity uh
is that special relativity the
relativity of motion with respect to the
speed of light can be extended to any
expression of motion which is
accelerating relative to some other
expression of uh that motion. A
consequence of this view is that all
noninertial motion is identical to
inertial motion on a curved surface
which causes some acceleration. This is
called the equivalence principle. Uh and
the equivalence principle was properly
introduced by Albert Einstein in 1907
when he observed that the acceleration
of bodies towards the center of the
earth at a rate of uh 1g. G being the uh
acceleration due to gravity is
equivalent to the acceleration of an
inertially moving body. Uh meaning not
accelerating uh within a frame of
reference. uh that would be observed on
a rocket in free space being accelerated
at a rate of 1g. So if you have a uh a
thing in motion and it's not
accelerating within a frame of reference
that's
perceptually the same as if it were in
motion uh and its frame of reference
were accelerating.
So again this is the equivalence
principle. Uh accelerating reference
systems are physically equivalent to
gravitational fields. As such the
curvature of spaceime is gravity.
Um
one sometimes hears truisms like uh
there is no experiment observers can
perform to distinguish whether an
acceleration arises because of a
gravitational force or because their
reference frame is accelerating. So the
curvature the warping uh the
acceleration due to motion uh is not
distinct from a uh constant velocity no
force motion within an accelerating
reference frame.
Um uh another truism uh due to uh John
Wheeler is that spacetime tells matter
how to move. Matter tells spaceime how
to curve.
And we can see this is uh most uh let's
say
impactful
uh when one looks at a black hole. The
path of a photon uh a light carrying
particle uh on spaceime
is uh warped so strongly by a black hole
that it uh or rather that the path on
spaceime that it takes is affected by
gravity so strongly that it looks as if
gravity is uh completely uh taking
spaceime and pinching it and pulling it
way way down.
So we have this interplay between
geometry and uh constraints and dynamics
and forces.
This interplay has also been useful in
the uh field of biopysics. So in the
work of uh Ken Dill for instance uh it
was discovered that one of the
organizing principles for how proteins
fold is if you set up a kind of energy
landscape and you look at what are the
transitions in states that the protein
can achieve as it goes along
dynamically.
The geometry of the energy landscape
turns out to constrain what the protein
does and it allows you to make
predictions about how the protein will
fold uh as it continues to go along and
experience confirmational changes. This
was a a big advance in the '90s in uh
bioysics in protein folding uh because
there were no good overarching
principles for how proteins fold. uh but
uh the work of of Ken Dill uh gave us
one such principle uh which is that the
uh the loss surface so to speak uh
between energy and entropy uh is
determining how the protein uh folds and
it looks as if it's sort of uh a bunch
of skiers uh going down a hill. So they
take the path of least resistance. They
take the most natural path afforded to
them and the interplay between energy
and entropy and the geometry the
curvature that uh that interaction
evinces is what actually guides the
notion of resistance.
This is true also in uh genetics in uh
the theory of epigenetic expression.
Uh there is
the uh notion of Wington's landscape and
it looks like a marble rolling down a
hill.
What people uh often
use this analogy for is saying you have
uh set before you a bunch of possible
paths of genetic development and your
system is the marble and as it's rolling
down the hill uh it gets caught in one
or another canal and that canal it gets
caught in is what determines the
epigenetic expression and therefore its
phenotypic traits. But underlying the
actual curvature and therefore
underlying the dynamics of gene
expression
are a whole web of interactions
uh that determine what kinds of
expressions are allowed, what kinds of
expressions are uh admissible or which
kinds of expressions require a large
burst of energy.
uh that would need uh that would be
needed to get you from one free energy
canal uh in the landscape into another
one. So you can see in in this figure
there are a whole bunch of pegs and
trusses shaping. In uh some recent work,
I proved a theorem that says that
actually uh inference in general has
this property. uh when you are trying to
infer the probability
uh being assigned to different states uh
if you have a sense of the constraints
on the probability uh or the constraints
on the preference of how likely or how
desired a state is then that constraint
function gives you a surface and there's
a very nice very well understood
onetoone mapping between the geometry of
the constraint surface and the resulting
probability density over the state
space. So you can see in uh figure
subfigure a I have my constraint
landscape. It's it's a sort of distance
function. It says that as I get further
out from the the center um my penalty
increases. It becomes much greater.
If I look at subfigure B, I have all
these level sets of
equrained
states. So states with similar
preferences
uh and and those are the states that are
available to me if I designate a level
set of constraint value. I say um my
preference for the state is going to be
uh such and such. I have whatever
tolerance I'm going to give myself uh
for getting away from the center.
Uh and then these rings are all of those
level sets of equal constraint value. In
figure C, I can see myself projecting
those rings down onto the state space.
So now these are all of my states of
equal constraint value uh with the uh
constraint surface overlaid on them
highlighting those rings. And then in
subfigure D I see how the idea of
maximum entropy is actually a geometric
procedure that converts the geometry of
these level sets into a probability
distribution. So that the
equally constrained level sets are
equiprobable level sets. And the
curvature that affects my sort of uh how
radical the change in preference as I
move in some direction is that gets
converted to a log probability gradient
or in other words a surprisal.
So what is afforded to me by this
technology
is a deeper understanding of how systems
which
are
making decisions about what states are
preferable and what states are not and
then evolving according to those
decisions. Uh what is afforded to me by
this technology is um a description of
such systems uh as though they were
marbles rolling down a hill. I'm
afforded some geometric description of
those systems.
So before I move on to that, I I just
want to say um the the ultimate goal is
to then map out the geometry of such
spaces and start to make predictions
about how complex systems are going to
move in their state spaces using the
knowledge afforded to me by the mapped
out geometry of those state spaces.
Some other
interesting things that uh this gives me
access to are uh you'll recall we made
this analogy to uh gauge forces. Uh well
gauge forces
they they are sort of abstract
mathematical things that relate
curvature to
forces. They relate geometry to
dynamics.
But they're physical things as well,
right? The um
the notion of a gauge bzon is a physical
force carrying particle that actually
tells you how a force creates a
curvature. How does a force being
applied warp spaceime? How does geometry
get created by dynamics?
So these are things you can go out and
measure in nature.
Uh and that means this gives us certain
knobs to turn.
So for instance, if we're looking at
engineered biological systems,
uh there are observations of localized
uh excitations in those tissues uh that
actually look like what mathematicians
would call solutons. And solitical
excitation. They're a type of gauge
bzon. So this gives you a knob to turn
in the sense that now you can go look at
uh here's the uh excitation
corresponding to this kind of intended
evolution
if I want to bring about a different
kind of evolution.
uh what do I need to modify in my
observed excitations and how can I
continue to probe and uh change the
excitation being expressed until I get
uh my system into the right canal.
A lot of parallels are drawn for me uh
to Michael Leven's work on bioelectric
signaling networks uh where it is shown
that the thing that mediates how
uh systems evolve through morphological
space. The thing pointing to
states in morphological space and the
thing uh mediating transitions between
those pointer states uh is a bioelectric
signaling network. And this is something
that is very easily accessible by human
beings by scientists, experimenters and
so on. Uh and can be directly modified
if we can model it as an electrical
circuit. Then we can ask well what
happens if I pass a current of this
voltage uh with this direction through
the through the uh circuit. Um how does
the system then evolve? And if we've
mapped out morphological space then we
can go on and start making predictions
about how that mapping uh carries the
modification through.
With respect to alignment, I'm I'm very
excited about the prospect of looking at
complex systems and saying
I'm going to map out the geometry of
this systems possible evolutions.
I'm going to infer some utility function
or some constraint function telling me
well what does the system prefer?
What are the kinds of states the system
wants to visit? How does it want to
visit them?
Once you have that geometry
and if you have physical knobs to turn
um relating to a description of that
geometry by some mediation, some
dynamical mediation gauge bzons for
instance. If you have that and you have
a knob to turn, then you can start
manipulating that geometry. you can
start coaxing the system to evolve
towards other states. Right? If you have
the preference function
derived from mapping out this geometry
and you also have the knob to turn, then
you know exactly what you're doing. You
know exactly how to tell the system to
say
um I would rather prefer this over that.
So as an alignment problem when we refer
to engineering systems with provably
beneficial behaviors what we really mean
is figuring out what is the uh
preference or reward function
determining those behaviors getting that
out of the geometry inferring that
mapping that and then taking some
intervention that reassigns those
preferences. So if we can find the
preference function, we can modify it to
say for instance uh to avoid a paperclip
situation to say you know I want you to
pursue world peace. Um but don't just
have pure pragmatic value. Don't just
say okay the path to world peace is to
eliminate all humans. Uh no you
have the preference function. we can see
what would it take to introduce some
sort of Asimov's three laws or
something. What would it take to make
the system think pursue world peace but
don't harm humans in the process?
So ultimately this is all about mapping
the evolutions of complex systems with
an eye towards
understanding what does it look like to
teach and mentor
uh artificially intelligent systems. How
can we increase the synergy between
biological and artificial intelligence?
So I hope this was compelling. Um I'm
personally very excited by this research
program and the way that it involves a
lot of very pure mathematics, very pure
geometry and dimensal systems and very
forwardslooking futurism
uh and
tackles some of the the biggest uh most
important existential questions of our
time.
So thank you for listening. Uh, and if
you have any questions, uh, please write
me an email, uh, or,
uh, get in touch with me some other way.
I, I'd be happy to, to chat with you
about anything that might have piqued
your interest.
Hello, my name is Zara Shakbai. Today I
will talk about a specialized modular
architecture for collective intelligence
and briefly about Hello, my name is Zara
Shakbai. Today I will talk about Maple,
a specialized modular architecture for
collective intelligence and briefly
about our in progress stream to explore
world model architecture. Both project
are inspired by active inference and aim
to build um social and uncertainity
operation that can better align with
human values. This work is a
collaboration between the institute for
advanced consciousness studies mil and
university of Montreal.
Instead of chasing
abstract AGI in the usual way, my work
focuses on what I call social neuro AI
and um brain inspired architecture.
We take the brain as a modular pilot
system and we use active inference idea
to treat each module as an implicit uh
model of the world and other agent. The
big idea is that human compatible
intelligence must be social from the
start with architectural law prior that
favor poor social behavior theory of
mind and mutual modeling.
Let me start with uh how complex social
behavior emerge
um and how has been studied today. Um in
open AI hide and seek environment which
was published in 2020. Selfplay create
creates an autocurriculum of strategies
like run chase build for use ram defend
ram and so on. Um team learn
um to use tools and division of labor
but each agent is still uses a single
monolithic policy network and the
internal structure of these strategies
is opaque and it's not interpretable.
Roma take a a step toward a structure by
explicit modeling rules. Each agent
sample a role from its observation,
condition its policy on the role and
regularize the
um
by that and push roles to be
identifiable, compact and specialized.
This allowed them to in to have more
interpretable division of rap labor but
rules are still imposed in a top-down
way rather than emerge directly from a
modular architecture.
Our core idea is that big monolithic
network entangle everything. So any
change becomes risky and unpredictable.
If one part breaks, the whole system can
lose its ability. In contrast, true
collective intelligence from ants to
human relies on diverse experts.
Decentralization and knowing who needs
to track whom. We want systems that look
more like a team of a specialized
mechanism that share only a sparse
information. So adaptation stay local
and robust.
To get this kind of specialization, we
built on recurrent independent mechanism
or rims. Instead of one big recurrent
neural network, we use several smaller
recurrent modules and each module has
its own hidden state and its own
parameter. At each time step, we run an
input attention phase. Every module send
a query. The input gives keys and um
values and top case selection decide
which modules actually receive and
process the information. Only those
active modules update their hidden state
through their recurrent cell. For
example, a small GRU
while the inactive one simply keep their
previous memory. Then we run a
communication attention phase where
active module use query key and value
over each other state. So they can
exchange a small amount of information
before going back to mostly independent
dynamic. This gives us a sparse
activation, a sparse communication and a
natural way for u modules to be a
specialized.
Our first um maple architecture that we
introduce here is the rim only model
which is also our best performer. Each
agent gets um an egocentric pixel
observation for the policy and a global
observation for the value which we pass
through a normal CNN encoder. The
encoder features then goes into a rim
and the combined state is used to
produce both policy and the value. Over
time, different rim can specialize in
tracking different aspect of the
environment or other agent um giving us
a modular social polic policy. We also
use uh independent PPO as uh our multi-
aent architecture base. The second
architecture aim for a stronger
interpretability and objectentric
reasoning. Instead of a standard
encoding, use a slot attention to factor
the scene into a set of latent slot
where each slot tend to represent an
object or entity. We then feed each slot
into its own recurrent module again a
rim unit so that objects are tracked
over time through dedicated memory
pathway. This makes it easier to to say
things like this module is tracking the
opponent and this slot holds the share
resource information.
For this to work, the slot feature
themselves must be high quality. We
pre-train a slot encoder using
reconstruction and a compositional
consistency
loss on data collected from the
environment. So the same object is
mapped to similar slot across different
scene.
The Tessani plot in the latent state of
the slot here shows the initial result
slots are
starting to separate but clusters are
messy and overlapping which push us to
design a strandic a stronger
inductive biases
to sharpen these representation in the
latent space and make them more cluster.
We introduce our perceptual orthogonal
projection loss or POPL.
POPPL encourage different slot to be
distinct. Push class center to be
orthogonal
and pull features towards their center.
Different object type or rules should
sit in orthogonal direction in feature
space and each type should form a tight
uh cluster. After adding POPL, the TES
plus in the latent space should clean
well separated cluster which gives our
rim a much more disentangle objectentric
input. So this avoid the interference
between what um gets inside each of the
rim module. This object centric is not
tied to a single game across very
different melting pot environment like
alopatic harvest and territory room P O
L still produce clear clustering and
disentangle feature in each slot. This
suggests that we are
learning a shared object vocabulary that
can transfer at across social games and
can later be reused in benchmark
like meta and common ground.
Once a single encoder is pre-trained, we
copy it to all agent and allow only the
highle representation to be fine-tuned.
But we face a Classic stability
plasticity dilemma.
What does it mean? We want to adopt the
high level features of a slot during the
RL task, but we do not want to forget
the useful object
structure they learned during the
unsupervised
uh pre-training. To manage this we
freeze low-level feature and finetune
only highle selected layers which by
adding elastic weight consolidation popl
clipping and normalization. These tool
protect important weights keep slot
representation disentangle and still
allow the policy to adapt to each social
environment.
Here we compare our two maple structure
side by side. The rim only model use a
simple encoder plus rim
and it's fast, lightweight and very
strong in performance. It's good default
when you care mainly about robustness,
sample efficiency in complex game. This
lottery model is more complex
um because it requires pre-training and
carefully fine-tuning but in return it
give us interpretability objectentric
slot and clear specialization of modules
from end to end. So we think of it as a
model for analyzing, auditing and
reusing a skill especially when safety
and alignment are priorities.
We evaluate maple on melting pot which
is designed to test generalization and
collective intelligent. We focus on
three environment that form a ladder of
social complexity. First territory room
as low complexity spatial competition
with nine agents mostly working in
isolation. Repeated prisoner dilemma as
a mixed motivated game with eight agent
and alopathic harvest as a high
complexity coordination problem with 16
agent. If modular architecture really
support social cognition, the benefit
should be most visible in the harder
environment.
This slide shows reward over training
for each architecture. Our room only uh
model is green. The slaughtering model
is yellow and monolytic baseline like
GRU and transformers which are used as
um memory in the policy networks are in
the other colors in both territorial and
prisoner dilemma. The modular model
learn faster and reach higher return
than baseline. In alopathic harvest the
the gap is the same. Modular agent
achieve achieve a stable high reward
while monolithic network mostly fail to
coordinate in the complex environment.
Now we are testing the scaling law and
we ask whether performance is just about
adding more parameter. We vary the
number of rim unit and how many can be
activated at once. We find that more
modules helps only when activation stays
sparse. When everything is activated all
the time, performance drops slightly. So
it's not just capacity but capacity plus
a sparity.
Structure interactions matter much like
having a bigger team of expert who do
not all talk at once and they can
communicate efficiently.
Um
to look inside the network we
evaluate our model with using uh
conditional mutual information as a
metric. Uh CI ask how much information a
given module
K in agent I holds about the actions of
agent J beyond what is explained by its
own actions.
In other words, it quantify how much a
module is modeling another agent's
behavior which is a proxy for theory of
mind processing.
As social complexity increases across
these three games, we see CMI value
rises and spread across more module
showing that the network allocate more
capacity to more complex environment and
more clustering
and specialization between agent.
Um we can visualize this as heat map
where rows are modules and um columns
are other agents actions. Some module
light up across many agents and look
like coordination
between agent other track a specific
partner or norm violation like monitors
and sanctioners. Um some are more
sporadic like free rider. This
connection back to Roma instead of
adding explicit role parameter we see
role emerges from interaction of modular
dynamic in the environment. So we move
from blackbox emergent strategy to
monolytic interpretable picture of
collective intelligent inside our multi-
aent system.
So again putting
this all together mapel gives us a small
toolkit. If you want maximum performance
and efficiency in complex multi- aent
task, rim architecture alone is usually
the best choice. If you focus on
interpretability t object centric and
reusable skill for alignment and
auditing, a slot plus rim is more
attractive.
I see them as complimentary simple rim
for
everyday deployment a slot based rim for
probing intervention and safety
research.
These architectures are also well
matched to upcoming benchmark like meta
and common ground. Meta AI aim at
open-ended multi- aent cooperation and
alignment with agent embedded in the
nested social circle. Common ground
emphasize richer embodiment
and multi-cale models of bodies and its
rhythm dynamic.
To succeed the agent needs both a strong
internal world model and modular social
machinery which leads us to the second
part of talk our dream to explore
aiming.
Maple gives um agents a social brain at
the policy level but they still need a
deep theory like generative model of the
world itself.
Amy, our dream to explore architecture
is a single agent world model that learn
to imagine possible counterfactual
future trajectory and plan in the this
latent space that it learns through
learning a world model. It follows
active inference idea. The world model
is trained by minimizing free energy
objective and control is learned through
imagination rather than risky real world
trial and error.
With Amy, an agent can dream thousands
of candidate future trajectory in its
latent space, including bad and
catastrophic one, and learn to avoid
them without even enacting them in
reality. So Amy provide the um explicit
generative model and imagination engine
needed for robust planning while Maple
provides an implicit model uh for
modular social machinery needed for
social cognition.
Let me briefly sketch Amy architecture
instead of a simple gausian prior which
is usually used in variational model and
it uh suffer from mode collapse. We use
a dish process causian mixture model as
the latent prior. Uh we also add a
bottom up attention posterior from the
current image and a top down attention
prior for the latent state and context
to mimic an attention schema
uh process. During training we ask the
prior and posterior attention to agree.
So the model learn both what will happen
and where it should focus next given
current action.
The nonparametric prior can grow new
mixture component when the environment
become more complex. So it can represent
futures like either outcome A or outcome
B instead of one blurry average and it
gives better uncertaintity on their
distributional shift.
Uh for dynamic we use variational
recurrent models uh and we add perceiver
inspired temporal context model. The
perceiver reads full trajectory through
a
to and use its bottleneck
um as a context vector
which condition both inference and
learning the transition dynamic. During
training we use a variational posterior
and teacher context.
uh and during imagination we sample from
uh dishly process gia mixture prior and
roll out future using a learn causal
student context predictor.
On top of this world model, we train
adversarial guided active critic purely
in latent imagination
that produce with this generative world
model and um it improves exploration and
robustness compared to a standard
dreamer style actor model.
So to wrap up we have two main pieces.
Maple give us modular brain inspired
implicit
world model architecture for multi- aent
system with a clear evidence of emergent
specialization and increasing social
modeling as environments become more
complex. Aiming gives each agent a rich
prob probabilistic
explicit world model that can imagine
and plan over uncertainity
of a future trajectory in the latent
space instead of acting blinding in the
real world.
So many existential risky stories assume
a single opaque monolithic super
intelligence that we cannot in interpret
or control. Our work points to a
different path. An ecosystem of modular
interpretable agents with a strong
inductive biases inspired by mamalian
brain for cooperation and mutual mod.
If we design these architectures
carefully for from the start, alignment
can become an uh emergent property of
the whole society of Asia, not just the
patch we add at the end. So I see these
um modular world model based
architecture
as a concrete reason for hope a password
AGI that is plural understandable and
fundamentally
built for cooperation. Thank you for
your attention.
Hello everyone. This is Sanjapi. Thank
you for being here. It's a pleasure to
share this talk with you.
First of all, I would like to take this
opportunity to express my gratitude to
everyone um who has worked hard to
organize and prepare the symposium.
Thank you so much.
So the title of my talk is modeling the
emergence of perspective an active
inference account of intentionality.
But um before getting into the main
part, I have to admit that I spent quite
a bit of time thinking about what I
should show and share with you today
with while preparing this presentation.
Since this month, I've officially joined
the active inference institute as a
research fellow. So I wanted to share
some of the research agendas I hope to
pursue as a member of the institute but
also wanted to make sure that this talk
resonates within the spirit of the
symposium and um which feels engaging
for everyone participating. So um after
much thought I decided to shape this
talk not as a report of any finished
results but rather as a reflection on
why I have come to walk uh come to walk
this path and what kind of inquiries I
wish to continue exploring within this
community.
So rather than diving immediately into
technical details, I'd like to focus on
a few broader framing questions that
include why should we study
consciousness, why consciousness
matters, and how might phological
insights meet uh computational modeling
under active inference framework and um
why this convergence crucial for
addressing the agent alignment, the
social alignment problems including the
AI alignment. ment and most importantly
how can active inference serve as a
framework in this process.
It's hard to answer exactly what will
emerge through the work and some of I
think perhaps that uncertainty might be
part of the process but my aim here is
simply to be honest as I have always
tried to be in my own research journey.
So I often introduce myself as a
consciousness researcher and I think
it's worth now to share a bit about how
I came to walk with this path and why I
continue to stay on it. So personally I
have had a kind of lifelong question on
why can we never fully access another's
inner world or why such subjective and
personal experience are ineffable and
unreachable.
This question began from reflecting on
the isolation of experience. That is, no
matter how we deeply we empathize, we
can never actually know what is it like
to be someone else. Each of us is
enclosed in our own private polia so to
say.
So I started to wonder how did the
subjective living experience arise in
the first place and is it truly
something that can never be shared and
why do such subjective living experience
like suff like including suffering and
joy uh seem to have such purely
intrinsic and private urgence. So um
those who live in flammness are clear to
me that they cannot be simply reduced to
behavior or m functionality. So there is
something irreducibly first person about
it. That is experiencing is something
about having a perspective of mind.
So to have subjectivity is to have a
perspective and to have a perspective is
to inhabit one's own universe. Each of
us in that sense lives within a world
model that is uniquely of our own. And
then communication what we call
understanding or alignment or even
attunement is in its heart a meeting
between universes I would say.
So it is not about controlling or
synchronization but it's about resonance
or attunement between perspectives. So
even though we can never become another
person, we can still affirm their
universe. We can recognize the limits of
our own role models and respect the
plurality of values and perspectives
that arise from this.
In essence, alignment is all about
perspective and resonance. So it is less
about govern governance under law and
order but about more about honoring the
uniqueness of each way the world can be
experienced and this I believe is where
consciousness research and the alignment
problem truly meet.
So uh for instance, people who rescue
refugees in the Mediterranean often say
that um even though they know rationally
speaking their work may be futile in
many ways by many reasons but yet once
they meet and resonates with the sheer
urgency of the refugees by you know
looking into their eyes and share that
physical space together they say they
that they simply can't stop doing what
they do.
But well, I'd like to say that this is
not unique to the case of material
refugees. So if we look across a wide
range of so social conflicts from the
struggles of underrepresented under
represented minorities to the realities
of war, we often find that what's
missing is precisely this experiment
experiential resonance. So many
conflicts arise when we fail to realize
in a lived in a felt sense that the
author is also a human being, someone
just as real and alive as ourselves.
So um here one could you know of course
imagine developing a program of
something like a phenomenology and
practice quote unquote to cultivate such
resonance. But for the purpose of this
talk for now, I just want to emphasize
that this is exactly where my own
research uh research on consciousness
began. And um it is also why I believe
that understanding consciousness is
indispensable for addressing the problem
of social alignment. Well, pro-social
alignment or what I sometimes call
pro-social attunement.
Again, understanding consciousness is
ultimately what allows us to imagine
aligned and coherent agents whether
human or artificial. So when we talk
about alignment whether in social
context or in artificial intelligence
the discussion often centers around
reverse goals and accuracy but I believe
alignment is at its core not just a
technical problem of control or
optimization is more of a problem of
orientation and maturity. So um most of
social discord and misalignment arise
not because people lack information but
because they lack perspective. So there
is a kind of poverty of perspective
which is essentially a failure to grasp
how another another mind or another
world model is structured and felt. So
if we really want um aligned systems, we
need models that encode perspective that
reflect epistemic norms on how Asians
come to know and effective stance on how
they care and feel.
So here the science of consciousness
grounded on phnology gives us a way to
understand subjective experience in a
principled and non reductive manner
through agent-based modeling especially
within the framework of active
inference. We can simulate the agents
that self-organize intrinsic value and
perspective rather than being externally
controlled by reverse or imposed
objectives. So this would let us able to
um model how agents evolve and um evolve
and adapt together not from not through
reduction or one-sided control but
through mutual constraint and resonance.
So in the long run, my research vision I
would say might be closely linked with
integrating nominology and active
inference in a computational manner to
explore sentience about as something
emergent and relational and situational
and bound in context. And eventually for
future visual systems this could mean
modeling how perspective forms, how
epistemic autonomy develops and how the
um effective embedding that means the
capacity to deal with um becomes an
integral part of intelligent agent.
Now let's take a look at what might be
required to realize the computational
phenomenology.
In some of my previous work, I proposed
a framework that attempts to unify four
different major um major theories of
consciousness based on phological
analysis. That is main theories tend to
describe only partial aspects of
consciousness almost like the blind men
touching different parts of an elephant.
I won't dive in too deep here, but the
paper's point is was that all the four
different theories are in fact
describing different features of
conscious experience. That means none of
them are entirely wrong in an
ontological sense since each each
captures a partial truth of conscious
mental process.
So building on this unified framework,
what I now hope to do is to model the
minimal conditions of mind or um of
perspective perspective itself um as a
step toward an active inference
framework based computational
phenomenology.
Okay. So before I go any deeper um I'm
sure many of you are already familiar
with this concept. Um but let me just
start from very briefly introducing what
what is the phology. Um when when I
speak the speak the word out this I
argue phnology is important in doing the
science of consciousness because
consciousness essentially is an umbrella
term. So it is important to discuss what
exactly is the conscious um conscious fa
that we are interested in and want to
want to describe and um I argue
conscious is not just the qualia or not
just awareness but um every aspects of
the entity of the experience.
So um basically phenomenology is a
philosophical view that begins with fa
which means um the living experience as
given. So taking the experience as given
means that we should analyze the
experience as itself instead of
pre-implying anything before the
existence of our experience.
So the for cons for um conscious agent
the experience is equal to the world and
it is not something that should be
described through some external
framework.
So this intuition is from the discovery
that first person view always exists
before the objective third person view
that we can we cannot essentially escape
from the first person view no matter
what we do.
So intentionally intentionality here
means that every conscious experience is
constructed through the first person
attitude and situation. For example, if
we are in a pessimistic attitude,
uh actually let me bring the framer
figure here. Uh have filled the cup of
water here would be seen as half of the
water has gone. So um the is it blue
blue colored uh part is part represent
pessimistic attitude and the yellow
colored part would represent optimistic
attitude.
Um so well pessimistic attitude half of
the water has gone. Well under
optimistic attitude that this half half
filled glass um cup of a cup of water
would be seen as half of the water is
left and this difference results in
totally different quality of experience.
Um so our experience cannot really
escape from the intentionality
but typically phology by itself explains
the embodied nature of mind
uh through by always starting from the
experience itself. So um I would say
this also plays huge significance to
emphasize phological discoveries when
studying consciousness.
uh and this is the framework that I
proposed uh which is basically built
upon the properties discovered through
phenomenological research methods that I
just introduced. So this diagram here
illustrate a conscious agent finding
themselves in a lab environment and
spotting a half-filled glass of water
which is their current focus of
attention.
um while on one hand perceiving it under
a pessimistic point of view and the
another on the other hand perceiving it
under optimistic point of view. So this
uh this different point of view is
defect depicted as different intentional
quality
which give rise to different conscious
experience left and right while having
same objects at as the intentional
matter. So here conscious experience A B
and C is also different to one another
depending how much this agent is deeply
interacting with environment. So if the
agent is closely closely interacting
with um the cup of water like holding on
to the glass and observing it that
experience with the depict the cup of
water in a much more vivid uh manner and
as it's quite literally or graphically
presented the vividity of the cup would
mix in and decrease when the agent is
not actively engaging in the cup of
water.
So here I point out four big properties
of consciousness that necessarily should
be included and investigated through any
theories of that intends to explain
conscious love. So the first is very
reflective self acquaintance.
That mean that means every conscious
individual recognize their own uh
conscious experience as belongs to their
own whatever experience it could be that
very experience always belong to our
themselves or ourselves. Uh which means
uh not to some other person than I. So
um importantly this does not require any
secondary or higher order reflection in
realizing. So the name pre-relect
pre-reflective self-acquaintance.
Second is contextualized and
environmentally situatedness
basically consciousness is a dynamic
process of interacting interpreting the
surrounding environments. So our
experience of rather relative than being
absolute. So this would naturally lead
to the third aspects aspect um which is
called the spatial temporal
expandability.
uh this points out that our conscious
experience is something that is
continuous and expandable with regards
of surrounding environment both
spatially and temp temporarily. So the
conscious experience could be depicted
as the layered contour graph uh more
specifically the contour surface of this
diagram um and putting bodily self or
the pre-reflective self recognition as
the very core.
The last part uh basically describes um
agency.
A conscious conscious being those can
apply reflective analysis to their own
experience would inevitably possess the
agency of shifting um attention and the
ability to apply selective attention
under their own volition.
This could implo um involve multiple
levels of shifting from simple
perception to meta awareness.
Now let's talk about active inference.
In my opinion, active inference
framework provides a powerful foundation
for applying phological discoveries in
an effective way
because it offers a way to formalize
systems that are self-organizing and
values forming. that means systems that
maintain themselves through intrinsic
preference formation uh rather than
being driven by purely external rewards.
So within this framework um
intentionality which is a basically key
concept and phenomenology can be
understood as a kind of hyper prior that
shapes an agent's behavioral dynamics.
Similarly, similarly pre-rele reflective
self-acquaintance in phological terms
naturally connects to the body schema or
bodily um uh up to bodily sensation. So
um active empress framework based on
free energy principle specifically uh
provides a computational handle on this
uh suggesting how embodied states
continually update the agent's generated
model itself
and as the models evolve an agent's
world model naturally expands spatial
temporally contextually and socially um
reflective how perspective unfolds from
immediate sensation to broader
situational awareness well and including
shared meaning which is essentially what
it literally means by act of emperence.
So um I kind of skipped over this part
when I was talking about the theories of
consciousness earlier but to be specific
um active infer space predictive uh
predictive processing framework doesn't
directly explain the formation of
process of qualia itself in full detail
but what it can do is model the
conditions for qualia and subjectivity.
So basically modeling is a
self-organizing dynamics that makes
subjective experience possible in the f
first place and um since what I'm trying
to do as a first step is to model int
intentionality or so-called perspective
as a minimal form of subjectivity. I
believe active inference framework
offers significant uh theoretical
advantage for that purpose also. Um this
is a whole another branch of research
that I didn't go through in this talk
but um it's worth noting that this
framework can coexist conditionally with
integrated information theory which
directly address the formal structure of
qualia. So following active inverse
framework doesn't mean rejecting or
ignoring the exist existence of kia
rather I see it providing a theoretical
space where the dynamics of subjectivity
can complement these structural
explanations offered by um IoT.
Another benefit of modeling according to
your active inference framework is um
that it allows agent alignment to be
handled in a more natural way within a
simulation environment. So active
inference allows us to model artificial
agents without hard coding their
behaviors. So instead of scripting what
an agent should do, we can simulate the
environment which includes the context
in in which the agents act, learn and
adapt and let the agent well basically
itself emerge agents itself emerge from
the dynamics of self-organization.
So um in such simulations agents don't
simply follow the fixed of set uh fixed
set of instructions.
They adapt and grow within the context
defined environments continuously
updating their uh internal models in
relation to what surrounds them. So in
other words, their intelligence and
value model is situated.
And the same logic applies to the social
dimension. When multiple agents
interact, their goals and values begin
to co-regulate over time through uh
through repeated interaction. what we
might call empathy or altruism can
emerge slash evolve in a natural
sequence as each agent learns to attune
its internal model to others in its
social environment.
So in this way, active inference allows
agent alignment to be handled much more
naturally within a simulation
environment as an immersion property of
relational dynam dynamics not as a con
uh constraint arbitrarily enforced from
the outside.
Now we move on to the step one
perspective modeling. So when I would
when I use the word perspective, I refer
to something that deeply tied to what
phalomnology calls intentional quality.
I describe this as being, you know,
optimistic versus pessimistic from this
illustration. Um in computational terms
we can think of this as how an agent
assigns the informationational value to
the things it encounters like different
subjective experience arising from the
same intentional matter such as the
half- fil glass of water. This
difference technically can be roughly
captured by assigning task dependent
loss functions. But that approach still
require hard- coding the agent's
preference structure in an arbitrary
way. So instead if we decide to explain
this regarding active inference grounded
in the free principle
these kind of preferences can be modeled
as arising spontaneously through the
agent's own inferential dynamics.
In other words, instead of prescribing
whether the agents should see the
glasses half full or half empty, the
active inference framework would would
enable the agent to develop its own
epistematic and epistemic and effective
stance based on how it minimize the
price in its unique environment so that
we could computitionally model the
perspective as an emerging property of
self-organized intentionality.
So here I believe this diagram would oh
sorry this diagram would better depict
the sequence what I just explained. Uh
so here we can model the experience of
different quality. So intentional
quality under context like dislike
indifferent just as like the context of
being optimistic versus pessimistic.
uh we can model each each experience
being different
uh being different
uh sort of probability distributions. So
here the whole idea is that we could
represent each different um intentional
quality as certain probability
distributions. So here the subjective
experience of same intentional
intentional matter uh which would be
well we
um have flat filled a cup of water
probably um over different intential
quality is simply put as the conditional
probability um we can essentially
express this as different generated
models under active inference framework.
So um here each generate model should
share the same hyper prior which would
resemble the bodily sense bodily sense
of self of this agent or pre-reflective
self-acquaintance.
Um also please note that prediction
error minimization and basian update is
not uh specified on this diagram.
So if we ask how perspective can be
modeled computationally perhaps the
simplest way to describe it would be
something like this. So if we draw an
Asian network based on a generator model
grounded in the four minimal um four
properties of minimal consciousness, it
could be a list roughly like this. I
would say as you can see here both of
the exterior dimension and the
proprioceptive dimension operate through
a chain of prediction minimization
um where the loss function is formulated
as a minimization
of the prediction loss across both
exterception and uh exterception would
be the role model basically and
proprioception which is the body schema.
So these two dimension would jointly act
as variables within the generative model
determining the agent's policy which
then leads to action and um of course
that action in turn influence would
influence the inputs of the uh the
environmental input which would act as a
full loop in a dynamic sequence.
But the key point here is that I
intentionally granted the generate model
with a latent structure.
This latent structure encodes
information uh encodes information
basically that's equivalent to
possessing perspective in a veilance
like form. So um in other words the
worldview of the agent being either
optimistic or pessimistic
uh can be designed to stem out from
these latent variables so that
perspective itself becomes an emerging
feature within the model.
So this is still an ongoing project, but
the goal for now is to implement this as
a kind of wrapper function that could be
applied within um a simulation
environments like Python Gymnasium
um which would make it available as a
Python package
um applicable for simulation.
Now the next step two and three that I'm
going to introduce are not just about
realizing phological properties through
active inference but about stretching
this framework further towards the
problem of alignment.
Um after all as I mentioned earlier my
own motivation for studying the science
of consciousness in the first place has
always been deeply connected to the
question of self-sufficient social
alignment. after all. Um so this next
strand of research is really about
extending that inquiry um from modeling
minimal consciousness to exploring agent
alignment as this natural continuation.
So let me put now um let me touch on a
point that I find quite important
something about how we often misunders
um misunderstand what alignment really
means. So to me equating training
accuracy with maturity level is a kind
of category error because acquiring
specialized knowledge and developing the
ability to truly take another's
perspective are two entirely different
functionalities.
So a system can be extremely you know
precise in prediction or classification
and um but still yet remain completely
blind to the life live the realities of
others. So in human terms that's like
being highly intelligent but emotionally
or or both morally immature.
So if you're serious about addressing AI
alignment at a more fundamental level
uh then perhaps the discussion shouldn't
be about training accuracy at all.
Instead it should be about maturity and
specifically the capacity of perspective
taking because it's at its core social
alignment is all about respecting the
unique conscious experience of the
other. So that should be the basis of
all true attunements whether between
humans or between our visual agents.
So when I say maturity I'm referring to
processes like like perspective taking
and um meaning making grounded in
metacognition.
So maturity requires a certain subject
subjectivity at at the very least um
which means the ability of an agent to
reflect on its own standpoint. So here
we can think of greater stages of ego
development or Keegan's notion of the
subject object shift where um growth is
basically defined precisely by one's
capacity to take um what one what once
was me and hold it as object which means
turning one's own worldview as just one
among others.
So what exactly do we mean by high
maturity
in development psychology? Uh this idea
is closely tied to adult development
theory um and has also been extensively
explored in uh meditation research too.
So in those context maturity is often
evaluated through uh language patterns
essentially. So that means that how
people describes themselves and
surroundings and how they reflect on
their inner life. So it is less about
what we know and more about how we
relate to what we know. At a deeper
level, higher maturity uh seems to
correspond to the ability to affirm the
plurality of conscious universe and to
recognize that um multiple perspectives
can coexist without collapsing into one
single truth. By linking these findings
from the phenomenology of meditation to
the model introduced in step one, I
would say we can begin to ask very
concrete and testable questions
including what kinds of environmental
interactions would stimulate an Asia's
growth and maturity and um within a
simulation environment and how might we
detect or quantify the markers of
maturity as they emerge.
And this becomes especially relevant
when we think about self-sufficient
social alignment. So um if we want to
cultivate alignment that doesn't rely on
rely on external control uh we need to
understand what factors can route these
type of effective stances like empathy,
care and openness toward higher levels
of maturity and perspective taking. So
um insights from this approach could
extend far beyond the artificial
systems. So they could inform not only
um AI human alignment but also human
human alignment which means how
understanding and attunement evolve
naturally in social context.
And importantly this idea is
particularly applicable in active infra
framework based multiple agent
environment that will be described from
the next step. Those settings would
allow us to uh simulate the emergence of
maturity as a property of relational
dynamics.
So now let's take a look at how the
concept of maturity can be applied
within a multi-Aian environment.
In development psychology, maturity is
you know difficultly measured through
language markers um as I mentioned
before but that doesn't necessarily mean
we have to apply human language directly
within a simulation environment. So even
without um even without language uh when
the communicate communication is non-
linguistic uh it's still functions as a
form of information transmission and
sharing.
Um so whether agents use words, signals
or actions, the essential process is
that the information is being exchanged
and interpreted and also transformed
through such social interaction.
So from this standpoint um it is able to
define certain type of
informationational flow as proto proto
linguistic maturity marker. Um in this
view uh communication can be modeled as
each agent reinterpreting a raw message
through the lens of its own its own role
model representation. So that re
reinterpretation process would tell us a
lot about the maturity status of the
Asian's cognitive behavior.
For for example, if you wanted to test a
certain dimensions of cognitive maturity
such as reflective judgment and
interpretive complexity,
uh reflective judgment RJ could be
understood as the ability to interpret a
raw message objectively. objectively
with which means with less distort uh
with less bias uh coming from one's own
perspective. So say an agent with high
RJ can recognize its own standpoint as
just one possible lens among many.
And while integrated complexity I see is
the ability to consider and incorporate
the world models of other agents when
receiving or generating a message. um
that would mark um agents with high IC's
as um more likely to adapt its its
interpretation in response to diverse
perspectives.
Now using these measures we can identify
signatures of alignment failure modes.
For instance, an agent showing high uh
prestige bias that is overvaluing
certain sources or hierarchies is likely
to have low um IC interpretive
complexity because it's not generally
interpreting multiple uh viewpoints.
And if an Asian seems trapped within its
own world model um unable to update its
interpretations that would indicate low
RJ.
Now to actually test these ideas, the
next um and for ultimate step is to set
up a simulation environment that follows
the active infra framework that um it
would allow us to examine how maturity
and alignment dynamics emerge through
these um asentic interaction.
for a simple implementation
using the RXMER package being developed
from active empress institute as a
foundation would be um one possible
method I would say uh especially
utilizing the package within a
relatively lightweight environment such
as gymnasium or a pie game would be a
good first step where these platforms
are ideal for building early prototypes
in terms of visualizing how Asians adapt
and coordinate in real time. So good on
visualizing
uh for a more complex configuration. I
eagerly look forward into multi-ion
simulation spaces like Metag Grid or
common grounds. These frameworks are
particularly useful because they support
contextsensitive social dynamics,
meaning that agents would adapt their
behavior based on changing social or
environmental context.
Um in particular metagrid is a project
uh that is currently being developed
within the active river institute. Um so
if it turns out the perspective
architecture can be applied within this
u metag environment I believe it could
uh strongly highlight the parts of the
simulation that could benefit from
active inference principles. And as for
Common Grounds, which is basically a 2D
Minecraft like gaming platform where
humans can directly intervene in the
civilization uh building sort of
processes of agents, artificial agents.
Um
I find it especially interesting
um because it allows us to design
testable scenarios of pro-social
alignment. And um by the way, from my
understanding, there's a live chat
scheduled about this project as part of
the symposium. Um so I would recommend
attending it if this line of work
interest any of you.
So in any case, testing self-organized
pro-social behavior based on maturity
dynamics within such platforms is
something I'm planning to work on as
part of my research activities at the
institute.
To close the talk, modeling
consciousness leads us to understanding
perspective. Understanding perspective
in turn enables mature uh mature
alignment.
And while active inference is serving as
a bridge by linking phological insights
with computational realization,
ultimately alignment begins where
understanding becomes empathy.
May we act and infer answer and share.
Thank you for your attention.
Um if you have any questions or would
like to share your thoughts freely,
please feel free to reach out using this
email. Thank you.
Greetings. Hello Maxwell and Patrick. It
is November 2025 and this is the
thermodynamic brains discussion for the
applied active inference symposium. So
let us begin with whichever order you'd
like little introduction and then we'll
jump into some questions and discussion.
>> Awesome. Patrick, do you want to go
first? Yeah, sure. Uh, thanks a lot
Daniel for the invitation. Um, my name
is Patrick. I'm a physicist by training
now working at Nomino uh as a researcher
and we're trying to combine uh
thermodynamic computing and active
inference proistic inference um to
advance let's say robotics and other
applications.
>> Awesome. I'm Maxwell Ramstead. I'm a
co-founder at Numinal uh active
inference researcher. I've worked
closely with Carl Fristen. Uh very much
interested in the intersection between
um information theory and thermodynamics
in particular non-equilibrium
thermodynamics. Um so yeah, very excited
to tell you a little bit about the
thermmo brain and what we're up to at
New Middle.
>> Amazing. Yes. Let's get right into it.
So what does it mean to say that a brain
or reasoning in the brain is
thermodynamic or that it's a
thermodynamic process or computer?
So I mean if you think of um
and taking a few steps back maybe from
um thermo itself if you think of the
free energy principle uh what the free
energy principle basically tells you is
that um basically in the presence of uh
in the presence of boundaries
um what would ordinarily uh look like
diffusion dynamics turns out to look
like something a little bit different.
Um I mean in effect what the free energy
principle tells you is that uh the
dynamics of systems that are separated
but coupled uh by their maroval blankets
will look as if uh they uh they
implement some kind of parameter
estimation where the systems that are
coupled but separated through their
markoff blankets end up I mean
effectively um tracking each other's
statistics or estimating each other's
parameters. Um and um I mean this is in
effect a thermodynamic process. Al
although in the free energy principle
literature we tend to um you know
emphasize the dual information theoretic
description this kind of coupling is
ultimately a kind of thermodynamic
equilibration. Um so what's what we what
we think is striking really is that um
almost all uh physical systems uh that
learn learn through this kind of um
coupling and gradient consumption where
you know when systems kind of find a
dynamic equilibrium or you know reach a
non-equilibrium steady state they they
end up becoming parameter estimators for
each other. Um so uh I mean yeah the
claim is essentially that all systems
all physical systems that end up
learning um the the structure of what
they're coupled to learn through this
kind of thermodynamic process with the
exception um and I think it's a very
important exception of the actual
digital machines that we've built that
should be you know the the main kind of
learning machines so the these kind of
machine learning stacks
Um you know Hinton calls these immortal
computers for a reason. Um but I guess
the paradox is that um you know in um in
architecting you know our digital
computers such that they can uh you know
uh execute uh instructions in you know
wellgoed deterministic ways and you know
hold on to pieces of information for a
long time. in kind of architecting these
systems, we've forced them to learn um
in a way that's unlike the way that
anything else in the universe learns.
So, I guess part of our ambition here is
to allow our thinking machines to learn
in the same way that everything else in
the universe does. Uh Patrick, do you
want to maybe like add on to that or
expand or disagree?
>> No, I think it's a very complete
picture. Um,
yeah, I I completely agree. I would
totally second that.
>> Okay. Where do you think reasoning fits
into that? Is that process reasoning or
is it another layer beyond that that
would make something reasoning as
opposed to doing something prior to or
below reasoning?
I I think an important thing to point
out is that um you know what we're
talking about here is kind of um
implementing
algorithms
using the physics that naturally maps on
to the algorithm. So this isn't
necessarily about reasoning as opposed
to perception as opposed to learning as
opposed to policy selection. This is
another kind of uh approach to um I mean
codeesign in effect right so codeesign
is this idea that algorithms uh so
software right and then the devices that
run those algorithms hardware should be
designed together what thermodynamic
computing allows you to do in effect is
to replace um the simulation part uh in
a lot of these uh sampling based
algorithms like MCMC
uh with the actual physics that you're
interested in. Right? So MCMC Markoff
chain Monte Carlo, right? The the
Markoff chain part is the part where you
specify the causal structure of
transitions in the world using a
Marovian model and then the Monte Carlo
part um is about actually simulating the
dynamics over time. And it turns out
that um you know this kind of uh
stochastic algorithm is extremely useful
um in the context of machine learning. I
mean you know if you've been on Twitter
recently like everyone is now talking
about diffusion models for everything
and I think Elon Musk recently talked
about like diffusion models for
reasoning and this kind of thing. Um so
the the important thing is um that all
of these stochastic algorithms depend on
simulating these kind of stochastic
dynamics and this is where I think the
fundamental contradiction of the current
you know R&D landscape for AI like
enters into the picture. So on the
hardware side, you know, we spend a lot
of time and energy to make sure that our
digital computers are not stochastic,
that they're fully deterministic, right?
Like we drive the energies uh of these
components to very high degrees to make
sure that the the the uh bits are, you
know, distinguishable in a reliable way
that they don't bit flip and so on. So
on the hardware side what we're doing is
spending a huge amount of energy to
drive the stoasticity away and then we
end up you know from the algorithm side
reintroducing it. Um so the idea is to
design an al a hardware stack that is
more apt to the kind of algorithms that
we want to run on them. So ra you know
design a chip basically such that rather
than simulate all of these stochastic
dynamics you can just have uh physics as
computation. Um and that's really the
key I think. Uh Patrick do you want to
add on to that? I've been talking a lot.
I'm sorry.
>> No no no I mean so I think also maybe to
it's important to say that this idea is
not that new. I mean uh a lot of people
have heard of quantum computing. you
know, you use a quantum system to do
quantum simulations instead of running
it on a CPU, which we know is very
inefficient. But then there's also this
idea of like analog computing in
general. There's people, I don't know,
using water pipes to simulate some
systems. Um also even like actually
putting a car in a wind channel is
somehow a form of like doing physics
based computation. Instead of doing this
simulations in like a digital computer
uh you use the actual physical object
and wind and maybe some smoke to to do
these simulations. No. Um so this these
ideas are not like fundamentally new. Um
but the evolution or the the
technological advances of the last years
in like especially CMOS design um allow
us to actually build sophisticated
devices that that actually do this
physics as like that I think that's the
the biggest change. Yeah, I mean maybe
to address your question a little bit
because I think what you're asking is
like where does this fit into like
current stacks like what you know you
you mentioned reasoning but like why why
would you want to do this? Um and I mean
in effect um you know a lot of the so in
the context of active inference since
we're talking to you know the the
founder of the active inference
institute um I guess on one level the
math of the free energy principle rests
on these kind of stochastic
uh thermodynamics non-equilibrium
thermodynamics formulation. So if you if
you open um Carl's monograph which is by
the way going to be published with
Springer I think either later this year
or next year I'm sure you've heard of it
um it's now called uh the free the free
energy principle on the nature of
things. Well so if you open the
monograph the which is on archive in
2019 I think the original title was the
free energy principle for a particular
physics. Um so if you open that um
monograph up literally the first
equations that pop up are you know the
longan equations the fauler plank
equation this is fundamentally
stochastic thermodynamics it's based on
the this kind of stochastic approach to
uh you know understanding uh dynamics.
These are like fundamentally
non-equilibrium
formulations. Um so this math is
important for the foundations of the
free energy principle. Um and it's also
very important I think to more applied
work in the active inference space. Um
so I mean as as I'm sure you know um by
now uh it's it's turned out to be very
difficult to scale active inference in
part because it's so um purely basian it
verges on the puritanic puritanical
sometimes. So um in in some interesting
work that has allowed us to scale active
inference up, what we do is uh we create
hybrid systems that employ active
inference sure but also you know um MCMC
family algorithms to perform for example
policy selection. So, Zafas has this
very cool uh paper or rather set of
papers where they uh ex where he and his
team um explore um you know
implementations of sophisticated
inference uh the use MCMC to finesse the
policy search aspect of that to to avoid
kind of like having to deal with the
computational explosion. And obviously
the um the bottleneck there is you have
to run the Monte Carlo steps um on you
know a CPU or GPU or whatever you know
is your favorite digital hardware stack.
Um what this kind of technology the
thermo technology uh promises is to you
know make those uh steps in the hybrid
algorithm like dramatically more
efficient. So, uh, you know, the early
numbers that are being reported here,
you know, they're something on the order
of like 10,000x
less, uh, energy demanding. Um, so
that's significant, right? It's it's
significantly more than say like a 50%
decrease. We're talking about like
orders of magnitude efficiency increase.
So, you know, I mean, to to to put it a
bit more um simply, uh, what this allows
you to do is cheap sampling.
And uh you know for those of uh are
those in the audience who are machine
learners uh your ears have probably
pricricked up at this point because you
know sampling is very expensive and it's
arguably one of the main bottlenecks
um in you know just general deployment
of machine learning technologies at
scale.
>> Thank you Maxwell. Patrick, do you want
to go into a little more detail about
what's happening inside the algorithms,
inputs, outputs, what languages or what
similarities or differences with other
kinds of toolkits that are available
today?
>> Yeah, this is like probably one of the
the questions we get asked mostly is
like, yeah, what do you actually program
on these devices? No. Um I think the
simple answer is that
we all aim in this community of
thermodynamic computing to abstract this
away. So in the end if you're familiar
with uh I don't know the active
inference community that well but more
like proistic machine learning let's say
uh these frameworks like nonpyro standc
if you're familiar with those it's going
to be very similar to them if not even
the same no because uh numpyro allows
you to say hey I want to run this on the
CPU I want to run this on the GPU Maybe
in a few years we just can change the
back end to a thermodynamic computer
because fundamentally it does the same
thing. Um it just does it in a very
different way. Um same as if you change
from a CPU to a GPU. Um you you don't
mind just by using it in Python uh where
it runs but you will feel it in the
difference of like how fast it's going
to be uh executed. Um and then yeah
obviously what happens in the back end
is is fundamentally different. Um so the
sampling then really occurs through a
physical thermal process instead of like
some digital emulation of it. But to
answer your question for the end user
like most people in the field that do
not care about writing their own
compilers
nothing will change. Maybe two lines of
code just like send it to thermal or
yeah, whatever we're going to call it in
the end.
Yes. Interesting. So, I mean, what are
those sorts of building blocks? How
might you connect that to maybe Mars
levels of analysis? Where do you where
does the cognitive part come into play?
Or what granularity do you do you think
about a system or a problem
>> and which pieces could you swap out
model?
Just to interject quickly, I'm not sure
um Mars level of anal Mars level of
analysis is an appropriate framework to
think about this um because that
framework supposes uh that there's a
tight decoupling between you know the uh
the different levels of analysis and in
particular uh between you know the
algorithmic and the physical
implementation layers. What we're kind
of saying is like you you you don't want
to ignore those connections actually
between the algorithm and the physics.
The idea is to build a physical system
whose uh kind of intrinsic physics if
you will implement the algorithm that uh
you want to run. So, um, yeah, I'm not
sure that that kind of detachable or
kind of separable concept
uh is uh like as ill as as informative
as it might be. I mean what what we're
trying to say is like it's it's probably
a mistake to separate the software from
the hardware uh in such a dramatic way
as see in today's stacks and things
would be much better um if we went the
other route which is to actually try to
couple them more fundamentally.
>> Yes, I I hear you on that. a little like
an enshed codependent
marian.
>> Yeah, precisely synthetic point. Um,
from the point of view of a software
developer,
um, this just changes the hardware that
is actually running your software. So,
you know, why why you care is you're
going to, you know, have a radical
efficiency increase. Like things are
just going to run faster um, at the end
of the day. But uh I mean you'll still
be um you know using the same kind of
algorithms that are being deployed right
now in software. It's just that the the
actual physical routines that the system
goes through to compute those algorithms
is just going to be that much more
efficient. Um and you know this also
opens the door to um a kind of more
extensive codeesign approach to
algorithm development. So, you know, um,
if you're developing for thermo, then
knowing about the thermodynamics
of a ther of a TSU, a thermodynamic
sampling unit, and, you know, how that
works is going to be pretty important.
Um, so yeah, I mean, I think your
knowledge of how the hardware works is
is now going to possibly contribute to
how you're thinking about software
development. Um, but in terms of model
building, as Patrick was saying, uh, it
it's pretty much plugandplay. I mean you
might as you were saying you know route
route your algorithm through another
kind of chip
>> but ultimately um you know this is this
is more going to be a gamecher for from
the point of view of performance and you
know long-term code design than um just
like in in an immediate day-to-day kind
of thing for developers. And I mean just
like adding to that it's like there's a
lot of people uh on this planet that
that care about CUDA kernels and
optimizing them but a lot of machine
learning practitioners have never
touched pure CUDA which is still a
relatively high level language if you
think of like actual transistors and the
GPU know so but even that level of
abstraction which is already pretty high
most practitioners never touch that's
the job of of like really specialized
folks and this still will exist. This
kind of profession will continue
existing and people will have to think
of like hey we have this particular sub
routine that people really care about in
let's say active insurance like this
this specific way of sampling something
um let's try to make this more efficient
and then there's also really like the
the hardware level where people think of
like actual single transistors and how
to communicate them together and so on.
These kind of professions exist also now
in SMOS. It's just like no one really
talks about them in in machine learning
or there really this are abstracted away
fortunately otherwise you'll not be able
to do any meaningful machine learning if
every machine learning engineer has to
think of bits and transistors.
>> Yes. So to fuse a few questions
together, let's say you were setting up
a research and development lab over the
coming few years time scale. What does
that lab look like in terms of skills
and hardware? And what kinds of
problems? What sectors is it tackling
and why?
Hello, I'm Michael London and I am a
member of the science advisory board at
the active inference institute. I live
in Washington DC. Have an academic
affiliation with a couple of local
universities and then by training a
Hello, I'm Michael Lennon and I am a
member of the science advisory board at
the active inference institute. I live
in Washington DC. I have an academic
affiliation with a couple of local
universities and then by training a an
economist and a technologist and today
I'm going to share some reflections that
um through the mostly lens of an
economic technologist you could say um
about um the impact of AI. Uh and so
uh about a year ago or so I co-wrote a
book with um six others seven others
about the possibility in the future of
AI. It was um mostly optimistic. Um I
was one of the skeptics. You can see the
chapter I wrote there dancing with a
fire. Um but it's been um an area of
interest for a long time the kind of
tensions that exist with uh uh
artificial intelligence and over the
past year some of these have simply
continued to sharpen. um one of the ways
certainly within um not just economics
but from the mindset of of economist um
two mindsets about the future impact of
of AI on on economies and on humanity
and one is that um it will take over
inefficient humans that it'll shrink the
bad in the world but uh but really it's
going to be a kind of this someone would
say this a technoutopian vision of hyper
efficiency um a different technoutopian
vision is that it will help grow the
good in humans and amplify human
capacity for meaning and contribution
and um and this debate is going on in in
um in many circles. Um one of the ways
in which I found um talking about impact
with folks is u uh can be illuminating
is using this this particular diagram.
I've u I developed it a while ago for
comparing investments in different uh uh
technology projects around the world and
comparing where they were uh targeting.
the institution that I was doing the
work for was um had a global portfolio
and um one that wasn't just economic but
included um social and other kinds of
impacts and um and yet all the reporting
was done through an econ an economic
lens and by asking people to talk about
a whether they were trying to address
finance or experiential life or or the
larger system such as
>> Hello, I'm Michael Lennon and I am a
member of the
um was one way of uh fairly easily
contrasting uh these these different
projects but often these projects also
had two very different kinds of
objectives. Uh one was often a shrinking
of a problem um and the other was often
growing a new capability and just like
fixing a broken arm relieves your misery
and uh and and uh helps create a sense
of being better than when you were
miserable. It does not make you an
Olympic athlete. And so often these uh
by by distinguishing between what are
what are interventions that shrink harm
versus growing good, one really gets
much greater clarity about what is the
invisibleized impact of of of the
project that one is undertaking. And so
um often in one class of political
mindset, there's the the growing the
good is often uh solidarity type
economics, folks that uh that are trying
to grow the solidarity, the well-being
and uh and such. Whereas often for um
efficiency and um uh minded folks um the
idea of shrinking waste uh uh is at the
heart of uh of what there is to do and
um and where for example um
neoliberalism often finds and people who
self-describe as neoliberals uh often
find themselves setting up the the the
focus of the work that they're doing.
And so one of the things that both these
narratives are um useful and and they
represent um uh perspectives on
realities. One of the things that's been
interesting about the emerging science
of predicting economic futures has been
that it turns out that one of the most
influential aspects of predicting uh a
country's future economic performance is
um its networks. what kind of networks
in which kind of it's learning networks
frankly um uh learning cities learning
relationships between the cities all of
these um and the complexity and
sophistication of these all are much
more accurately predictive than many of
the uh what have been traditional uh
indicators used to to look at at what
the future will hold and um and that
these particular um uh networks um
operated at different levels that
there's both uh networks of people
individuals networks of groups networks
of firms and that Each of these are like
um layers of a living system that each
are learning at in their own way at
their own level and and all are
contributing in uh in um in their own
ways. And so really beginning to
understand how the economy is a is a
often could be looked at as a kind of
learning system that is learning how to
do things better in the place where the
economy is and add value uh based on
what is there in the economy. that life
does that often with the energy and
nutrients that receive from the living
ecosystems in which it's in. And so a
takeaway could be that uh you know a
priority for for AI in the future is to
boost the learning capacity of networks
that we do this for ourselves that we do
this for the groups that we're in and
that um and that when we're having
conversations with others that it's like
do we understand what are the networks
and how can we boost the the learning
and interarning and it's really
important to sharpen our understanding
of what these different um learning
units are because we have vocabulary
that is mostly individual and it turns
out that as a as a group or collective
learns it it happens in a different
place and in different ways. So, um I
learn within my brain, if you will, uh
to oversimplify things, and a a hive of
bees learns by by interacting with other
bees, signaling where is the honey,
where are the flowers, and then
responding as a group. And so, we can be
talking about learning and um and be uh
referring to what is happening within an
individual or we can be talking about
learning and and be talking about what's
happening across a group of individuals
that are a self-organized group or it
can be between groups of groups and and
and so on. So uh the learning edges
whether they are within whether they are
between or whether they are beyond the
group all of these are um different
learning edges that um that can be
adding value and um can be step points.
Uh so back to the original prompt for
this particular presentation. Um there
was last year in Buffalona uh a s a
group of creatives and uh technologists
and activists and civil servants a
variety of different communities all in
this vibrant city that were hearing that
uh that generative AI was going to
change the future and they weren't sure
whether it was all rainbows and
lollipops. Some of them were skeptical
and so they were kind of uh how do we
get smarter about this and how do we
begin to grow the civic conversation
about co-parenting a vision a shared
vision forward that uh that is grounded
in in um the information that we each
have our own individual perspectives and
woven together into a larger narrative.
So, so each of these communities um each
brought their puzzle pieces and they
tried to assemble into a simplified map
that became then a discussion board for
moving forward and um it did help uh
demystify and kind of build a greater
pool of knowledge as well as surface
some of the tensions and controversies
that that exists. And uh among some of
the outputs if you will was to identify
21 topics uh that um that are that they
identified that were affected by this
emerging phenomenon of generative AI. um
they had under each of these topics
whole bodies of additional content. But
one could summarize these and they did
in the following way that that this
phenomenon of generative AI was um was
magical was the word they used perhaps
oversold um and that there were there
were fascinating dazzling things about
it and um hidden harms and that some of
the pattern of accelerating harms that
they saw were that extractive practices
of data of resources of humans,
exploitation particularly uh in foreign
places, the invisibleized um uh the the
amount of humans in in in far away
places that support the cleanup of the
data and the delivery of AI is just
starting to come to the surface. And
they they were beginning to recognize
the hidden human factor in in AI.
Environmental destruction as well as the
concentration of economic power. All of
these things were being intensified by
this by this process. And so um as a
group it started to kind of feed a kind
of maybe we need to update our our myths
about um what is possible that it's not
just all about being smarter leaner than
what we were but also recognizing um how
is this affecting the the groups and the
intergroups in in interesting ways and
uh and uh one of the things that I uh
would have served here some additional
limitations of of LLMs that are known to
have problems. uh for me the one that I
want to build upon in this conversation
is the the architectural failure of chat
bots to uh to support nested learning uh
of networks. This kind of the different
parts of of the being and the different
layers of the being. Still um uh the
work was very very um fruitful and um
and it was well um built upon. Uh the EU
um uh incorporated whole aspects of it
into its vision for the AI Euro stack.
um in China uh several um organizations,
learning festivals and such have have
built upon it um in different ways. It's
been translated I think in over seven
languages and and is being um elaborated
evolved forward um in in many many ways.
And so I had as a as an aspiration uh
because our community is a learning
community how to bring if you will the
not just the engineering technosavvy
perspective but also um other non- US
perspectives on on on the macro trends
and how might that um serve or feed our
uh our own active inference community
and um I think one way of summarizing
that would be to say that uh that people
are also infrastructure and so it
becomes an invisibleized aspect of um of
really um optimizing the place in space
if one sticks to to the to the tools and
the automation without um without really
accounting for how the humans are part
of that living infrastructure. And so um
but then um as I opened up conversations
I ran into some problems. I I was u I
was engaging in bio regionalism
supporting uh this environmental
movement called bi-ism uh that looks at
kind of what are living areas that uh it
might be a watershed it might be a
forest that are self-contained um uh
unique living systems and often
adjoining each other and that this might
be another way in which humans can be in
relationship to the places that they are
that they're not just in a in a for
example uh the state of a political
state but that for example I who live in
Washington live on the Chesapeake
watershed and I'm in a in an ecotone
that is three different uh three
different uh bio regions uh the South
Atlantic, the North Atlantic and the
Appalachian uh mountains uh come into a
kind of confluence and create a
biodiversity hotspot that is not how
most people talk about Washington DC. So
this movement about um orienting to life
and living systems um has been u a
growing movement worldwide. Um and um
and then one of the questions was how
can AI be talked about in those spaces
and um and some of those conversations
turned out to be uh
uh well that would trigger the oh AI is
going to kill everybody or AI is you
know the the the usual. And so um after
a couple of attempts um I have um landed
on these three topics as ways to both
talk uh across different uh different
communities. And this is part of what
I'm testing here in this in this
delivery here today. Um that uh the
following three themes are ways to think
not exhaustively but usefully about um
about human and AI interactions and and
learning. So about data, data is a well
understood uh phenomenon by many um and
yet um most of us um are the data of our
own lives for example is uh managed by
others in other places away from us. And
so I think of um in this picture you see
uh a picture of my Gmail inbox and my
communication patterns. It turns out
that relational dynamics are predictive
of your happiness, of sales
effectiveness, of a whole variety of
things that people uh tend to uh explain
and and figure out through other lenses.
And if you're able to take your
communication patterns and render them
uh in a social graph, you're able to see
um dynamics about your relational
patterns that um that enable you to
choose differently than you might when
you're using linear and rectangular
presentations of your own data. And this
is a really important notion to get
because it's this whole systemic uh
relational data uh is something that
happens in layer after layer after layer
and sometimes we have to see it at the
level of me in order to then feel more
skillful or more confident about talking
about and how does this play itself out
in other spaces.
So this uh level of seeing our systemic
data and taking ownership, having
support for easier ownership and
integration of our data so that it's not
fragmented across Google and Yahoo and
and 20 other thousand places, but that
we have tools that enable us to to mine
our own insights about ourselves instead
of it being corporations that are
selling things to us is um is one of the
um uh ways in which a civic platform can
help um make our lives easier and see
our own data in in more novel and useful
ways to ourselves. That pattern repeats
at the level of groups. This
representation that you see here is uh
seven different data coding teams that
all used the same architecture, the same
platform on GitHub to um to code a
solution to a particular problem. And um
and what you see u represented there is
their data calls, the components that
they used, the pattern, how they solved
the problem, even if they were using the
same tool sets in a sense. And you begin
to see that there are all additional
ways to see how the the living sense
making is happening whether it's at the
level of individual at the level of
teams etc etc and so a third dimension
of data that uh can be uh of interest is
what I'm calling uh interubjectivity now
we all have um a sense of our own our
bodies naturally give us sensory
information uh that we then translate
into our own actions uh as groups we
also use language to get synchronized
and um and orient towards common goals u
one of the things that um that science
is helping um sharpen is u well let me
reframe it this way um a Nobel Prize was
won by Elanor Ostrong who who recognized
that um that when groups organized they
that econ economists used to describe it
as either as hierarchies institutions as
marketplaces and she recognized that
there was a different kind of human
grouping um she called it a commons a
group that self-organized and practiced
shared care it could be like fishermen
around the fishery and that their rules
were not um hierarchical or marketplace
place but but were others and that these
kind of self-organizing groups these
natural groups um were everywhere and
that they basically operated uh
according to eight principles if they
were sustainable and functional and
these eight um principles uh can be used
to to gauge perceptions of how
functional are we being what is our
level of symbiotic cooperative fitness
and that that becomes a way to to
support the evolution of of groups uh
forming into uh from from from baby
groups groups into mature adult
symbiotic groups and that this is a a
class of of data that pays attention to
interiority
um uh in ways that also builds
relational spaces between humans. So
switching now to the next topic away
from data and on to compute here I'm
just going to talk about what for me are
some of the interesting
uh for me have been some of the
interesting insights from active
inference it is far from complete but uh
when I tried to talk to people outside
of the community some of the what's in
it for me that might be different from a
computational perspective and um and
perhaps one of the hardest and both
intuit but most useful might be the idea
that AI that everybody gets is kind of
like uh pre-trained it's It's it's uh
it's like canned beans. They were
harvested. They were prepared. And now
you can eat them as prepared, but
they're not going to change or evolve in
any way. They it is pre-trained. And so,
uh these chatbots are things that can
ingest the entire web. And if you want
them to be current the next day or 3
days later, you have to reingest the
entire web. They are not really they're
capable of doing the ingestion, but
they're not continuously adapting and
learning. So the architecture of active
inference is one that both these types
of of computation have learning methods.
But in a sense, the FGBT, and this isn't
an oversimplication that many in this
group will probably debate, is that not
only is it um related to to only the
past in a sense, not the present or
making predictions about the future, but
um but it completes its training loop
and then is uh works for whoever the
user is of that particular canister.
uh that cognitive capability. Uh active
imprints uh can behave at the clustering
level and so it it crowdsources um what
are the predictions of of the group and
what are they predicting and then based
on errors is readapting or reevolving
forward um what has been um accurate or
inaccurate about the um about the
group's crowdsourced prediction. And
what that enables is it means that as
the group faces stable conditions, they
they uh stay on course whatever course
that they were on. But if new conditions
change or new circumstances arrive, then
the the updating of expectations and the
co-synchronizing of behavior all happens
in real time, which is how living
systems kind of um stay attuned and
adapting forward continuously. And so
and so it's a kind of distributed
learning that um that is not present in
these other forms of uh what I call
pre-trained uh GBTs. Um a second is that
that dynamic capability allows for new
degrees of freedom is is is how I
describe it. But but it allows for new
capabilities to emerge um a new
creativity which we see over and over
and over in the ingenuity of living
systems. And in part the logic of of
this is that um in order to there's in
in system thinking there is a uh there
is a uh rule so let's say a law that
says that in order to control that
system let's say it has 10 dimensions to
it then you must have control mechanisms
that either match the number like 10 or
exceed it. If you have fewer then you're
only able to influence but you cannot
control the complexity of that system.
And so matching the complexity of the
system that you're facing is an
important aspect in developing greater
and greater mastery over things in the
world. And one of the things that
language allows for groups to do
together that they cannot do alone is
that as groups new language can be
developed to describe what is being seen
collectively. And then that terminology
can be used to then co-behave
differently, co-adapt. So it allows for
groups to also perceive together and
then synchronize uh and do as groups
what they cannot do alone. And so this
linguistic development is um is the
mimemetic or the linguistic the the
development of the vocabulary is what
enables the creation of new forms of
competence. And um and that active
inference has algorithms that when we
were looking at the previous diagram on
the previous screen that the ability to
evolve its its assessment of what the
error was and then how does it weigh uh
correcting forward means that as a group
the co-correction can become a new
shared um capability uh that allows for
the group to do at the level of group
what it can't do alone. And so this this
is part of the miracle of adaptive uh
learning. you could say it allows for
the continuous adaptation the way that
life does. Last thing I'll talk about um
computation is that there are new
classes of learning metrics that become
available. Um what is learned by which
action? what is the information gain of
any particular learning activities and
um and in the environmental space for
example there have been new ways of
talking about the thresholds of
planetary carrying capacity versus
individual and how does the relationship
between the individual for example
consumption of water and um the capacity
of the wershed how are those two related
and those uh enable for new quotients
new ways of measuring new ways of um
monitoring the the sustainability of
let's say a a wershed the use of a
waterershed, water footprint or carbon
footprint that become these vocabularies
that we now use to understand the flow
of water, the flow of carbon through a
system. Similarly, um this idea of
agentic learning and the field learning
um can have um baselines and thresholds
that are related to each other so that
these become benchmarks that one can
begin to make new kinds of comparisons,
new kinds of metrics for for the
learning of groups and groups and groups
um and their overall the value and
totality of their of their learning. So
jumping down to the third topic, the
final topic and I know this is running a
little longer than expected is um and
all of these u different data types,
differentformational sense making types
all create new ways of learning and new
ways of weaving new learning to add
value to the new economy. And whether
that is to make faster cars or leaner
cars or cheaper cars or whether it is to
interact with other um social systems
and ecological systems in entire new
ways, there are a whole new set of job
opportunities um arising from these new
competencies. and um and so positioning
to provide some of these um advisory
services, these knowledge collection
services, these knowledge curation
services is all part of the reason why
this idea of a net zero from AI is
entirely uh plausible.
Um I'll just share an anecdote um uh
before moving to the next screen which
is there's a variety of countries that I
think of the richest the richest region
of Italy Emilia Rosana is um is composed
of almost one over one-third of his
cooperatives and as they uh went through
digitization and automation over the
last few decades um they did not lose
any jobs um they uh continued to lead in
productivity and performance but it was
a commitment of the community and of the
co-ops to keep people employed. Germany
has a similar kind of approach to labor
development. They outsource the the um
if you will the the simplest work and
they keep the most knowledge intensive
work locally in the design and the
engineering of the work. And so they
stay at the learning edge and they stay
wealthy as a result of moving the needle
and staying on the edges of uh the
knowledge economy retaining their people
and their their uh human networks as
having a component of that adaptive
learning as much as um as as the
codified knowledge in systems. And so um
this kind of learning um is happening in
level after level after level. examples
here um from developing economies is
some fishermen who had some reporting to
do in um on the fishery uh in um I
believe this was Latin America. Um it
was a bit u for them and they started
pulling uh resources and activity to
both uh track and uh and monitor the the
data together and they started both
becoming more um effective at their
reporting as well as developing
visibility into the kind of things that
help them manage their own fishery
better. And this kind of self-organizing
at at the microcosmic level is thing
that happens over and over. It's not
just the globalized systems that can
benefit from these AI systems. But each
of us can be tailoring at our local
place. And so whether it is health data
co-ops, um patient owned platforms, um
other forms of co-ops, these are are
coming up left and right. And there's as
much a revolution going on in the
development of machine learning
capabilities, whether it's translating
linguistically in different ways or
tailoring these capabilities to the
characteristics of the place that
they're in. So um there's a whole range
of opportunities for prototyping
ventures for adapting the governance of
these and for bringing things like geo
infer to the um Q infer which is
something Daniel prototyped as a
synthesis of active inference and GIS
data sources to to bring the capability
of active inference to GIS databases.
And so these are just three um of the
methods. Um I was going to show a list
of allies but had not consulted. Uh
there's of course um I already talked
about the service so I'll move along. Uh
active inference can help with sense
making through with human networks
through um through traceability of AI
which is a real problem for LLMs. Um
recasting digital footprints which we
talked about this idea of having methods
for how metalarning and metalarning
happens as well as these additional
tools. Finally, I'll throw out that um a
consortium of social impact investors in
the US have uh pulled together half a
billion dollars recently in the last few
weeks to drive three levers that they
hope will influence the present and the
future of AI, expanding the groups of
people that participate in AI design and
development, strengthening the
organizations that play these
coordination roles, and supporting the
creation of public goods. So, we are
wonderfully positioned as a community to
help with these. And this is one of the
questions that I like to throw out about
what comes to mind for people as
opportunities for action. Um so um I'll
leave as closing thought you know how to
better enrich the how can AI better
enrich the learning networks in which we
are all in. Um and um and I'll stop
there if uh you have questions or would
like to reach out to me individually. Uh
lenin
ci.org
is my email. Um and um thank you very
All right, this is going to be the final
pre-recorded video. It is active
inference for the social sciences
state-of-the-art with AEL.
Here it goes. It is a lengthy 1 hour and
43 minutes. Enjoy.
So hi uh I am Kush and this is the round
table about active inference for the
real science for the active inference
symposium
as I so we have uh well myself raising
it of course we have zitski we have
pashia we have we have malarasa
and what we will discuss tonight is uh
basically go over what that inference
does for these true senses if it does
anything which you know we may discuss
at some point. uh we will uh each try to
give a very broad impression of what our
work is about and each our work is
relevant to this question hopefully and
then we will uh discuss uh you know what
do we do with act in France what can be
uh what can it be used for etc such
questions so uh first of all I want to
go over a very short very um accessible
hopefully presentation of fat inference
which I guess people in the symposium
will not need uh very strongly but uh
we're trying to make this an invitation
for people who are not necessarily you
know cognitive sense people to
collaborate and to uh sing together uh
what I in France brings uh to the table
and so I believe there is a large
proportion of the audience that will
necessitate primary inference if they
are to follow anything that we say so uh
for those people welcome and thank And I
will now go over uh the
state-of-the-arts.
So uh first of all I will uh define
social sciences very broadly as the
study of societies. I know it come as a
shock.
>> You have uh many kinds of social science
with uh different methodologies and
different topic. For example, by
convention, due to historical
contingency, anthropology is mostly
interested in stateless societies while
sociology, political sense will be more
interested with societies with states,
large scale organization, parliament,
selection, etc., etc. And there are
other disciplines that interested stuff
in the past to stuff in the past that
has material culture, respective
history, and archaeology. There is a
very broad variety of social senses.
This is why we have a plural to the
term. I will not try to define
specifically what they do. But I would
say in broadstrokes uh social senses are
interested in social phenomena and
they're interested in finding patterns
in social phenomena and they tend to
hold that those patterns are actually
meaningful and explanatory
and this is where the notion of social
structure uh comes into play. Most
social scientists I would say uh would
agree that there is such a thing
structure and that are uh from the very
basic Wikipedia definition I found it is
uh the aggregate of pattern social
arrangement society that are both
emergent from and determinant of the
actions of individual. It's something
that explains individual behavior in the
context of society and that is not you
know really inside individuals. So this
notion brings a lot of questions
actually foundational ones. uh first if
there is such a thing as social
structure how is it implemented in human
minds? We are not born with a sense of
class or with uh the specific
arrangement of French. This is not
something that is implemented at inner
brain at birth. So at some point we
integrate those notion and there is
specific process by which and this you
know process necessarily will be limited
in some way. So the question of how
specifically structures implemented
matters quite a deal. Relatedly there is
a question of uh what is the relation
between social structure and agency. So
if structure that is something that is
not not really inside our heads can
determine our behavior. It does not
entail that we are just mindless robots.
It does not seem we are. So there is
some level we can decide what we do and
some level we are determined by society.
This is non trivial. The articulation
between the two is non trivial and it is
a widely studied topic in aology
specifically. And third uh is there is
such a thing as flow structure. uh it
seems to change over time. We are not in
the same societies are as uh our
ancestors 20,000 years ago and the
specific rules that apply to social
interactions engagement they seem to
change between context. You do not talk
to your boss like you do your dating
buddy. Hopefully for you and uh these
questions uh I believe you will see this
coming. I think uh sorry can be
approached through the lenses of active
inference which is the product we are
selling to you right now. Sorry about
this. So let's try to uh take a look
more specifically to what is this active
inference thing which I did not define
at any point so far.
uh let's get back to the basics which is
uh the concept of ping predictive
processing and the friendship principle.
So in 2006 uh British new scientist
called Carl Triston proposed a very
basic principle for commission that is
basically the idea that we do bas
inference. I will not get into it but
bas inference is the optimal way uh that
we can mathematically determine what
kind of uh stimuli what kind of object
out there would cause sensation. Uh here
uh h correspond to hypothesis and e
corresponds to evidence and the
hypothesis is you know the concept of
what's out there affecting us and the
evidence is how specifically it affects
us. Imagine if I hear mowing maybe there
is a cat but maybe there is a audio box
that meows all the time and I can use
the probability that a cat would indeed
meow and the probability that audio box
meowing would be out there uh and
determine the specific probability that
there is indeed a cat given that there
is meowing that's the core idea so and
the slides have frozen again.
Sorry about this. We have a reoccurring
technical issue with uh Google Meets.
Hopefully, this will uh arrange itself.
So, uh you don't need to get the math. I
just want you to know there is
mathematics. The fact is when you
consider complex problems with a lot of
parameters, uh just calculating basian
probability of something is not
possible. But what we can do is compute
what we call versional free energy which
is uh much more simple
much simpler to compute under realistic
circumstances and that has the nice
property of banning surprise which means
if you minimize for energy this is a
hard upper limit on how surprising the
world can be to you. So this is as good
as it gets really in terms of practical
inference and the idea of calf freestand
is that uh neurons do that they minimize
version 3 energy uh over models of what
is going on out there at the scale of
the brain and within the brain at the
level of lower neurons on the neuronal
hierarchy. So uh assuming that there is
indeed nested layers of terinal activity
uh that's organized as to be able to
infer sensations and predict what's next
uh then yeah there is a strong case that
the brain could indeed be able to
understand the world and navigate it in
the way we do. So uh this is very
abstract at least for people that are
not uh already into neuroscience. I will
ask you to do a very small exercise uh
to get better grip on the idea. There is
a text on the screen that says please do
not look away from the screen. I will
ask you to look at this text and not to
look uh away from the screen until
inserted other ways. And while very
carefully looking at your screen and not
elsewhere, I will ask you to pick out
something in your peripheral vision that
is outside of the screen, something
around you and uh something that you
believe you know what it is and then
while still looking very intently at the
screen, try to uh retrieve specific
details uh from it. For example, I can
see the box to my mic. I don't lost my
mic. Uh but what I can see now is very
much nothing. I can see it's very
square. I can see white. I can see there
is dark in the white. But practically
the sensor information I can retrieve is
much more limited than what I need to
infer it is the box of my mic. The only
reason I know it is is because I knew it
is before I looked. uh because I know I
put it there and because there is only
so many things out there that could be
white and placed there. So you can now
look away from the screen. Hopefully
most of you will experience the same
thing I did. Uh pick out a thing,
believe you know what it is and then
realize that you just do not have the
sensory information necessary to make
this inference. Uh at some point you had
necessarily some prior model of what was
going on that allowed you to recognize
uh what it was. And before I look the
exercise, it seems seamless. You just
knew what it is and that is at core uh
what predictive processing uh says.
So I forgot a bit of a slide. This is a
phenomena that is well known to
philosophy of perception and to
neuroscience and it has been for a
while. So this for example is a rabbit
duck illustration from pagander blatter
I do not know how to pronounce this that
was made very famous by the philosopher
vinstein using it to show the um let's
say duality flittiness of human
perception if you are like most people
uh you can see a bird a duck
specifically or you can see a rabbit but
you cannot see both and the point I
believe vidgenstein was making and the
point I'm making now is that it kind of
goes to show that perception is not
purely information processing. It is uh
judgment. It is decisions. You can apply
the concept of a rabbit to this and you
can apply the concept of a duck to this
and you will just see a rabbit or just
see a duck and this is something that
will be constructive of how you engage
with a thing at a very very basic level
prior to your conscious experience.
So uh let us get in a bit more detail
about active inference. active inference
is that it is the idea of predictive
processing as I presented to you. But
because of mathematics I will not get
into uh uh freestone and most of us here
believe hold that not only agents engage
by predicting uh what causes their
sensation predicting u what is out there
and cause you to see this white blob on
the wall or whichever it is that you
picked. We also select actions uh the
same way. The idea would be that we not
only predict sensations but also actions
that we uh maximize the basian coherence
or minimize version of energy over both
and that therefore both uh perception
and action are guided by near optimal
prediction of ongoing sensory motor
flop.
So
uh this idea I believe is very powerful
and this idea I believe solves lots of
very foundational problems in the
cognitive sense. I could go on about
this for hours which we do not have so I
will not do that but I will tell you one
thing as an engineer and former engineer
physicist technically physicist I'm
interested in models I'm interested in
mathematics and um something that is
very important in most fields of
engineering at least signal engineering
uh automatics this kind of thing is
inverse problem if you have a forward
model you know exactly how hypothesis
would shape the
Uh maybe you can run uh this through and
you can know exactly how a given object
would um
sorry how would your given object would
look like to your perceiving robot or
something. But uh knowing what object is
out there given the array of vectors
that your sing robot would see requires
the inversion of your forward model and
for reasons I will absolutely not uh get
into. It's not practically possible for
the wireless category of models.
Uh let us take a look at this vehicle
quickly and this unlin again.
Sorry about this. This is a painting. I
believe you can see a shape that is
orange under a dark background. I do not
believe you could practically recover
what the painting is unless you know
what it is uh from this picture. And
actually I know you can't. The painting
is this and okay linked again.
Sorry about this.
The painting is this William Blake
ancient of days and just because of the
nature of the process which is a very
simple blurring process. Well, you can
know precisely how this picture will be
affected by blurring but you cannot
recover the picture from blurring. And
this kind of problem is the kind of
problem that we have to resolve every
single day. Every time we try to pick up
perceive something to decide on what our
plan and there is no way that we brute
force it uh we have to work around the
problem somehow and this is what active
inference
okay this is what active inference uh
proposes that we do this is at the most
basic level why I believe that inference
is a correct model of the world maybe
not like you know specifically precise
in the most metaphysical way, but it
seems to capture something very
important, which is how we use prior
information and we use selfization in
the brain to circumvent the inverse
problem by anticipating what it is that
we will do and what it is that we will
see.
So let's hope that it did not link. It
did not link. It is incredible. So what
this means for our experience of life as
active influence agents I believe you
have a you know experience of life as
active influence agent because I believe
that we are that but we do sense we need
to put words in things and I would say
the most basic level if active inference
is verified then we experience the world
as a landscape of agencies affordances
being a technical ecological psychology
term that says actual or perceived
opportunity fraction. So for example,
this is a very nice picture of of a path
in Galysia that's towards a
archeological site we will not get to
see. Sorry about this. And if I removed
it uh briefly you would remember mostly
there is a path and there is green
because the way it is structured uh it
is the possibilities for action this
image and tail that you know jump to
eyes and so you see the path and you
don't see that much else. And in
addition to that, if active inference is
verified, uh there is not only the
prediction of uh states outside you,
which is called extreception, but also
of the states inside you, which is
called interception. And because the two
are predicted in a dual manner, just
like because sensory states, active
states are created in a dry manner,
there is a very efficient use of
context, there is a very efficient way
in which our bodily perception will
shape what we look for there. If it's
thirsty, we look for water, etc., etc.
And uh all of this again runs at a very
basic level uh far prior to our
conscious experience.
And this entails I would argue the
dissolution of agency as we know it. The
idea that there is a little thing inside
of us that has opinions on what we
should do and that you know neutally
analyze world out there and takes
decisions for us. It is not the case. Uh
the world as we experienced it is loaded
with value. It is loaded with
affordances and a lot of the processes
that shape our activity exist outside
our conscious grasp. We flow in uh
practical terms along our predictions of
what the world is our world bundle and
our prediction of what it is that we do
our self model. And this is a very
fundamental insight that has many
application to visual sciences which I
hope we'll discuss later. Here I will
only uh take a very quick look at what
was canonically done uh to relate active
inference to the social senses.
Uh the first paper that I believe
qualifies as social scientific is this
paper by Brunberg and Vidvelt that
analyzes that says basically what I just
told you. If the acting story is
verified then we experience the world as
a field of currencies a field where we
can do stuff and due to versionization
we strive to maintain an optimal
agreement and it happens to be
structured by social and cultural
resources. So this is the basically
everything that active inference
sociology people did relies on that
framework skill skilled intentionality
framework. Uh the first major paper I'm
aware of is the Ram title cultural
affordences
that uh tries to get into more detail
about how we can specifically integrate
and perceive such uh culturally and
shaped differences. And their argument
is that there is a thing called regimes
of attention which is way of paying
attention. Wave of cues outside out
there matter and what sense to give to
them and that uh the action of those
regime is basically forced by
selectivity. So when you perspectivity
you follow along regime of attention
that thereafter you can mobilize to uh
pick out cultural affordances.
Uh from there uh there was the thinking
through the minds framework that
basically agrees with the uh prior ranch
paper and that's uh further opines that
the transmission of culture as in a
sense of human specific culture. There's
a lot to be said about animal culture.
This isn't what we're talking about. Is
enabled not only by participation in
social activity that are embedded with
regimes of attention, but also and
perhaps most importantly by the ability
to think through other minds by the
attitude of when we are confronted to a
situation to a problem to a thing that
calls action. uh wonder what would
someone else do instead of us which
entails a coupling mechanism between
ourselves and other people that's
mediated by expressive capacities and
that essentially entails a runaway
evolution of uh
culturally embedded cognition
and then there is the paper by Mu and me
automated nurativity which is interested
more in the role of material culture in
uh shaping humanity and our argument is
that because of the normative nature of
perception and direct inference because
of this affordances thing. Metal
landscape are a direct participant in
cognition by the fact that they
constrain activities towards certain
perceptions and actions which is uh the
essence of you know cognition. if the
version of attention picture is correct
and which is the basis of behavioral
regulation and also there is other uh
more out there stuff I did where I
argued that such constraints over
regimes of attention collectively
constitute forms of forms of life
strictly speaking biological things
biological if not biochemical that are
embedded in patterns of human activity I
don't know if we will get into it a lot
because this is perhaps a bit abstract
but I thought this was a important thing
to say because if it's true we have two
level autonomy ours as biological
individuals and collective autonomy of
this form of life that we collectively
enact. So uh let us run over core
message core ideas that are relevant to
social science very quickly. Uh first uh
active inference if it is correct
validates some ideas about uh within s
science. It basically provides a
framework that proves that if our nested
recognition is correct then this is
true. It also grown society in the sense
that it provides a way to do very
specific models and very specific
predictions according to those. So this
is in my opinion a pretty interesting
thing if not relation of direct
constraints. So the first thing that
active inference I would argue validates
and grounds is daily that social
structure. It is not something that you
know exists out there. It is embedded in
systems of cultural meaning in way that
we have to attribute well meaning to
stuff out there and those systems exist
prior or within our basic phenomenology
or experience of the world and this idea
is a very central idea to anthropology
to at least second half of the 20th
century anthropology because it was
popularized by Cloud Leistros within his
anthropology structure.
The second idea I think inference,
validates and grounds is that and I need
to be on the slides is that social
interaction is embedded in such systems
of cultural meanings in the sense that
those system are constrain are
constraining but are also expressed
within social interaction and social
interaction is not only you know
determined by such system of meaning but
it also participates in making them
evolve and this is I would say uh very
broadly speaking the point of symbolic
interactionism which is another of the
major mid 20th century syology school.
Well, this one is a both sology and
topology actually. And third, uh the
same applies to matter landscapes. The
way in which our physical reality is
organized, it signifies stuff. It
constrains our attention. It
participates in uh you know constructing
systems of cultural meaning that may or
may not be uh strictly speaking life
forms. So uh this is it once again we
want uh this session to be dedicated to
inviting people to collaborate on the
project of uh building active inference
for visual science. And so I will leave
you with while with these two QR codes
that are respectively a link to the
discord channel of our project and a
link to the course that some of us ma
and myself organized I think three years
back to give a much more exciting
perspective on what we can do with
France than we'll possibly do during
this room table.
So I thank you for attention and now
we'll uh go towards uh this presentation
of the different participants of the
round table. Uh starting with Tarius and
I hope you got the QR code because I
will stop sharing
now. Okay.
Allow to share.
No, no, that's not right.
>> Excuse me.
>> Excuse me. Sorry. Uh, I got to I think I
hit the wrong thing. Uh,
wait.
Okay, hang on a sec. Um,
share screen. Allowed to share screen.
Where is it?
Allow to share window.
Why is this not working? I'm having some
trouble here. Sorry about Oh, wait. Show
all windows. Here's There we go. All
right. Where is it? There it is.
Okay. Can you all see this?
Hello.
>> We cannot see anything.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Um Oh, share this window. Hang on. How
about this? Can you see this?
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. I'm going to get
started. Um,
is everyone ready?
>> Yep.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So I love uh Avil's presentation
and I have a you know I've have a lot of
work that bears a close affinity to what
he was talking about but today I'm going
to talk about a new kind of new
direction in which I'm taking active
inference in my thinking uh and it's uh
about um I think it provides the
resources to uh critically interrogate
some uh very uh old and classic
assumptions about human thought and
action.
embedded in the European philosophical
tradition and offer an alternative to
them. So intuitively there is this
distinction we make between patterns we
find in nature. For example, laws of
nature that science finds and patterns
we make um uh cultural phenomena mainly
music, architecture, dance, technology,
uh language and so forth. And this
distinction has a very old provenence in
European philosophy. Aristotle made a
distinction between theoria which uh is
a uh capacity to discover patterns in
the world and praises and poises which
is about making patterns. Um and he even
he even hypothesized two different
cognitive processes. One theoretical the
theoretical syllogism one the practical
syllogism underlying these two
capacities. This has been taken up in
cont uh re more recent European
philosophy in terms of the uh
distinctions in direction of fit. So
some cognitive acts and speech acts have
a worldto-word
direction of fit. What does that mean?
That means if there's a discrepancy
between what you say and the world, you
alter the world in some cases. But in in
other cases, there's a word to world
direction of fit where you alter the
word to uh respect the world. So uh
Elizabeth Anskim has a very memorable
illustration of this with the grocery
list. Suppose you have a list um and
you're doing your groceries. Um there
the the word is d is regulating the
world. So if you don't have what you
want on the grocery list, if there's a
discrepancy, you change the world in
order to match the list. But you can
imagine a private investigator following
the person around and making an
identical list. Um but there the
direction of fit is in the opposite
direction. The the list is modified in
light of what the person puts in their
shopping cart. Surl uh uh uh marked this
distinction as the distinction between
declarative and imperative speech acts.
Some speech acts uh declaratives aim to
track the world and if they don't track
the world it's the speech act that has
to be changed. Other uh speech acts like
commands imperative speech act aim to
change the world and if there's a
discrepancy it's the world that has to
change.
Um this has been applied to models uh
classical model cognitive models of the
mind where there's a distinction between
belief modules and desire modules. Uh
Hume is very explicit about this
distinction. Uh Peter Kurthers is a
contemporary example where belief
modules aim to track the world and
desire modules produce states that aim
to alter the world primarily uh the
body. Now the interesting thing in uh
active inference is um that the proposal
is the brain doesn't work that way.
Here's Andy Clark's uh very uh
interesting recent article where he
writes desires and motivations are
fluently accommodated within the
unifying predictive processing schema
where they emerge as webs of prior
beliefs that sculpt probabilistic
predictions some of which become
positions so as to bring about actions.
Importantly, a single construct here
plays the role of belief and desire. So,
it's a departure from this classical
dichconomy between uh states that have a
word to world direction of fit and
states that have a world-to-word
direction of fit. Um, now what I find
interesting about this is it can make
sense of certain um uh um phenomena,
linguistic and cognitive phenomena that
don't fall neatly into either category.
And one uh such example is the concept
of ideology which has gotten expression
in uh any number of thinkers including
Marx, Fukco, Nichze and Freud. But
basically what I want to suggest is a a
kind of quick uh fast def definition of
ideology is that it's pattern making and
masquerading as pattern finding. So we
we uh think that we're discovering a a
pattern in the world but actually in
believing in that pattern we are making
the pattern where it it becomes a sort
of self-fulfilling prophecy. The pattern
wasn't there but by believing that it's
there it becomes true. So in ideology,
the basic idea is we the you promote the
interests of the powerful by concealing
true patterns with masking patterns that
victims unwittingly work to reproduce at
least partially. So you might think sort
of the Christian um belief that the meek
shall inherit the earth or God will
redeem our suffering. these uh help make
patterns um rather than track patterns
that are there independently of these
beliefs or uh example from Fuko it's
only natural for men to desire women
again it's pitched as a description of a
pattern but it functions more to make a
pattern true okay so I think active
inference is a really nice way of making
sense of a phenomena like ideology uh
and that is because as a pointed out. Um
what active inference says is that all
that matters is that the discrepancy
between a pred prediction or an
expectation and an observation is
minimized. But there are actually two
ways that one can minimize uh these
discrepancies. One can adjust the
prediction so it better fits the
observation or could one can adjust the
world through action so that it better
fit uh fits a prior prediction.
Now that uh raises the following
question um why don't we just adjust
expectations always adjust our
expectations in response to differences
um discrepancies between extterceptive
feedback and expectations. Um well the
idea is that some expectations for
example those related to fundamental
requirements on survival like uh the
your body temperature or levels of blood
sugar are sticky and the only way to
minimize the discrepancies with relevant
feedback is to act. You can't adjust the
level that your blood sugar should be at
or the level that your body temperature
should be at. The only way of minimizing
the discrepancy is through action. So as
Clark puts it, bringing about action
requires attenuating, that is assigning
low precision to the sensory information
currently indexing the actual
disposition of the body so as to enable
precise propriceptive predictions to
prevail. Intentional action thus depends
upon a delicate balance that combines
precise propriceptive predictions with
attenuated information concerning
current bodily states. An interesting
consequence is that action thus depends
on a kind of systematic
misrepresentation of how our body is
currently arrayed in space. I emphasize
that because it's very similar to the
idea of ideology. Ideology is a
systematic misrepresentation of the way
of the social world but it leads to a
kind of alteration of the social world
to more approximate it. So one of the
interesting consequences of this picture
is that we can replace this classic
pattern finding and pattern making uh
disjunction that we saw in SURL and
Anskam, we could replace it um with a
more nuanced um continuum. So here
rather than two categories into which we
could place thoughts or or judgments or
sentences, we have a continuum that and
anything you think or say can be placed
on different places in this continuum
depending on how sticky it is. That is
how likely are we are to hold on to the
belief no matter what and the prediction
error that you get. So diet doesn't
impact health. Presumably that's pretty
we're willing to revise that and if the
prediction error is high as it is in
this case but something like life has
meaning even if there's a lot of
prediction error um we we can't help but
hold on to it because it's very sticky
and but it can vary for individual to
individual or occasion to occasion and
it's it's um a continuous variation not
a discrete one like in the classical
understanding of these things falling
into one of two categories. A final area
that I I'm really interested in applying
this to is an another ancient tradition,
an alternative to the European
philosophical tradition, the Buddhist
tradition. This is Amber Carpenter
channeling Christopher Gowens's uh
talking about the belief in the self. So
she writes the false belief in a
substance self that there is a stable
entity distinct from phenomena with
which to identify leads to the sort of
mental activity of grasping and aversion
that creates generates and constitutes
the continuum that is what we in fact
are process cells. So falsely taking
myself to be substantial generates the
kind of thoughts that keep keep my
process self my continuous self going
and more broadly u I'm not going to read
this uh citation out of interest of time
but the I the very Buddhist idea that
desires help construct our our reality
is um I think very compatible with the
active inference framework. The idea is
that we divide the reality up into the
chunks that we see based on what we want
based on our preferences and uh if we
didn't have those desires we might
divide reality up in a different way and
I think that fits very nicely with the
active inference framework. So anyhow
that's the direction I'm taking it uh
these days and I hope you found this
interesting.
>> Yes. Uh thanks a lot. Uh that is
uh so now yes let us move on to M
and then we'll move to Reish.
>> Thank you. So I think the talk I'm about
to give is somewhat congress in the
sense that uh you both discussed what it
is that active inference allows us to do
and and how it allows us to frame how we
carve reality. But I think I'm about to
talk about the mechanism at play when we
talk about the ways in which our
perception overlays with group dynamics
and then um shapes that reality itself.
Um and I'm going to go rather relatively
quickly to give Andrew and Remy a chance
to um talk as well. The core idea here
is that every adaptive system biological
or social operates by minimizing
uncertainty. And so active inference
starts with the individual. So the self
model maintains coherence between
internal states of the world, internal
states and the world. Uh but because no
one can model the entire world alone,
cognition extends beyond just the
individual.
And so uh to reduce uncertainty we
extend our cognitive boundaries by
coupling our inferences with those of
others. And the shared modeling of
reality depends on uh shared prior. So
overlapping assumptions about what it is
likely uh meaningful or true. And so um
trust here arises when we assume that
others self-evidence as we do that they
also act to maintain coherence between
their predictions and the world. So
through this mutual self-evidencing,
individuals become part of each other's
generative models, they enable social
cognition, uh the the the ability to
think together, to coordinate and to
construct shared worlds. And so these
distributed inference loops become the
foundation of social identity and group
belonging.
And so self-esteem here functions as a
precision regulator, a dynamic estimate
of how well our internal model aligns
with social feedback. So when prediction
errors are low and feedback is
affirming, confidence increases. And
when errors rise and feedback turns
negative, self-esteem decreases,
prompting potentially self-correction.
Um overconfidence and shame emerge when
the system miscalibrates precision.
So over confidence inflates certainty
discounting error signals and preventing
learning and shame amplifies precision
on negative feedback overweighing error
and suppressing action. So in this sense
self-esteem is a sociometric gauge of
prediction error keeping our self models
coherent with the social world. And so
through this continuous calibration,
individuals align with collective
expectations and they form more stable
social groups.
And so social groups can form around
shared expectations or beliefs that
collectively minimize uncertainty. And
so over time, confirmation bias
reinforces these shared priors.
individuals selectively attend uh to
evidence that supports their existing
models and ignore what contradicts them.
It's it's uh it links to what Tadu was
saying about motivated reasoning. And so
this feedback signalizes social identity
but also traps the group in local minima
um of of belief space the the states
that feel coherent internally but are
resistant to change. So within these
echo chambers, prediction errors are
reduced not by updating beliefs but by
filtering experience itself and such
stability preserves belonging at the
cost of flexibility. So the system
maintains low surprise through mutual
reinforcement rather than genuine
adaptation. And so once we have these
shared beliefs, once they are
stabilized, um power and influence can
determine whose priors guide the
collective models.
Power here emerges when one agent or an
ideology uh or ultimately a group can
modulate the priors that guide
collective sensemaking rather than
controlling actions directly.
Influence operates through the precision
weighing of beliefs by determining what
counts as credible, relevant or true.
Leaders, narratives, institutions
steer collective attention.
They um shape how groups interpret
evidence and update their models of the
world. Under this view, power is the
capacity to steer collective belief
updating. It is to define the boundaries
of what can be imagined or questioned.
And so the group's generative model thus
becomes a shared cognitive architecture
governed by those who set its priors.
And this hierarchical modulation scales
from individuals and small groups to
entire societies.
But finally um we can express cultural,
political and interpersonal processes in
terms of shared inference. And we can
formalize how meaning, trust, and
coordination emerge without producing
their complexity or richness. The goal
here is not to necessarily mechanize
society, but to make its hidden
computations visible to describe how
collective sense making evolves, adapts,
and sometimes fails. And so we can use
this to design systems that learn and
align together. We can apply it to
artificial intelligence but we can also
apply it to policym
large and that's the direction I hope to
take here.
>> Thank you. It was fascinating. Remy, are
you ready to share?
>> Yes, I'm going to share my screen or
attempt to do it.
Okay. Um,
can everybody see the presentation?
>> Yes.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
So, um, yeah, I'm just make it full
screen.
Okay. So, um, yeah, I'm going to talk
about, uh, things that are really
similar to what Tad presented a bit
earlier. Um, so, uh, yeah, I'm just, it
seems that it froze. Sorry.
Okay, I'm just gonna Okay, so can
everybody see the presentation?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So uh the what has drawn me
to active inference is really something
that's similar to what Tad was talking
about which is uh this kind of um
questioning of traditional distinctions
uh which have really ancient origins in
accidental philosophy and have been
represented also in more con
um more contemporary philosophy of mind.
So this distinction that Tad discussed
between what is sometimes called
epistemic attitudes which have the
function to accurately represent the
world. Uh so things like beliefs and
perceptions and uh on one hand and on
the other hand prottitudes which uh like
intentions and desires which have the
function to change or transform the
world. Um and as Tad explained there's
no such distinction in active inference.
there's only predictions which can be
more or less like beliefs more or less
like desires depending on precision
modulation as Tad explained and so I
think this has a potential to explain to
um eliminate
a wide variety of social phenomena as
Tad explained I think ideology is one of
them but what I want to focus on here is
the phenomena phenomenon of social norms
so what are social norms norms. Social
norms are simply behavioral regularities
that are socially maintained in a group.
So simply these are patterns of behavior
which are um socially maintained which
means that uh members of a group will
behave so as to incentivize
reward behavior that follows the norm
and disincentivize or punish behavior
that infringe upon the norm. And so uh
social norms are just like patterns of
behavior which are enforced through uh
patterns of social sanctions. And um how
do these social sanctions uh come about?
How do they emerge? Um I think that uh
the active inference framework has a lot
of uh things to to say about that. Um
the idea as I said earlier is that in
the active active inference framework
there's no strict distinction between
beliefs and desires. So uh when an agent
predicts something about its world, it
can either alter the the prediction so
that it fits how the world is or it can
also alter the world itself so that it
fits what it model is predicting
predicting.
And so in a social group uh there will
be various kinds of social regularities,
ways that people tend to behave in in
this group. And so uh we can expect the
members of this group to learn these
social regularities. So these the models
of these agents will tend to integrate
the these social regular regularities
they will tend to form social
predictions that predict these
regularities.
And um when uh uh uh these predictions
are fixed in the the model uh you can
expect uh something like social
sanctions to uh to to uh appear because
uh as we said earlier uh when these
social predictions are well uh well
confirmed well placed in the in a model
um the the agents will not simply uh um
update their um their social
predictions. concerning the environment.
They will also try to minimize social
prediction error by intervening in their
environment so as to confirm these
social predictions. And so we can expect
members of a group that have learned uh
social uh regularities of their group to
enforce these social regularities. that
is we can expect them to uh start
behaving so as to produce in their
social group the behavior that follow
the norm that follows the norm and uh to
produce behavior that punishes uh
behavior that uh that violates the norm.
And so uh I think that this uh erasing
of the distinction between belief and
desire to have just one notion of
prediction can help us explain how
social norms appear in social groups and
how they stabilize in social groups
because members of such groups will
attempt to minimize social prediction
error and not only by revising their own
model of the world but also by actively
enforcing these social predictions on
their social environment. I think so
that we have now better tools to
understand how social regularities in
social groups can become social norms.
So that's what I had for today. Thank
you for listening to me and uh yeah I
think it's close to what dad was saying
about ideology but it's kind of a spin
on the notion of social norm.
>> Okay. Uh thank you Reie. Uh I will do
the next one if I can share my screen.
Okay. So this is uh you know I think it
was originally a 45 presentation. I will
go through it very quickly. So I the
thing I want to talk about is uh my
contention that we can actually make
things up and it matters which I will
explain uh very shortly. So uh first uh
the way that we engage with the world
displays uh very clear signs of what we
call opening evolution. We can make new
things up that do not seem to follow
very clearly from published law
principle. For example, we can build a
city and then there is an entire new
level of organization that follows its
own rules that are constrained by but
not strictly by prior law of physics. We
can make signs that mean things and
because we treat them as meaning things,
they do indeed seem to mean things.
uh that at least they work to signify
stuff and they work to constrain mission
and so there is a I would say very very
very very strong case and a quite
trivial one that that we can build uses
of the world that causally matter and
uh there is an entire sub field of
physics that yes
>> well I'm sorry I think your presentation
is um
>> frozen thank
it's back
>> and so I will not get to detail but uh
it's hard to explain physically because
in physics we tend to have specific list
of states that define a system and you
know we can't just tell to the math to
invent new math in the middle of doing
math that does not work. So most of it
is what I showed you about inference.
What I want to get at is the following
uh contextuality in life and cognition.
There is a very basic concept in quantum
physics that is I think it's simple but
uh it's the reason why everyone is so
confused about it and it sounds very
weird. That's called contextuality. So
at a very basic level I don't really
want you to read that but I want you to
know that the math exists. What's we the
kind of system we study in quantum
physics there are vectors and there are
vectors that are kind of like
probability distributions up to uh
squaring but whatever and when we do an
observation what we observe is not a
vector but uh on value um
multiplicatively stable value of the
vector uh given the operator. So if I
look at energy, I can find any of the
level of energy that are defined by the
operator with which I look at energy.
And what this means is that
um the physical act of observation
in teran
gladly it uh I don't have much longer to
talk. So the physical act of observation
uh in a contextual theory cannot be
understood to reveal appreciates even
reveal up to noise. It brings them about
and there is a quite simple uh way to
show it from a thermodynamic perspective
that you would know about if I could
make this slideshow work.
uh which is that if you want to observe
an object, you're reducing the entropy
and the entropy has to go somewhere
because we live in a bonded universe.
And so every time you observe some
information, you destroy some
information somewhere else. And this is
something you cannot escape if the
universe is bound by the which I will
very much assure it is. And my
contention here is that uh no
is that uh human perception is in fact
uh contextual maybe not quantum. I do
not have the contention that our brain
is a quantum system but at the scale of
functional activity where which is
relevant to explain and understand our
behavior. It is contextual and the duck
rabbit is a case in point. You can
observe it as a rabbit or as a dog. You
cannot
whichever would be a neutral process of
observation that would naturally
constrain uh action down the line. You
either perceive it as a rabbits or you
don't. And uh in the same
okay in the same way uh when we observe
uh material landscape here uh pathway in
the forest uh we can observe it as a
pathway we are actively projecting
context uh that are defined by the
priors with which we look at situation
and the priors in the rabbit duck case
is that there is such a thing as a duck
and such as a rabbit and they are
different things and the prior here is
the fact that we are physical bodies
which walk upright on feet and can walk
in a pathway but not through a bush. Uh
mice would likely not see the picture as
we do if you could get the mice to look
at the picture which is an entire other
story. And this
this is nerve-wracking. And this becomes
very important uh when we consider uh
the constructive nature of uh cognition
and of well uh the communication system
that we build. We can just decide to
that something is a letter and then we
can use it to communicate. We can just
decide that something is a word and then
we can use it to communicate. I can just
decide that this gesture means okay and
this gesture also means okay and another
one I will not show means I don't like
you. We can decide this and then we
think in those terms and then it becomes
actual determinance of social
organization and the entanglement of
this if I am uh correct in the broader
scheme of things is that uh there is a
process uh by which we can observe uh
reality observe social reality and
material reality in a way uh that
basically tells us what the constraints
over what can perceive are uh what are
the letters what are the kind of path
you can go down and the kind of path
that no you cannot I assure you you
cannot do that and uh because this
process is not uh you know purely
patterning transmission of pre-existing
ideals because it is something that
requires trial and error and
misunderstanding
uh it's enables the possibility for
open-ended evolution and this is this uh
you know tension between what we want
the world to be and what the world is uh
that enables that
and moreover I would claim that if this
thing is related we can understand
sociality at least the kind of norms
that was talking about but more more
broadly the constraints that material
and social uh context averally
described as constraints and they can be
formally defined as a closed system of
constraints where every constraint
brings about other and is brought about
by the other and that's what uh at least
some corners of the elective literature
called biological autonomy. So if this
is correct then there are circuit life
forms and there are several layers of
that are embedded uh in humanity from
the level of basically down to the level
of ourselves and up to the level of
judges parliaments uh discussion about
whether social organization and this is
I would say the core idea I'm
complaining for.
So, uh, thanks for your attention. I
hope it was a short talk. Uh, it's it's
a your turn, Andrew.
>> Okay.
Okay. Can you guys see and hear
everything? Okay.
>> Mhm.
>> Great. Um yeah, thanks. So um wasn't
quite sure what to expect from the round
table. So I did not give any kind of
like redux of active inference. Um I've
done that a lot uh over the past couple
years. I'm also going to set a five
minute timer for myself. Um
but um so this is effectively just like
uh kind of a a snapshot montage of some
of the things that I've personally been
working on. Um,
and it starts with uh hopefully this
maybe fills in some gaps regarding
something like affordance sharing for
anyone who watches this. Um, so there's
three slides total. I always overpack
them. Uh this first one is essentially a
summation of sort of what I did last
year at University of Pennsylvania,
which was uh give a three-hour tutorial
somewhat Ryan Smith style for anyone
familiar with with his work uh on uh
creating agent-based models uh using the
active inference framework, but now in
more of a uh social science focused
multi- aent setting. Um I think from my
perspective of the field there's a lot
more work to be done uh on multi- aent
agent-based modeling especially with
applying active inference um
specifically or even just any kind of uh
sort of cognitive or autonomous uh agent
model in general. Um during that uh
3-hour tutorial, I kind of make this
this narrative, this this argument um
that seems to be happening in
computational social science where um
those who do engage in uh agent-based
modeling are repeatedly coming back to
ideas of what is cognition and uh what
what does it mean for an individual to
to have beliefs? And so whenever it
comes to doing agent-based modeling
where traditionally due to low
computational resources and power, we've
largely relied upon very simple
conditional rules that agents follow uh
whenever we actually simulate their
behavior. Uh which you know there sort
of the justification for that is well
one we don't have the computational
power. to uh create an agent uh who's
who's necessarily um uh able to emulate
sort of real world behaviors that we
find in other areas of science. Um but
then also well if the model is sort of
real enough if it exhibits enough sort
of ver similitude then um then that's
enough of a justification and then
whenever you start to imagine trying to
simulate say hundreds of agents
simultaneously
um you're you're you're definitely
reaching the limit whenever it comes to
concerns about computational power. So
I'll I'll attempt to speed through the
rest of this, but this was simply uh
anyone who's interested in that tutorial
I gave. There's roughly 70 to 80 slides
of material uh as well as all the code
for this particular simulation which I
taught everyone sort of how to recreate.
Um this is a classic uh computational
social science uh simulation by Laser
and Freriedman uh at um at um
Northeastern and Harvard respectively.
And this is a way of looking at agents
in a way that um they're composed in
networks. And so suddenly network
science becomes relevant looking at
agents who maybe interact with
particular agents but not others. Uh we
often think of you know societies or
collectives at varying levels. And so
basically this this almost provides a
kind of sandbox to allow for testing
agents in different kinds of networks
with one another with different network
network uh configurations and have them
uh do what we could phrase as parallel
problem solving. And so this this kind
of boils down to how do agents
collectively solve problems which is
something that I'm personally very
interested in. Uh I think that culture
in some ways could be read that way. I
think that sociology in some ways could
be read that way. I think that if we're
able to have different kinds of proxies
for I don't know say we we need to have
food uh to live and so whenever we
organize different kinds of agricultural
and distributional systems around food
and those become sort of a you know a
basis for being able to have a society
otherwise it dissipates. uh that you
know having those kinds of perspectives
of these are agents who are collectively
you know trying to maintain their
homeostasis or or however we want to
phrase that. Um but that's sort of what
those are some of the kinds of dynamics
that this simulation gets to and then by
being able to use active inference
agents. You can see how the sim
simulation is reconfirmed using the old
agent-based model as well. But here we
have agents who who who learn who who
adapt to the particular network
configuration that they're within the
kinds of ideas that are being shared. We
do find semblances of a lot of the kind
of phenomena that uh that I think ma was
referencing earlier. Uh here there are
agents who they they share ideas with
one another trying to find the better
solution. But whenever agents are too
heavily connected uh with one another,
sort of like our our modern world a
little bit and thinking about
interactivity on the internet, um
attention is so broadly distributed that
what happens is that agents tend towards
uh actually converging towards whoever
seems to have the best idea. And then
whenever that happens, the diversity of
ideas and solutions to a problem starts
to dissipate and everyone's kind of
limited by the leader at the top. And so
if that leader at the top sort of
doesn't quite have the right idea or
it's not very well reflective of reality
then uh what you find are a lot of
agents kind of converging towards um you
know ideas that might be very much
maladaptive or be more focused on the
social dynamics between the agents
rather than actually solving the
problem. So that's a bit abstract but um
it's just I what I find very interesting
in the framework is uh the rel of active
inference is relating it to neur
biological plausibility of getting down
to sort of first principles. Um I've
done a variety of different kinds of
projects. And so tomorrow, which has
kind of been my main focus this week in
preparing for a presentation was uh this
um model that we're actually making in
more of a computational psychiatry
setting. And it uh we're so I'm actually
working with a clinical therapist who's
done a clinical study with seven
individuals who have PTSD. And this is
sort of that how do we bridge the
qualitative to quantitative gap in the
kinds of data and information we can
collect and and and then kind of compose
and and analyze or interpret in the
formation of a study to yield some kind
of insight. And so um we're effectively
making a model that somewhat um kind of
replicates a lot of the behaviors
synthetically produced from these seven
different accounts of individuals with
with PTSD as well as of course a lot of
other sort of empirically inclined
literature. Um there needs to be in in
active inference there needs to be a lot
more kind of work on validation of
different kinds of models. Um there's
been a lot of great work uh already done
with like Aumura uh Takuya who's who's
done a lot on on validating this sort of
at the at the cell culture or or
neuronal level. Um and so I'm very
excited to see where the social sciences
uh can kind of take this next and
recreating like broadly social behavior.
So with this particular example, this is
an agent who um you know analogously
exhibits the symptomatology of PTSD, but
they're in a social task. And so we're
looking at something like epistemic
trust. We're looking at uh what does it
mean to pursue your own individual goals
while simultaneously needing to
potentially rely upon others? How do you
establish that kind of trust? Uh what
happens when trust is lost? What happens
actually in the body? Um so so there are
aspects of like modeling the autonomic
nervous system here and relations
between um affect and emotion. Um yet
another kind of reference back to some
of the things that uh I think Ma brought
up earlier with with uh sort of having a
sort of emotional sensor or looking at
um precision modulation changes in
confidence. All those dynamics are here.
Um there will be more on that tomorrow.
And then finally, this is a little much,
but this is just sort of a quick like uh
overview of some different kinds of
things I'm I'm looking at right now with
agent models. Uh I'm deeply involved
with the active inference institute
where I teach um the textbook uh with uh
Daniel Freriedman. I'm involved in a
variety of projects. Uh, I look
frequently at different computational
resources that are being like developed
that people could use, figuring out how
I can use them and then how I can teach
others to to use them in in potentially
new or creative ways. And so um you know
this is I'm just interested to see like
what we can do not just with optimizing
agents and systems for accomplishing
real world tasks in the way we want them
to do but actually looking at how do
agents on their own so to speak kind of
interact amongst one another. So um the
the upper left this is just um I'm
interested in mix models. you know, a
lot of people are using uh POMDP models
to emulate uh decision-m, but I'm more
interested as as someone who my my main
career is as a data analyst. I'm looking
at different kinds of data all the time.
And so I'm interested in like how do we
include continuous data? Of course,
there are many ways to do that in active
inference, but it's just what are the
ways that sort of neurobiologically
plausibly align with what what we can
make, what we can emulate and then what
can actually scale, right? Such that we
can reach those kind of dreamed uh uh
100,000 million agent level uh
agent-based model simulations and what
can be fit to real empirical data
otherwise. So, uh I'll I'll stop there.
I went much went much went much went
much went much went much went much went
much went much went much went over on
time but thank you for your attention on
all that
>> thank you Andrew
uh so we did uh we went a little bit uh
of time uh we spent 70 minutes on the uh
presentations instead of 45
this is okay uh so to my knowledge we do
not have uh any hard time limits now is
there a limit on the Google call
thank
So we don't have any term limit. I don't
have any term limits. So like for me it
is uh very much okay.
Oh what I would like to open for the
rest of the session however uh lensing
gets is uh for us to discuss uh what
active inference brings to a table for
social science. Uh it is uh I would like
it to be a very open conversation. We
can talk about anything that we like
like collectively individually.
uh just as to be somewhat scholarly. Uh
also I'd like us to talk roughly
equivalent amount of times each of us. I
don't think we have a timer but I guess
we can be mindful of that.
And uh I would
>> excuse me do you mind if I take a quick
break before we start because I
>> Okay,
>> I'll be right back. Sorry.
>> Yeah.
Uh and uh last thing we can uh like if
we want to show things we can show
things we don't have to just talk there
is a interesting graphic we think of we
can share it. So uh just to break the
ice I'd like to ask one question. Um I
would say we are beating upon the
contention that there is indeed some
value that active inference has for this
science. I would say there is a pretty
strong case to believe there is not
social sense existed for a long while.
They have existed with very information
about cognition and they they functioned
uh this way. You don't need to have a
very specific model of the hypocalus to
know what symbolic threat is.
And uh yeah so what I would like to
discuss is your opinion what it is that
active inference brings to the table for
the social science uh how valable it is
what are the terms in which it works. Do
we reduce social science to cognitive
sense or is this something more
integrative?
And if we are convinced that there is
indeed value to act inferred, how do we
uh tell this to social sense people that
maybe are not very interested in
learning a lot of mathematics for a
pretty questionable value from their
perspective?
>> Oh, I'm hard balling. Yeah, we don't
have a Please go ahead now.
Yeah. Um, well, I mean that's that's
what most of my thesis motivation
section was about. Basically saying why
would we want to apply active inference
to social science and what's in it for
them. Um, and my answer was predict
predictive power. That's one of the
things that social science really
doesn't very much. We have a lot of
descriptions. We understand we think we
understand things. we can discuss about
phenomena and critique it, but when it
comes to actually predicting things,
we're very bad. Um, and that that's
partly because social systems are
extremely complex and they span over
multiple scales and a big chunk of it is
subjective, i.e. not accessible through
real objective metrics. Um, so it's it's
it's really hard for us to to get a real
insight. And that's part of what active
inference also gives us. It gives us
what we could consider to be a
mechanistic map of the processes that we
can then leverage to make predictions
based on measurements we've taken for
years and years and years. Sociology,
psychology, anthropology have made a lot
of measurements, if not a lot of very
good predictions. Uh and now what we can
do is okay well now we've got this
mechanism we can potentially fit to all
those measurements we've taken what does
it allow us to say about you know the
future at x time scale
>> yeah uh so we don't have to raise the
ends every time I guess if it gets a bit
competitive we can do that but just to
for context
uh what I asked question which was a bit
of a hard ball which was why do we
believe that active inference has
anything to bring to social science?
>> Oh okay. Um, can I should I go now or
I just wanted to riff off of what um, Ma
Mah said, which is um, just the only
thing I'd add is that the other a nice
thing about the active inference
framework is it it doesn't give just
give theorists a predictive purchase on
this complex domain, but it explains how
humans non the non- theoretically can
adapt to this complex domain without
without having an understanding of it.
Right? that that's what I find very
interesting is that um because we uh
through the mechanisms that I was
describing regarding ideology but also
me about norms it shows that you could
have sort of relatively cognitively
cheap ways of um uh of creating uh uh
social consensus and enabling
coordination making people more
predictable to each other without them
having to understand how it's done, how
this very complex domain uh functions.
So, uh I think that's a really nice kind
of um uh corollary maybe of of of the
active inference framework.
Yeah, just um quick comment that uh I
think because I'm regularly interfacing
with people who are very interested in
active inference and trying to figure
out how to apply it in their respective
field. It's something I notice people
frequently kind of flock to is the
notion of the marov blanket. whether
they're very familiar with the notion of
like you know what it means to have like
a conditional independence or not. um
the idea of being able to separate out
what is a thing uh which becomes very
relevant in in social science where we
say like what is a society what del
limits that society what is inside of it
and what is outside of it and I think
that uh sort of you know I I enjoy I've
enjoyed talking about the notion of the
markoff blanket with others whenever
they try to conceptually model out like
map like what what is a society what are
these different institutions and then if
you could reach some point where you
could delimmit what are sort of the
inputs and the outputs or the sens and
the blanket state uh active states uh in
relation to those entities then you
become much closer able to actually
specifying a system where you're not
getting so confused whenever you change
different scales right because it's
social science is like we'll break
things out into a micro scale and a mazo
scale and a macro scale or others will
look at things at different time scales
the anal school with with history and
Fernandell that sort of thing uh and I I
just think it's Great. But I think that
active inference supplies a very strong
framework for looking at many many
phenomena as opposed to kind of you know
side siding with your own like little
sub subd discipline silo in how you look
at things and then kind of either
casting out or getting in a debate with
others but not making much progress
beyond that without making too much
assumptions about other how others
operate.
Yeah, I mean another thing that
beyond the interdisciplinarity which I
agree is because it acts as a lingua
frana due to its precision and due to
the fact that Carl and most of the
people who have developed it come from
to some extent a degree of the social
sciences at the very least cognitive
science. So the the language that they
use has been nicely couched in this sort
of veneer of accessibility
um for social scientists, cognitive
scientists. But I find that another
benefit which perhaps not everybody will
will thinks is a benefit but coming from
queer studies, gender studies, um
is its amanability to postmodernism.
Yeah,
>> you mentioned it, Tadius, with the
constructionism, but I I feel like it
gives you a concrete foundation to make
those claims beyond just the observation
that it really does seem like the
concepts have different meaning for
different people and they seem to lead
to different kinds of conclusions for
different people as well. But under
active inputs, you can literally couch
that under. Yeah, your mapping is
different because you've carved reality
at its joints differently. And therefore
um now that you've carved reality at its
joints differently, you're going to
sample reality and shape it through your
sampling also differently because of uh
this this uh joint distribution and
therefore the ways in which your
boundary coexists with the world and and
and forces it into a certain way. Um and
and that's profoundly postmodern.
And I think it also is some of the the
issues we found with with postmodernism
which is okay but now what if you accept
that things are relative and and hard to
measure that measurement itself is a bit
um not facious but uh begging the
question to some extent what do we do
what do we measure what like what's the
future I think active inference sort of
answers that question like okay yeah
sure we we can map all these different
ways of couching reality and it is
amanable to a dynamism of perception
itself and to cultural um influences.
But also we can map things to each
other. Like we can understand how
perhaps through this anchoring with
common observations you have seen
something slightly different given your
vector. And we're now coming to the
point where we can apply things like
perhaps uh category the theory, coology,
uh and all kinds of mathematical tools
to understand how these different things
map to each other without having to
resort to well nothing's real, nothing's
true, we can't do anything.
>> Yeah. So I uh strongly agree with what M
just said up to postmodernism. might say
I'm not a fan of uh postmodern theory
for forat reasons. I can stand some fuko
but uh that's pretty much it. What what
I would say is uh there is a very strong
record of social science that try to
work with positivistic social sciences
uh that try to measure behavior in
isolation and then use it for prediction
and this record is absolutely terrible.
There is no probability for anything. uh
most of the time there isn't even a
coherent theory behind predictions
and at some point uh I will share a
thing because such is my power uh at
some point uh there is a very strong
contention that agency matters uh and
agency is if the active influence
picture is uh concrete uh more
constrained by how we happen to perceive
a given situation than by um Craig's
mechanism or social structure in a very
strong Marxistish sense and then what we
are left with is what Gopan calls frame
analysis. It is semiotics. It is
specific fields of visual science that
have studied how we signify stuff and
how we understand stuff. And um to me
it's a very strong result that if
factory inference is correct then those
fields are in their basictology correct.
the object they posit exists. They are
valid construct and we can work with
them because such is not true for say
social psychology. We cannot just well
we can't just measure effects and then
expect them to replicate uh outside of
context but it did not work. It did not
work very well and so active inference
seems to be correct from an empirical
perspective because again this is my
basic contention. we do not have another
theory of how we can circumvent the um
inverse problem and maybe it's uh
formulation is not wide enough it's not
it's too restrictive I do believe that
the formulation of the fy principle is
restrictive it's my one of my horse
battle but the basic structure of it
seems to work there is no competitor to
that and seems to flow from very basic
physical principles so I think it's a
very strong indication for some
tradition of study which do include
qualities which include symbolic
interactionism which include the most
constructivist interpretation of
structuralism and to me it's a very
strong result because we can not only
say that again those fields have
construct that work but also now we have
a way to model it that is not based in
speculation that is based in very
specific uh computational hypothesis
that translates the basic physical
principle of in cognition this is a I
cannot say that this will make and
breaks is ridiculous. This is another
field with its own theory.
This is I would believe a force that is
very important to validate and verify
specific theories within specific fields
of the social science and this is where
uh M was talking of lingua frana I think
this does that I think inference is a
lingua franka it's a way to talk and
representical phenomena and
so on a bit more negative note I think
also we must be aware to not think it is
a selfstanding theory of sociology that
will uh replace uh this or that
approachology. This is a cognitive
science thing and it works and it can be
made useful for syology but there is
also a distinction in methodology and in
ontology and in what we are trying to do
at the most basic level between the two
disciplines. Uh so Remy you did not say
anything yet. Do you do you want to wait
in on this issue
>> specific? Uh yeah, no I do not have that
much to add but thank you very much for
for giving me the opportunity to to
intervene. Um I I uh I I wanted to come
back like I'm a mere philosopher so I
don't know much about empirical
applications of vector inference but I
was wondering um so so ma you said
earlier that uh there's a potential for
better predictions uh in social sciences
with active inference.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh yeah. Okay. Sorry the Okay. So yeah.
So I do you know if there's like work
that are that is it just like we're
we're thinking that there might be
better prediction or do you know if
there's there there's current work in
social sciences that use accurate and
that yield better predictability
uh do you do you have any I would be
very very curious to see if we have this
additional benefit of active inference
in in the social sciences. Um yeah,
anything that relates to social systems
I know but it's generally used in
industry right um so for example the
company versus which I'm part of uses it
to do market predictions um I know that
Connor had done a lot of simulations for
social groups one of our simulations was
about predicting opinion dynamics within
um within social media um we're being
approached by multiple companies to do
say um marketing trends etc. So it's
it's just that um I think what's missing
a little bit
um is
heavy work on empirical validation. Part
of the benefit of active inference is it
can be leveraged by one person. So you
can get into your computer make a little
simulation and it has some degree of
validity because you can reproduce an
existing phenomenon. But
gathering a lot of data is really
expensive. So we're still missing large
scale studies of the kind. But Ryan
Smith is doing such studies right now.
Um and he is getting predictabil
predictability. So it's not that it's
not happening. It's that these are the
kinds of coalitions that take a lot of
funding, a lot of coordinated efforts
and ultimately the things which social
sciences are good at which is taking
measurements of
given social groups.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Might just um briefly add to that too
that uh I agree with a lot of mouse
points. there does need to be a lot more
uh empirical data collection. And so
what I like just coming from the kind of
computational social science side uh I
see the strong division between those
who would use something like agent-based
modeling and recreating dynamics uh
which are some of the things we've kind
of talked about here today and then on
the other hand there are those who are
only looking at very large like kind of
big data level volumes of data um
textual corpus uh looking at a lot of um
downloaded X or tweet data or otherwise.
And so you get this weird division
between like natural language processing
over here versus like kind of recreating
essentially dynamics that come out of
physics um numerically. And so I I would
love to see more of an integration
between those two kinds of perspectives.
I can't say precisely how that should
happen, but I only say all of this
because I think that there are a lot of
social scientific theories that maybe
haven't been able to see their day per
se because someone hasn't been able to
simulate something or test it on data or
otherwise. So, I I think that active
inference here at least gives us the
framework to start doing that. Um,
again, we just we need to really build
out the the toolkit, uh, so to speak,
and and get more people involved and
feeling capable that they can sit down
at their computer, give something a
shot, and publish their results so we
can keep this going.
>> Uh, yeah. So, I would, uh, want to get
back on what you just said about based
modeling versus, uh, big data analysis.
I would say that act in France gives us
a very strong ground to believe that uh
sorry me could you cut the audio I can
hear people behind you I think
>> thank you uh so I would say it gives us
a very strong ground that cognition is
contextual in a practical sense that it
depends on context and uh therefore I
would place much more faith into
detailed agent based analysis of
specific phenomena to reconstruct I
don't know dynamics of influence ritual
of power in network etc etc. Uh then we
could have in a very large physical
analysis because your stats will be
based on a very great variety of context
none of which understands and for which
you have no appur reason whatsoever to
believe that it generalizes. Uh so it's
a problem with experimental methodology.
We never test for erodicity. ever test
that the uh effect that we measure is
invariant between populations and I
would contend that most of the time it
is in fact not and so I think we I think
we need to move toward much more
detailed qualitative analysis of uh how
people think things and I think we need
to move to models approaches to
computational methodology that reflect
that and that's more in the agent based
modeling brand than it is in the data
analysis uh strictly speaking
you're still muted.
>> Yeah.
>> Can't hear you.
>> This is a different topic. I'm going off
a bit. Um but in in a number of the
presentations people talked about how
um active inference can explain why um
non-adaptive or maladaptive belief
systems are maintained I think
especially in Mao's talk but I'm
wondering what the definition of
adaptive and maladaptive is in that
context because of course for the
individual it's adaptive because you
need to um respect the norms of your
community or the the prevalent
ideologies in order to succeed in that
community. So are you in you know is it
um is the idea that the group becomes
the the group becomes the um unit of
analysis here. So that uh it's it's a
maladaptive group because um in the long
run say the ideology gets the group to
deplete natural resources at a at a rate
that threatens its sustainability or
something like that or is there some
kind of normative um background that's
being presumed in claims that these
beliefs are maladaptive where you're
just saying they're just wrong. it's
wrong to uh to treat women differently
from men or something like that. So, uh
yeah, I'm just wondering what the
thoughts your thoughts are on that those
sorts of questions.
>> Yeah. So, I've given this actually quite
a bit of thought. Um I don't have a
formal answer, but I have a thread of
research that aims in that direction. Um
and I think you have to think of it in
terms of paths and scale of paths. uh
and something we're developing with
David Highland and Dalton Shakivel and
Alex Kefir uh and other people from uh
the empowerment literature is and and
Ben Girtzil as well
there are
paths on a given time scale
which are irreversible.
So, for example, uh if you jump off a
cliff, even if you're in the middle of
jumping off the cliff and you're not
dead yet, effectively
you can't come back from that. That's
that's an irreversible irreversible
path. And so whilst not everything is as
um obvious as that, you can sort of
couch your paths a little bit like um
like a like fineman uh paths where you
can see there's a probability
distribution over certain paths and then
uh the the probability distribution
means that somewhat they're they're most
likely connected, right? There's a
there's a probability of going from one
path to the other. closer they are and
the closer they are the more likely they
are you know to be um uh under the same
distribution.
Uh and so
before knowing what a good path is if we
apply some normative aspect to it there
still are some paths you know cannot be
returned from and some paths you know
have a a high ability to be um flexible
so you can go from one to the other. So
assume you don't know what a good path
is. You still know that if you go in
that direction, you're most likely to be
able to switch. If you if you were
wrong, then if you go in that direction
where you will not be able to switch and
if you're wrong, you're you're you're a
bit And so that's that's the
difference between like a rigid path and
a flexible path. So we can we can sort
of take this as a as a sort of
um
metric that doesn't have any veilance to
it. Now considering scales of interest
let's consider that on my life alone I
can make a judgment of suffering say
based on suffering well okay well my
life will probably suffer less if I max
out on one thing but if I look at a
larger scale and say my children or my
children's children or whatever and
that's usually the uh the kind of uh
thought process that um long- termists
take um yes I could max about my benefit
through like convenience uh reality that
we take right now but I'm depleting all
the resources for everybody else and so
again this notion of path yes my path is
still somewhat flexible but on a larger
scale um that path also entails that
their paths are now extremely rigid they
have no other possibilities afterwards
because their resources are depleted so
you have to consider scale of concern as
well and then the last thing is
functionality like it is true that um
some beliefs can be maintained without
losing a degree of functionality if you
are not actively acting on those
beliefs. So there are scales of beliefs
that are differently related to your
day-to-day life. And I'm going to use an
example and it's that it's potentially
um um sorry controversial, but if you
believe angels exist and that if you
jump off a bridge an angel will catch
you, you will die. No angel will catch
you. We can test this like it's it's
testable, but if you hold that belief
with high precision and you take some
actions based on it, you will die. But
there are people in the world today that
hold a belief that is somewhat related
to that if not that. The thing is they
sort of shelter themselves from areas
where they actually have to act on those
beliefs. So if you believe the earth if
you believe the earth is flat, you
probably shouldn't be an aerospace
engineer.
>> And it so it turned out that most of
them aren't aerospace engineers. So they
can maintain such beliefs in a form in a
sort of normative way without them being
dysfunctional. But that means they are
limited to that sphere of reality. So
all of these three things together I
think lead us to beliefs which can be
more or less maladaptive
regardless of the cultural context which
would qualify certain beliefs as adapt
as adaptive. Then you can talk about
just existing within a social context.
Relative to a social context, walking
around naked is maladaptive. Now, it
holds no value other than you will
probably incur social um social
consequences along the lines of what
Remy was saying. And if you live in
Canada, you'll probably like me have
issues if you walk outside naked. But if
you live in, I don't know, somewhere
really warm and nice, then the only the
only issue is social. So perhaps you're
only maladaptive relative to the current
um context of the group.
>> Could I just quickly respond to that uh
before people go? Yeah. So I I really
love that and I especially like the
first idea that uh it's uh without
committing to any particular normative
uh preferences it's better to have open
paths than than committed paths is kind
of fallibleism. It's a very minimal sort
of um and plausible uh constraint on on
uh what is adaptive certainly. But uh my
worry is that there might be situations
where just
false beliefs basically are extremely
adaptive because
our most important decision- making is
social. And so we uh it's not just a
matter of you know you might get some
sanctioning in the way or um Remy
suggests but literally like um life and
death decisions decisions affecting our
biological fitness, who to trust and who
not to trust, being able to to to uh
find uh mating partners. All of these
things rely essentially on having
beliefs which are complimentary to uh
those of members in your society and and
that could be anything right I mean if
in order to get a partner a life partner
you have to believe that men's and
women's roles men and women are sort of
naturally suited for specific kinds of
roles and that is it doesn't really
matter if that belief is um uh um false
or anything like that. All that matters
is that it matches the beliefs that it
complements the beliefs of of the
available pool, right, of people you
have to interact with. And that seems to
be a case where uh you can have very
false beliefs equivalent to a flat
earth, but they're not quarantined from
action. they're actually they're
actually involved in action because all
that matters is that other people have
equally absurd beliefs. Yeah. For for
those sorts of social actions. And I
guess that's the that's the case that
I'm most interested in. Um all right.
>> Okay.
>> Andrew,
>> you all just covered a lot of ground, so
I'll try to keep it short, but this is a
very interesting piece on the
maladaptive versus adaptive. And I do
think that both of them seem to entail
the dimension of time. And so we're
talking about something changing and it
can become very abstract where like okay
well anything that changes based upon
like some kind of mutual interaction and
relationship with things around it
influences must be adapting whatever
that means. And so yeah, I do think that
to say something is adaptive expressly
as as opposed to being maladaptive is to
apply some kind of criteria for how you
can judge like how well something
adapted or something. Um part of what
brought me to active inference aside
from a few dozen other reasons was uh an
interest in in mental health and
clinical care. That's the computational
psychiatry project there uh that I
showed earlier. And uh one so one take
on the idea of adaptive versus smile
adaptive is if an individual themsself
expresses a personal disturbance with
how their life has been and they notice
it's coming from certain kinds of things
that don't appear to be immediately
external to them. That is they are
advocating for themsel I am having a
problem then it suddenly becomes a
little bit more potentially like ethical
or reasonable to apply the word
maladaptive. Oh, there's something
maladaptive that their life is being led
in a direction or I guess we could say a
path that they themselves don't like
that that that is harmful to them in
some way, shape or form. Right? So, so
that's one take on that kind of divide.
Um and and it's so difficult as social
scientists whenever we want to make
these kinds of divisions, right? because
we're immediately hit with like well
aren't you just agreeing with one
particular set of norms when something
is adaptive rather than my adaptive
right and why are your norms better than
my norms or what the norms I think
should exist right so it's just we're
we're scientists within the phenomena
that we are trying to study and it's so
tricky so I don't know if I gave a lot
of useful material there but I hope it
is helpful in some way
>> so we'll need to uh close this out sadly
for logistical reasons.
Uh I just want to say one thing. Um I
think when we talk about adaptive and
maladaptive what we tend to imagine is
some kind of utility theory, rational
choice theory of decision because this
is what uh I don't know about the rest
but at least the western cannon has
theorized for thousands of years and we
think that we infer belief somewhat
rationally and then from this belief we
infer uh desired actions somewhat
rationally and this is not how people uh
work. So Tadus uh described in my
opinion very uh relevantly the social
meaning of beliefs. There is a social
value to being believed as a to being
perceived as a flatters person. And so
maybe there is interest to talk about
flatters and this is something that is
that has been studied by these school
senses for decades. Actually I think the
most revealing thing I've uh come across
well I'm doing hyperbole now but uh
something very interesting is the study
of authoritarian personality by adorno
uh Frankurt school which is by all right
someone I should be sworn to kill
because I'm not into Frankfort but um
which so the point I'm getting at is
that you have uh authoritan
personalities are by the studies uh
people from very authoritarian families
and there is always the double discourse
of oh yeah my father was great it was
the best of fathers well sometimes the
ex spoiled and he told me it was my
fault and then he beat me in the belt
and then he locked me in a room that was
dark and then I starved but you know
he's a father he's the best there is a
way in which uh violence is not only
naturalized but presented as a sign of
goodness and this is because within a
society and a small society of family
that is uh this violence you you'd
rather agree with that and so you
integrate it as the normal way of doing
things and as uh mostly already pointed
out norms are not there is no clear
distinction between what is normative
and what is uh descriptive. So the norms
that you integrate, what you believe the
world is is what you believe the world
must be. At least this is uh what modes
of behavior your attention uh will be
tuned towards. And I want to very
quickly point out one political
philosopher, my favorite contemporary
political philosopher um which is uh yes
I want to do that which is
Washington
>> and uh he pointed out in my opinion very
very very accurately that uh in
authoritarian systems that I'm
interested in as anyone that has open
news since 2016 understands why Um in
this context uh the role of propaganda
is not to affect beliefs because you
cannot just yell at people to believe
the earth is flat. They will maybe stop
answering you but they will not change
beliefs. What's the goal of propaganda
is to change what uh public discourse is
accepted. What you think you can say
without getting bad things happen to
you. And with four reasons that are uh
very much related to inference, what you
kind of behavior you expect yourself
publically will cut very closely to what
you believe to be the case. And I think
that's that little tiny thread that
comes from the solution of the directive
inference. Uh it is something that is
very strong. It's something that's very
robust. This is something that is uh
basically what we can bring to social
science as a cognitivist that have a
strong interest in active inference and
that understand how this kind of thing
work because not only we have some kind
of conceptual thread that has a very
high level of validity. Uh but also we
have a way to model it and to uh
translate it into specific computational
hypothesis and specific frameworks to
interpret uh evidence. So this is uh yes
I did not want to articulate closing
thoughts but we are closing at the time
articulate my thoughts. So I guess this
will work as a closing thoughts
uh I'd like to thank you all for the
opportunity to talk today. I'd like to
thank in particular Mao for uh helping
me with recording well for recording the
session and hereby helping me organizing
it. It was a pleasure talking to you and
I hope we have some opportunity to uh
get things get a little deeper at some
point in the near future. We will uh
stay in touch. So thank you and thanks
to our audience for bearing with our
rants about mathematics and commitive
sense.
>> Thank you.
Thank you.